This is the 99% of us will breakdown of the power broker. I'm Roman Mars. And I'm Elliot Kaelin. So today we are finishing part 6, The Lust for Power, and finally beginning part 7, The Loss of Power. That's chapters 39-41, pages 895-983. Later on in this episode, our special guest is Clara Jeffrey. Clara is the editor-in-chief of Mother Jones and the Center for Investigative Reporting, which produces the fantastic radio show and podcast Reveal. You should definitely subscribe to Reveal.
This is the 99% of us will breakdown of the power broker. I'm Roman Mars. And I'm Elliot Kaelin. So today we are finishing part 6, The Lust for Power, and finally beginning part 7, The Loss of Power. That's chapters 39-41, pages 895-983. Later on in this episode, our special guest is Clara Jeffrey. Clara is the editor-in-chief of Mother Jones and the Center for Investigative Reporting, which produces the fantastic radio show and podcast Reveal. You should definitely subscribe to Reveal.|||这是《权力的经纪人》99%的人会崩溃解析。我是罗曼·马尔斯。我是埃利奥特·卡林。所以今天我们要完成第六部分“对权力的渴望”，并终于开始第七部分“权力的丧失”。也就是第39至41章，第895至983页。在这集节目稍后，我们的特别嘉宾是克拉拉·杰弗里。克拉拉是《琼斯母亲》杂志和调查报道中心的总编辑，该中心制作了极棒的广播节目和播客《揭秘》。你绝对应该订阅《揭秘》。
It's fantastic. She had a long and storied career editing works of investigative journalism that speaks truth to power and afflicts the comfortable, all the good stuff. So she brings that perspective to her understanding of the Power Broker. What is especially fun to me is that I've known Clara for a long time. She hadn't read the Power Broker before and this podcast inspired her to pick it up and read it along with us. So she is truly one of us. And a special thanks to everyone who came out to our live event with Robert Caro in
It's fantastic. She had a long and storied career editing works of investigative journalism that speaks truth to power and afflicts the comfortable, all the good stuff. So she brings that perspective to her understanding of the Power Broker. What is especially fun to me is that I've known Clara for a long time. She hadn't read the Power Broker before and this podcast inspired her to pick it up and read it along with us. So she is truly one of us. And a special thanks to everyone who came out to our live event with Robert Caro in|||太棒了。她有着长期且传奇的职业生涯，编辑过许多向强权说真话、让养尊处优者感到不安的调查新闻作品，全是这些好东西。因此，她将这种视角带入了对《权力的经纪人》的理解中。对我来说特别有趣的是，我认识克拉拉很久了。她以前没读过《权力的经纪人》，而这个播客激励她拿起来和我们一起读。所以她真的是我们的一员。特别感谢所有来到我们在纽约与罗伯特·卡罗的现场活动现场的每个人……
New York, the New York Historical Society. What an amazing thing. What a dream come true. I felt so grateful and excited to be on that stage with him. And it would made it even more exciting was that you were there too. Thank you for bringing your excitement and your energy and your interest and yourselves. We had a great time. I hope you did too. So on the last episode of the 99% visible breakdown of the power broker, Robert Caro
New York, the New York Historical Society. What an amazing thing. What a dream come true. I felt so grateful and excited to be on that stage with him. And it would made it even more exciting was that you were there too. Thank you for bringing your excitement and your energy and your interest and yourselves. We had a great time. I hope you did too. So on the last episode of the 99% visible breakdown of the power broker, Robert Caro|||在纽约，纽约历史协会。多么了不起的事啊。简直是梦想成真。能和他在那个舞台上，我感到无比感激和兴奋。更让人兴奋的是，你们也在那里。谢谢你们带来了你们的兴奋、你们的活力、你们的兴趣以及你们自己。我们度过了一段美好的时光。希望你们也是。所以在上一集《权力的经纪人》的99%可见解析中，罗伯特·卡罗
took us on a lavish, luxurious trip to Jones Beach so we could see what it was like to be wined and dined by Robert Moses. And then we watched him ram one mile of expressway through a Bronx neighborhood, needlessly destroying it and bringing misery to the many lives of its occupants in the process. It was a real roller coaster of an episode. It was a real, here's the good news, here's the bad news about Robert Moses. Truly. And today we'll be covering chapters 39 through 41,
took us on a lavish, luxurious trip to Jones Beach so we could see what it was like to be wined and dined by Robert Moses. And then we watched him ram one mile of expressway through a Bronx neighborhood, needlessly destroying it and bringing misery to the many lives of its occupants in the process. It was a real roller coaster of an episode. It was a real, here's the good news, here's the bad news about Robert Moses. Truly. And today we'll be covering chapters 39 through 41,|||带我们进行了一次奢华的琼斯海滩之旅，让我们看看被罗伯特·摩西盛情款待是什么感觉。然后我们看着他将一英里长的高速公路硬生生地穿过布朗克斯的一个社区，在过程中无谓地摧毁了它，并给那里居民的众多生活带来了苦难。这真是一集像过山车一样的节目。这真的是一集“关于罗伯特·摩西的好消息在这里，坏消息在这里”的节目。真的。今天我们将讨论第39到41章，
that's pages 895 through 983 in my copy of the book. At this point in the story, Robert Moses is at the height of his power and control, but that doesn't mean it's always going to be that way. We're gonna be finishing part six, the lust for power and beginning to move into part seven, the loss of power. We have arrived. Not quite Roman, we've still gotta get through this episode.
that's pages 895 through 983 in my copy of the book. At this point in the story, Robert Moses is at the height of his power and control, but that doesn't mean it's always going to be that way. We're gonna be finishing part six, the lust for power and beginning to move into part seven, the loss of power. We have arrived. Not quite Roman, we've still gotta get through this episode.|||也就是我手头这本书的第895到第983页。在故事的这个阶段，罗伯特·摩西正处于他权力和控制的巅峰，但这并不意味着情况永远会这样。我们将完成第六部分“对权力的渴望”，并开始进入第七部分“权力的丧失”。我们到了。还没呢，罗曼，我们还得熬过这一集。
That's right, that's right. Midway through this, we're gonna turn the corner. Yes, power will begin to be lost. Not as quickly as we might like it. No, not as quickly to turn the corner. Yes. Power will begin to be lost. Not as quickly as we might like it. No, not as quickly as you might want it. But keep in mind, this also happened a long time ago. It's all over. So it did happen.
That's right, that's right. Midway through this, we're gonna turn the corner. Yes, power will begin to be lost. Not as quickly as we might like it. No, not as quickly to turn the corner. Yes. Power will begin to be lost. Not as quickly as we might like it. No, not as quickly as you might want it. But keep in mind, this also happened a long time ago. It's all over. So it did happen.|||没错，没错。在这中间，我们将迎来转折。是的，权力将开始流失。可能没有我们希望的那么快。不，转折没那么快。是的。权力将开始流失。可能没有我们希望的那么快。不，没有你想要的那么快。但请记住，这也是很久以前发生的事了。都结束了。所以它确实发生了。
That's right. Okay, so we're going to start with Chapter 39, The Highwayman. What are we going to cover in The Highwayman? So in The Highwayman, we're starting the first of a duology of chapters. We saw that trilogy of chapters in the last episode that were centered around specifically East Tremont, the neighborhood in the Bronx where the cross Bronx Expressway is just being shoved right through against all reason and rationality. These two chapters, they're going to build beautifully yet frighteningly off of those previous two, going from this microcosm of one mile of the Bronx, and now he's going to widen out his focus,
That's right. Okay, so we're going to start with Chapter 39, The Highwayman. What are we going to cover in The Highwayman? So in The Highwayman, we're starting the first of a duology of chapters. We saw that trilogy of chapters in the last episode that were centered around specifically East Tremont, the neighborhood in the Bronx where the cross Bronx Expressway is just being shoved right through against all reason and rationality. These two chapters, they're going to build beautifully yet frighteningly off of those previous two, going from this microcosm of one mile of the Bronx, and now he's going to widen out his focus,|||没错。好的，我们要从第39章《江洋大盗》开始。我们将在《江洋大盗》中讨论什么？在《江洋大盗》中，我们开始了双部曲章节中的第一部分。我们在上一集中看到了围绕东特雷蒙特展开的那三章，那是布朗克斯的一个社区，跨布朗克斯高速公路不顾一切理性和逻辑，硬生生地穿过了那里。这两章将在前两章的基础上，以一种优美而又可怕的方式展开，从布朗克斯一英里的这个微观世界出发，现在他将扩大他的焦点，
Caro is, to show how that is just one part of a larger Moses plan, which will, deliberately or not, foreclose the future comfort, convenience, and quality of life for generations of New Yorkers and Long Islanders. He's like, oh, it's terrible how the, you know, 1500 families got really hurt by this. Now it's everybody. It's such a, such a sudden jump to a wider scale. And I have to assume that the title of this chapter, it's never made explicitly clear, but I have to assume it's reference to the double meaning of highwayman, not just a man devoted to highways, but literally a highwayman, the old fashioned sense of a robber who stops people on the road
Caro is, to show how that is just one part of a larger Moses plan, which will, deliberately or not, foreclose the future comfort, convenience, and quality of life for generations of New Yorkers and Long Islanders. He's like, oh, it's terrible how the, you know, 1500 families got really hurt by this. Now it's everybody. It's such a, such a sudden jump to a wider scale. And I have to assume that the title of this chapter, it's never made explicitly clear, but I have to assume it's reference to the double meaning of highwayman, not just a man devoted to highways, but literally a highwayman, the old fashioned sense of a robber who stops people on the road|||卡罗想要展示的是，这只是摩西宏大计划的一部分，无论是有意还是无意，这个计划将剥夺几代纽约人和长岛人未来的舒适、便利和生活质量。他就像是在说，哦，你知道，1500个家庭因此受到真正的伤害，这太糟糕了。现在是所有人了。这是一个多么突然的、扩大到更大规模的跳跃。我不得不假设这一章的标题——虽然从未明确说明——但我必须假设它是指“highwayman”的双重含义，不仅仅是一个致力于公路的人，而字面意思就是一个公路强盗，也就是老派意义上的那个在路上拦住行人
and steals their valuables. And he is here showing Moses to be someone who is stealing time, enjoyment, quality of life from the lives of commuters and stealing the future from as yet unborn generations of New York metropolitan residents. Yeah, it's not only a widening in scope of geography, it's really a widening scope of time
and steals their valuables. And he is here showing Moses to be someone who is stealing time, enjoyment, quality of life from the lives of commuters and stealing the future from as yet unborn generations of New York metropolitan residents. Yeah, it's not only a widening in scope of geography, it's really a widening scope of time|||并偷走他们贵重物品的强盗。他在这里把摩西描绘成一个从通勤者的生活中窃取时间、享受和生活质量的人，并从尚未出生的纽约大都市居民几代人手中窃取未来。是的，这不仅是地理范围的扩大，实际上也是时间的扩大，
that he is going to fuck up New York so much Yeah, it's not only a widening scope of geography, it's really a widening scope of time that he is going to fuck up New York so much and that you cannot unfuck it. You know what I mean? Like it really is like it's going to last forever for decades, maybe forever. And that's the scope of these two chapters. So where in time are we starting here? So we start by jumping back in time to July 3rd, 1945, when the first new civilian car made in the United States since February of 1942 rolls off the
that he is going to fuck up New York so much Yeah, it's not only a widening scope of geography, it's really a widening scope of time that he is going to fuck up New York so much and that you cannot unfuck it. You know what I mean? Like it really is like it's going to last forever for decades, maybe forever. And that's the scope of these two chapters. So where in time are we starting here? So we start by jumping back in time to July 3rd, 1945, when the first new civilian car made in the United States since February of 1942 rolls off the|||他将把纽约搞得一团糟。是的，这不仅是地理范围的扩大，实际上也是时间的扩大，他将把纽约搞得一团糟，而且你无法挽回。你知道我的意思吗？就像它真的会永远持续几十年，也许是永远。这就是这两章的范围。那么我们在这里从时间的哪个时间点开始呢？所以我们从时间倒流到1945年7月3日开始，当时自1942年2月以来美国制造的第一辆全新民用汽车驶下了
Ford assembly line. We're all so, and this is this not to get off the point almost immediately, but I was astounded seeing this again. It's just such a sign of how single-minded and goal-oriented the United States was during World War II that for three years there were no new cars basically. All auto plants were making military armaments for three years and the idea that the country could ever be that devoted to its single goal is astonishing and inspiring to me and someday maybe we'll have that sense
Ford assembly line. We're all so, and this is this not to get off the point almost immediately, but I was astounded seeing this again. It's just such a sign of how single-minded and goal-oriented the United States was during World War II that for three years there were no new cars basically. All auto plants were making military armaments for three years and the idea that the country could ever be that devoted to its single goal is astonishing and inspiring to me and someday maybe we'll have that sense|||福特装配线。我们都……而且这并不是要立刻扯远，但我再次看到这个时感到震惊。这真是二战期间美国如何一心一意、目标导向的一个迹象，整整三年基本上没有新车。所有汽车厂都在制造军火三年，国家竟然能如此专注于一个单一目标，这个想法让我感到震惊和鼓舞，也许有一天我们也会有那种目标感。
of purpose again. Maybe we don't won't have to fight the worst war in the history of the world. That's not great. Yeah, and hopefully not eat organ meat. I mean, I'm fine with that part. I mean, it's as long as it's prepared well, but we can talk about that later. But now it's 1945, the war's over, gas rationing is over. People wanna buy cars, they wanna drive cars.
of purpose again. Maybe we don't won't have to fight the worst war in the history of the world. That's not great. Yeah, and hopefully not eat organ meat. I mean, I'm fine with that part. I mean, it's as long as it's prepared well, but we can talk about that later. But now it's 1945, the war's over, gas rationing is over. People wanna buy cars, they wanna drive cars.|||也许我们不必打人类历史上最糟糕的战争。那可不太好。是的，希望也不用吃内脏。我的意思是，我能接受那部分。我是说，只要做得好就行，不过我们以后再谈这个。但现在是1945年，战争结束了，汽油配给制结束了。人们想买车，想开车。
They wanna do it as much as they want. And what does that lead to, Roman? Within weeks, what is the result of people wanting cars and wanting to drive them, they want to do it as much as they want. And what does that lead to Roman within weeks? What is the result of people wanting cars and wanting to drive them all the time? That there is street congestion, just streets filled with cars, not moving. Yeah. It's that old law we've talked about a lot. If people have the opportunity to drive cars on roads, too many of them will decide to do that and the roads will not be able to handle it.
They wanna do it as much as they want. And what does that lead to, Roman? Within weeks, what is the result of people wanting cars and wanting to drive them, they want to do it as much as they want. And what does that lead to Roman within weeks? What is the result of people wanting cars and wanting to drive them all the time? That there is street congestion, just streets filled with cars, not moving. Yeah. It's that old law we've talked about a lot. If people have the opportunity to drive cars on roads, too many of them will decide to do that and the roads will not be able to handle it.|||他们想怎么开就怎么开。罗曼，这会导致什么结果呢？在几周之内，人们想要汽车并想开车的愿望会导致什么结果？他们想怎么开就怎么开。罗曼，这在几周内会导致什么结果？人们想要汽车并总是想开车的最终结果是什么？那就是街道拥堵，街道上挤满了汽车，一动不动。是的。这就是我们经常谈论的那条老规律。如果人们有机会在道路上开车，会有太多的人决定这么做，而道路将无法承受。
And the Herald Tribune, it runs an editorial asking why the city government isn't doing enough to solve this traffic. And Robert Moses responds with a letter that is such, it's such classic Robert Moses writing, but I just wanted to read a little bit of it just for fun. Cause I just, I'm enjoying his style. And he says, what has New York done about street congestion? Bless your little journalistic hearts, a hell of a lot. And why sit we idly by without further plans
And the Herald Tribune, it runs an editorial asking why the city government isn't doing enough to solve this traffic. And Robert Moses responds with a letter that is such, it's such classic Robert Moses writing, but I just wanted to read a little bit of it just for fun. Cause I just, I'm enjoying his style. And he says, what has New York done about street congestion? Bless your little journalistic hearts, a hell of a lot. And why sit we idly by without further plans|||《先驱论坛报》发表了一篇社论，质问为什么市政府没有采取足够措施来解决这种交通问题。罗伯特·摩西回了一封信，这真是太典型的罗伯特·摩西式的写作了，但我只是想读一小段图个乐。因为我挺喜欢他的风格的。他说，纽约为街道拥堵做过什么？保佑你们这些小记者心肠，做了老鼻子多了。为什么我们还要袖手旁观，没有针对大塞车的进一步计划，
for the big jam, singing who threw the whiskey in the well while up in the roaring forties, editors are cutting up tires into rubber heels. Tush, tush, the blueprints are oozing from our files and spilling over the floors. And I just wanna say, I love this. Everyone in the forties, when they're writing stuff, they turn into Stanley.
for the big jam, singing who threw the whiskey in the well while up in the roaring forties, editors are cutting up tires into rubber heels. Tush, tush, the blueprints are oozing from our files and spilling over the floors. And I just wanna say, I love this. Everyone in the forties, when they're writing stuff, they turn into Stanley.|||唱着“谁把威士忌扔进了井里”，而在喧嚣的四十年代，编辑们正在把轮胎切成橡胶鞋跟。嗤，嗤，蓝图正从我们的档案柜里渗出来，溢满地板。我只想说，我太喜欢这个了。四十年代的每个人，在写东西的时候，都变成了斯坦利。
Like they just like Stanley at his most trying to be poetic yet also irreverent at the same time. This is, I love it. It's so of the time and it's like Robert Moses should have been like a columnist. That's what he should have been doing. Totally, not dot penning those racy novels, but it's just been replying to.
Like they just like Stanley at his most trying to be poetic yet also irreverent at the same time. This is, I love it. It's so of the time and it's like Robert Moses should have been like a columnist. That's what he should have been doing. Totally, not dot penning those racy novels, but it's just been replying to.|||就像他们一样，就像极力想表现得富有诗意却又同时大不敬的斯坦利。这真是……我太喜欢了。太符合那个时代了，感觉罗伯特·摩西就应该当个专栏作家。这才是他该干的。完全是这样，而不是去写那些低俗的小说，而只是在回复……
It makes you wanna read that romance novel he wrote so badly just to see what crazy turns of phrase were in there. And his solution to everything is just building more roads, that's it. Yes. And maybe more parking garages, that's it. Yeah, and the parking garages are the new aspect.
It makes you wanna read that romance novel he wrote so badly just to see what crazy turns of phrase were in there. And his solution to everything is just building more roads, that's it. Yes, and maybe more parking garages, that's it. Yeah, and the parking garages are the new aspect.|||这让你太想读他写的那部爱情小说了，只想看看里面有什么疯狂的措辞。而他对所有问题的解决办法就是修建更多的道路，仅此而已。是的，也许还有更多的停车场，仅此而已。是的，停车场是新的方面。
He's like, hey, get this, we're not only gonna build more roads for cars, we're gonna build more places just to stuff cars. And he keeps announcing these huge plans. He's going to expand the roads he already has. He's got this project that involves at least 200 miles more worth of roads. And Tara talks about how in each decade, the 20s, the 30s, the 40s, Moses has announced a plan that seems unthinkably large. And then the next decade, he announces a plan that makes the last plan seem like a small plan.
He's like, hey, get this, we're not only gonna build more roads for cars, we're gonna build more places just to stuff cars. And he keeps announcing these huge plans. He's going to expand the roads he already has. He's got this project that involves at least 200 miles more worth of roads. And Tara talks about how in each decade, the 20s, the 30s, the 40s, Moses has announced a plan that seems unthinkably large. And then the next decade, he announces a plan that makes the last plan seem like a small plan.|||他就像是说，嘿，听着，我们不仅要为汽车修建更多道路，还要修建更多专门塞汽车的地方。他不断宣布这些庞大的计划。他打算扩大他已有的道路。他有一个项目涉及至少200英里以上的新道路。塔拉谈到，在每个十年里——20年代、30年代、40年代——摩西都曾宣布过一个大得不可思议的计划。然后到了下一个十年，他又宣布了一个让上一个计划相形见绌的小计划。
And I was recently reading Ursula K. Le Guin's book, The Lathe of Heaven, and she has a passage in it that I couldn't help but think about Robert Moses when I read it. And she says, the quality of the will to power is precisely growth. Achievement is its cancellation. To be the will to power must increase
And I was recently reading Ursula K. Le Guin's book, The Lathe of Heaven, and she has a passage in it that I couldn't help but think about Robert Moses when I read it. And she says, the quality of the will to power is precisely growth. Achievement is its cancellation. To be the will to power must increase|||我最近在读厄休拉·K·勒古恩的书《天长地久》，其中有一段话让我在阅读时情不自禁地想到了罗伯特·摩西。她说，权力意志的本质正是增长。成就则是它的取消。要成为权力意志，就必须不断增加
with each fulfillment, making the fulfillment only a step to a further one. The vaster the power gained, the vaster the appetite for more." And while I was reading it, I was like, I wonder if she read The Power Broker when she was writing the science fiction novel. Or really, Ozymandias is really, that's the same principle there. You know, just like, you know, just like weeping because there's no more worlds to conquer. You just have to get bigger and bigger and bigger or this guy doesn't exist, you know. Yes. And so, and it feels like Robert Moses answers always is we need more roads, bigger roads, partly to ease traffic, but also partly because
with each fulfillment, making the fulfillment only a step to a further one. The vaster the power gained, the vaster the appetite for more." And while I was reading it, I was like, I wonder if she read The Power Broker when she was writing the science fiction novel. Or really, Ozymandias is really, that's the same principle there. You know, just like, you know, just like weeping because there's no more worlds to conquer. You just have to get bigger and bigger and bigger or this guy doesn't exist, you know. Yes. And so, and feels like Robert Moses answers always is we need more roads, bigger roads, partly to ease traffic, but also partly because|||随着每一次实现而增加，使实现本身仅仅通往下一步的阶梯。获得的权力越宏大，对更多权力的渴望就越巨大。”当我在读这段话时，我想，不知道她在写这本科幻小说时有没有读过《权力的经纪人》。或者说，奥齐曼迪亚斯其实也一样，那里遵循的是同样的原则。你知道，就像……你知道，就像因为没有更多的世界可征服而哭泣一样。你必须变得越来越大、越来越大，否则这家伙就不存在了，你知道的。是的。所以，感觉罗伯特·摩西的回答永远是我们需要更多的道路、更大的道路，部分是为了缓解交通，但部分也是因为
what's he gonna do if he stops building roads? Like what does his life mean if he stops building roads? Where does his power go? And in the 1920s and 1930s, Caro says people were really excited to see these programs completed. Now in the 40s, 1930s, Caro says, people were really excited to see these programs completed. Now in the 40s, the response is getting slightly more muted. And this is partly because urban planners have started to say with increasing urgency that you need a balance of transportation. You can't just rely on roads. You've also got to have mass transit to balance out the fact that when you build roads, there's going to be more roads. But Moses, he doesn't like mass transit. He doesn't wanna build it. He's not interested in it.
what's he gonna do if he stops building roads? Like what does his life mean if he stops building roads? Where does his power go? And in the 1920s and 1930s, Caro says people were really excited to see these programs completed. Now in the 40s, 1930s, Caro says, people were really excited to see these programs completed. Now in the 40s, the response is getting slightly more muted. And this is partly because urban planners have started to say with increasing urgency that you need a balance of transportation. You can't just rely on roads. You've also got to have mass transit to balance out the fact that when you build roads, there's more roads. But Moses, he doesn't like mass transit. He doesn't wanna build it. He's not interested in it.|||如果他停止修路，他能做什么？比如，如果他停止修路，他的人生还有什么意义？他的权力去哪了？在20世纪20年代和30年代，卡罗说人们对看到这些项目完成感到非常兴奋。现在在40年代，1930年代，卡罗说，人们对看到这些项目完成感到非常兴奋。现在到了40年代，反应变得稍微微弱了一些。这部分是因为城市规划者开始以越来越紧迫的语气指出，你需要交通平衡。你不能只依赖道路。你还必须有公共交通来平衡这样一个事实：当你修建道路时，道路会更多。但摩西呢，他不喜欢公共交通。他不想建。他对它不感兴趣。
And he monopolizes the construction money in the city so much that even if people were like, well, we'll build it without you, they couldn't do it. All the money is being poured into roads. And that's something that we're gonna see again and again throughout these couple of chapters is just how much he is taking from the potential of mass transit
And he monopolizes the construction money in the city so much that even if people were like, well, we'll build it without you, they couldn't do it. All the money is being poured into roads. And that's something that we're gonna see again and again throughout these couple of chapters is just how much he is taking from the potential of mass transit|||他垄断了城市的建设资金，以至于即使有人说，好吧，没有你我们自己建，他们也根本做不到。所有的资金都倾注到了道路上。这也是我们在接下来这两章中会一次又一次看到的内容，那就是他从公共交通的潜力中剥夺了多少资金，
so that you can put it into roads. Yeah. And this is really just points out again, more of Robert Moses's weakness is like, you know, Carol talks about him having a certain genius for seeing a city and carving up a city and drawing lines, but he has almost just like, I mean, rudimentary, like just a backwards notion of how systems work together. Like I think it's partly his bias towards not wanting mass transit and thinking cars are great and not realizing how cars
so that you can put it into roads. Yeah, and this is really just points out again, more of Robert Moses's weakness is like, you know, Carol talks about him having a certain genius for seeing a city and carving up a city and drawing lines, but he has almost just like, I mean, rudimentary, like just a backwards notion of how systems work together. Like I think it's partly his bias towards not wanting mass transit and thinking cars are great and not realizing how cars|||以便你可以把它投入到道路中。是的，这再次指出了罗伯特·摩西更多的弱点，你知道，卡罗谈到他有一种看清城市、划分城市和画线的某种天赋，但他对系统如何协同工作却有着几乎可以说是极其粗糙、甚至倒退的观念。我觉得这部分是因为他偏向于不想要公共交通，认为汽车太棒了，却没有意识到汽车是如何
just become functional things in people's lives through the 40s, 50s, and 60s. But I actually wonder if he's like particularly stupid in this area. You know, like because, because it just would willfully stupid because it's not that the buses or subways or light rail or trains would be good in and of themselves. They would actually make the roads he made better. If he thought more holistically about them,
just become functional things in people's lives through the 40s, 50s, and 60s. But I actually wonder if he's like particularly stupid in this area. You know, like because, because it just would willfully stupid because it's not that the buses or subways or light rail or trains would be good in and of themselves. They would actually make the roads he made better. If he thought more holistically about them,|||在40、50和60年代逐渐成为人们生活中的实用工具。但我其实在想，他是不是在这个领域特别愚蠢。你知道的，因为……因为这纯粹是装傻充愣，倒不是说公交车、地铁、轻轨或火车本身有多好。它们实际上会让他的道路变得更好。如果他能更全面地思考这些问题，
they would perform better for the people who wanted to be on them and, you know, siphon off some of the excess. And I find that particularly like interesting or kind of galling, but also just like strange that he didn't see any upside in making these things just for the benefit of Rhodes. Like you could make a case that for the benefit of just his Rhodes, you could have done these other things and made them better. I think there's, I think you're exactly, I mean, you're exactly right. And this is part of Caro's argument
they would perform better for the people who wanted to be on them and, you know, siphon off some of the excess. And I find that particularly like interesting or kind of galling, but also just like strange that he didn't see any upside in making these things just for the benefit of Rhodes. Like you could make a case that for the benefit of just his Rhodes, you could have done these other things and made them better. I think there's, I think you're exactly, I mean, you're exactly right. And this is part of Caro's argument|||它们会对那些想要使用它们的人表现得更好，并且，你知道的，分流掉一部分过剩的交通。我发现这特别有趣，或者有点令人恼火，但也觉得很奇怪，他竟然没有看到仅仅为了道路的利益而建设这些东西有什么好处。就像你可以提出这样的观点：为了他那些道路的利益，你完全可以做这些其他的事情并让它们变得更好。我认为，我觉得你完全……我的意思是，你说得完全正确。这也是卡罗论点的一部分，
that like the roads would function better if you had these mass transit systems working with them. I think I have two answers that as someone who has not studied Robert Moses as much as anyone except, I mean, as much as Robert Caro has, is I think one of them is because I don't think he really cares that much how the roads function.
that like the roads would function better if you had these mass transit systems working with them. I think I have two answers that as someone who has not studied Robert Moses as much as anyone except, I mean, as much as Robert Caro has, is I think one of them is because I don't think he really cares that much how the roads function.|||即如果这些公共交通系统与它们配合使用，道路的运转效果会更好。作为一个对罗伯特·摩西的研究不如罗伯特·卡罗那么深入的人，我觉得我有两个答案：其中一个原因我认为是因为我并不觉得他真的那么关心道路是如何运作的。
He cares about building them. And once it he really cares that much how the roads function. He cares about building them. And once it's built, he's onto the next project. Like I was saying with that lead of heaven thing, and this would be a much better place for me to put that quotation, but I already said it, is that he likes building. He doesn't like road management.
He cares about building them. And once it he really cares that much how the roads function. He cares about building them. And once it's built, he's onto the next project. Like I was saying with that lead of heaven thing, and this would be a much better place for me to put that quotation, but I already said it, is that he likes building. He doesn't like road management.|||他关心的是建造它们。一旦它……他真的那么关心道路是如何运作的。他关心的是建造它们。一旦建好，他就转向下一个项目了。就像我刚才说的那个“天长地久”的事情一样——这本来是我放那段引文的绝佳地方，但我已经说过了——那就是他喜欢建设。他不喜欢的道路管理。
You know, other people would have been fine with overseeing these enormous bridge projects and then not building other things. Like that's my monument is this bridge, but he just has to keep building. And once it's done, it's just a revenue machine for him. He doesn't really care if it's working well. He just cares about the driving numbers. But the other thing is I think we have to remember, because it gets thrown
You know, other people would have been fine with overseeing these enormous bridge projects and then not building other things. Like that's my monument is this bridge, but he just has to keep building. And once it's done, it's just a revenue machine for him. He doesn't really care if it's working well. He just cares about the driving numbers. But the other thing is I think we have to remember, because it gets thrown|||你知道，其他人监督完这些巨大的桥梁项目后，可能就心满意足不再建别的了。就像“我的纪念碑就是这座桥”，但他就是得不停地建。一旦建好，对金而言它就只是一台创收机器。他并不真正在乎它运作得好不好。他只在乎车流量。但另一件事是，我认为我们必须记住，因为人们经常提到这一点——
around a lot this, in the last episode, I think we made the mistake too. And we corrected ourselves in calling Moses an engineer that like, he's not an engineer, like his education is in civil service. Like understanding how a civil service system works and how to reform it. And a civil service is built out of people. And it's a system that's flexible because people can change. Whereas a road is not flexible.
around a lot this, in the last episode, I think we made the mistake too. And we corrected ourselves in calling Moses an engineer that like, he's not an engineer, like his education is in civil service. Like understanding how a civil service system works and how to reform it. And a civil service is built out of people. And it's a system that's flexible because people can change. Whereas a road is not flexible.|||在上一集中，我想我们也犯了同样的错误。我们在纠正自己时称摩西为工程师，其实他不是工程师，他的教育背景是公务员制度。比如理解公务员系统是如何运作的以及如何改革它。而公务员系统是由人组成的。这是一个灵活的系统，因为人是可以改变的。而道路则是不灵活的。
Once it's built, it's there. You can expand it or you can move it with great effort, but you're not dealing with people who are adaptable. And I think that's part of it. I wonder if he might be approaching construction infrastructure from the point of view of someone who thinks that it has the flexibility of a human-based system.
Once it's built, it's there. You can expand it or you can move it with great effort, but you're not dealing with people who are adaptable. And I think that's part of it. I wonder if he might be approaching construction infrastructure from the point of view of someone who thinks that it has the flexibility of a human-based system.|||一旦建好，它就在那儿了。你可以扩建它，或者花巨大气力移开它，但你面对的不是适应性强的人类。我想这也是原因之一。我在想，他对待建设基础设施的方式，会不会是出于那种认为基础设施也具备以人为本系统的灵活性的外行视角呢？
Yeah, well, but he also takes advantage of the fact that that is inflexible at a certain point, like he does steak driving later on that sort of limits any criticisms or changes that can come later on. So he counts on both sides of it. But it's just, I think that's really interesting. Like that part, like he builds it, he's done.
Yeah, well, but he also takes advantage of the fact that that is inflexible at a certain point, like he does steak driving later on that sort of limits any criticisms or changes that can come later on. So he counts on both sides of it. But it's just, I think that's really interesting. Like that part, like he builds it, he's done.|||是的，不过他也利用了基础设施在某种程度上是不灵活的这一特点，比如他后来通过钉桩来限制以后可能出现的任何批评或修改。所以他两头的好处都占了。但我觉得这真的很有趣。就像那个部分，他建好了，就完事了。
And then the only sort of value of that road is how it induces demands for more roads later on. Not that they do the thing that they're supposed to do. I mean, it's very similar to the way consumer technology works now, where a piece of electronics that you buy, it's not intended to do that job as well as possible.
And then the only sort of value of that road is how it induces demands for more roads later on. Not that they do the thing that they're supposed to do. I mean, it's very similar to the way consumer technology works now, where a piece of electronics that you buy, it's not intended to do that job as well as possible.|||然后这条路仅有的价值就在于它如何诱发了以后对更多道路的需求。而不是说它们去做了它们本该去做的事情。我的意思是，这非常类似于现在消费科技的运作方式，你买的一件电子产品，它的目的并不是尽可能好地完成那项工作。
It's intended to do it fine until it breaks and then you get the next version of it. There's that built in obsolescence and it's like, it's like the opposite end of not delivering a great product where on one end everything breaks down super fast and you have to replace it. On the other end, it doesn't work great but you can never replace it.
It's intended to do it fine until it breaks and then you get the next version of it. There's that built in obsolescence and it's like, it's like the opposite end of not delivering a great product where on one end everything breaks down super fast and you have to replace it. On the other end, it doesn't work great but you can never replace it.|||它的目的是表现得还行，直到它坏掉，然后你再去买它的下一个版本。这里面存在着内置的过时性，这就像……这就像是没能提供伟大产品的一个对立面：一端是一切都坏得超级快，你必须更换；另一端则是它运作得并不好，但你永远无法更换它。
You know, it's just, it's permanent and immortal. And he, I think he just doesn't, he doesn't care. I don't think he cares if it does a great job, partly because he's not gonna have to use it, you know, or if he does, he'll be in his office car that where someone else is driving him and he can, I would say he's gonna kick back, but he's just gonna do a lot of work in the use it, you know, or if he does, he'll be in his office car that where someone else is driving him. And he can, I would say he's gonna kick back, but he's just gonna do a lot of work in the backseat.
You know, it's just, it's permanent and immortal. And he, I think he just doesn't, he doesn't care. I don't care if it does a great job, partly because he's not gonna have to use it, you know, or if he does, he'll be in his office car that where someone else is driving him and he can, I would say he's gonna kick back, but he's just gonna do a lot of work in the backseat.|||你知道，它就是永久的、不朽的。而他，我想他只是……他根本不在乎。我不在乎它是不是干得漂亮，部分是因为他自己又不用去用它，你知道的，或者如果他用了，他也会坐在他的公务车里，由别人开车，他可以——我会说他会放松一下，但他其实会在后座上处理大量的工作。
So it's not only that he's just not building or considering mass transit in his plans. He is actively destroying mass transit in the process of building these roads. Like he's pulling up tracks. He's really just like, he's starving it of money, and he's taking advantage of this idea that this really is a system, but he's hogging up all the resources and sort of thought and leadership of this system of transit, you know, to the benefit
So it's not only that he's just not building or considering mass transit in his plans. He is actively destroying mass transit in the process of building these roads. Like he's pulling up tracks. He's really just like, he's starving it of money, and he's taking advantage of this idea that this really is a system, but he's hogging up all the resources and sort of thought and leadership of this system of transit, you know, to the benefit|||所以，这不仅在于他的计划中没有建造或考虑公共交通。他在修建这些道路的过程中，还在积极地破坏公共交通。比如他正在拆除轨道。他真的就像是在让公共交通资金枯竭，而且他利用了这是一个系统的观点，但他却独占了这个交通系统的所有资源、思想和领导权，你知道的，这一切都是为了
of just building bridges and roads. And there's ripples that lead out from that, and that's what a lot of this chapter is about about is it's not just transportation, but about the way a city is built around that transportation. And Carol started talking about how this road-based system is affecting the development of the outlying neighborhoods in New York and in Long Island, because a neighborhood developed around a subway line is going to be developing for foot traffic.
of just building bridges and roads. And there's ripples that lead out from that, and that's what a lot of this chapter is about about is it's not just transportation, but about the way a city is built around that transportation. And Carol started talking about how this road-based system is affecting the development of the outlying neighborhoods in New York and in Long Island, because a neighborhood developed around a subway line is going to be developing for foot traffic.|||仅仅建造桥梁和道路。由此引发了一系列连锁反应，这也是本章很大一部分所要讲述的内容——这不仅关乎交通，还关乎围绕这种交通建立城市的方式。卡罗开始谈到，这种以道路为主的系统是如何影响纽约和长岛外围社区的发展的，因为围绕地铁线路发展的社区是为了步行交通而发展的。
It's going to be much higher density because people need to be able to walk from the station to their homes. It's, living in Los Angeles, people are like, you should take the rail to work. And I'm like, so I drive to a parking lot and then get out at the train station and then take the train the rest of the way, come on.
It's going to be much higher density because people need to be able to walk from the station to their homes. It's, living in Los Angeles, people are like, you should take the rail to work. And I'm like, so I drive to a parking lot and then get out at the train station and then take the train the rest of the way, come on.|||它的密度会高得多，因为人们需要能够从车站步行回家。住在洛杉矶的人们总是说，你应该坐轻轨去上班。而我就觉得，所以我得开车去停车场，然后在火车站下车，再坐火车走完剩下的路，拜托。
I just don't, I wanna take the whole way. But if you are building around roads, then people are gonna need cars and the neighborhoods are gonna be zoned and developed in a way that is low density because people already have the cars. And it wouldn't be so bad if the people living in those kind of lower density,
I just don't, I wanna take the whole way. But if you are building around roads, then people are gonna need cars and the neighborhoods are gonna be zoned and developed in a way that is low density because people already have the cars. And it wouldn't be so bad if the people living in those kind of lower density,|||我才不要，我想一路坐到底。但如果你是围绕道路进行建设，那么人们就需要汽车，而且由于人们已经有了汽车，社区的规划和开发方式将会是低密度的。如果那些住在那种低密度、
more suburban parts of the city had access to jobs near where they lived. Maybe if they could walk or take a local transit to their jobs. But Moses is such an influence on how the land around his parkways is zoned and controlled. And he wants them to look beautiful and pristine. So he discourages industry from expanding out to those areas,
more suburban parts of the city had access to jobs near where they lived. Maybe if they could walk or take a local transit to their jobs. But Moses is such an influence on how the land around his parkways is zoned and controlled. And he wants them to look beautiful and pristine. So he discourages industry from expanding out to those areas,|||更偏向城市郊区的人们能够在他们住所附近找到工作，那倒也还好。也许如果他们能步行或乘坐当地交通工具去上班的话。但摩西对他的林荫大道周围土地的规划和控制有着巨大的影响力。他希望它们看起来美丽而原始。因此，他阻止工业向这些地区扩张，
which means the vast majority of these new residents in the outlying areas have to drive back into the city every day for work or take the rickety Long Island railroad. And we'll talk later about why nobody wants to do that, but he's, he's basically, uh, using his road building as a way, deliberately or not, to control how these parts of the city are developed and built
which means the vast majority of these new residents in the outlying areas have to drive back into the city every day for work or take the rickety Long Island railroad. And we'll talk later about why nobody wants to do that, but he's, he's basically, uh, using his road building as a way, deliberately or not, to control how these parts of the city are developed and built|||这意味着外围地区绝大多数新居民必须每天开车回城里上班，或者乘坐破旧的长岛铁路。我们稍后会讨论为什么没有人愿意这样做，但他基本上……呃，他正在通过修路——无论是有意还是无意——来控制城市的这些部分是如何开发和建设的，
and how the people there are gonna have to live their lives. Yeah, and it really is this positive feedback loop. And what I mean by positive feedback loop is the action amplifies the next action that amplifies the next action. And either that happens in a positive direction or negative direction. The positive part is just the amplification.
and how the people there are gonna have to live their lives. Yeah, and it really is this positive feedback loop. And what I mean by positive feedback loop is the action amplifies the next action that amplifies the next action. And either that happens in a positive direction or negative direction. The positive part is just the amplification.|||以及那里的居民将如何度过他们的生活。是的，这确实是一个正反馈循环。我所说的正反馈循环是指：一个行动会放大下一个行动，进而放大再下一个行动。无论是朝着积极的方向还是消极的方向发展。积极的部分仅仅在于这种放大作用。
It's the sort of death spiral. Yeah, it feels like it rarely happens with positive outcomes for anybody. But it isn't that a negative feedback loop will be one where the next action stops the previous action. But so this is like everything just sort of spirals away. Because of this choice, there's roads, therefore it makes low density housing,
It's the sort of death spiral. Yeah, it feels like it rarely happens with positive outcomes for anybody. But it isn't that a negative feedback loop will be one where the next action stops the previous action. But so this is like everything just sort of spirals away. Because of this choice, there's roads, therefore it makes low density housing,|||这算是一种死亡螺旋吧。是的，感觉它很少能对任何人产生积极的结果。但这并不是说负反馈循环会是一个“下一个行动阻止前一个行动”的循环。但这就像是一切都开始失控螺旋上升了。由于这种选择，有了道路，因此造就了低密度的住宅，
that means more roads and more and more of an idealized form of what could be a higher density, better, you know, served communities along Long Island are just denied. And it starts from the very beginning and just kind of builds and builds and builds on itself. Yeah, the other thing, here's the other thing about cars. All right, Roman, I'm gonna lay this on you. This might be a big shock to you.
that means more roads and more and more of an idealized form of what could be a higher density, better, you know, served communities along Long Island are just denied. And it starts from the very beginning and just kind of builds and builds and builds on itself. Yeah, the other thing, here's the other thing about cars. All right, Roman, I'm gonna lay this on you. This might be a big shock to you.|||这意味着更多的道路，而长岛沿线本可以成为高密度、服务更完善的社区的那种理想形态却被无情地剥夺了。这一切从一开始就开始了，并且在不断地自我叠加、累积、演进。是的，还有一件事，关于汽车还有另一件事。好吧，罗曼，我要跟你说这个。这可能对你是个大打击。
So you live in Long Island, your office is back in Manhattan, you gotta drive in to work. When you get to work, you gotta do something with that car. Yeah. You can't just put it in your pocket and then go into the office with it.
So you live in Long Island, your office is back in Manhattan, you gotta drive in to work. When you get to work, you gotta do something with that car. Yeah. You can't just put it in your pocket and then go into the office with it.|||所以你住在长岛，你的办公室在曼哈顿，你得开车去上班。当你到达公司时，你得把这辆车安顿好。是的。你不能把它塞进口袋里然后带进办公室。
You gotta put it somewhere. You gotta find parking. And Moses is pouring all these new cars into the city and people are like, where are we gonna put these cars? And he says, don't worry, we're gonna build these multi-story parking garages. He doesn't say this, but the implication whenever I read this part is the most beautiful thing
You gotta put it somewhere. You gotta find parking. And Moses is pouring all these new cars into the city and people are like, where are we gonna put these cars? And he says, don't worry, we're gonna build these multi-story parking garages. He doesn't say this, but the implication whenever I read this part is the most beautiful thing|||你得把它放在某处。你得找个停车位。而摩西把所有这些新车涌入城市，人们就在想，我们把这些车停在哪？他说，别担心，我们要建造这些多层停车楼。他没有这么说，但每当我读到这一部分时，其潜台词就是：这是你能给一座生活着的城市增添的最美丽的风景——
you can add to a living city, just multi-story parking garages above ground. And aside from the fact that they're hideously ugly, I apologize to anyone who owns or designs parking garages. They're just the ugliest thing you can put in a city, I imagine. The planners start to notice the city can never really park more than a fraction of the cars coming in.
you can add to a living city, just multi-story parking garages above ground. And aside from the fact that they're hideously ugly, I apologize to anyone who owns or designs parking garages. They're just the ugliest thing you can put in a city, I imagine. The planners start to notice the city can never really park more than a fraction of the cars coming in.|||也就是地上多层的停车楼。抛开它们丑陋无比这一点不谈——我向任何拥有或设计停车场的人道歉。我想它们简直是你能放进城市里的最丑陋的东西。规划者们开始注意到，城市实际上永远无法停放进城车辆的一小部分。
There isn't the space, there isn't the money to build those spots. At a certain point, you're just building a city made out of parking spots. Like there's no room for the people anymore. And this is something that is also kind of affecting and unfair for average New Yorkers. In 1945, and I think this is still the case, Carol says most New Yorkers didn't own cars. And now I think in many cases, it's a lifestyle
There isn't the space, there isn't the money to build those spots. At a certain point, you're just building a city made out of parking spots. Like there's no room for the people anymore. And this is something that is also kind of affecting and unfair for average New Yorkers. In 1945, and I think this is still the case, Carol says most New Yorkers didn't own cars. And now I think in many cases, it's a lifestyle|||根本没有空间，也没有资金来建造那些车位。在某个时间点，你只是在建造一座由停车位组成的城市。就好像再也没有空间留给人类了。这也是一件对普通纽约人来说既有影响又不公平的事情。在1945年，而且我认为现在依然如此，卡罗说大多数纽约人并不拥有汽车。现在我认为在许多情况下，这是一种生活方式的选择。
choice. Certainly when I lived in New York, I did not want the hassle of owning a car. So that's why I didn't have one. But back then, most New Yorkers could not afford to own a car. And Moses is diverting all this funding into roads and away from mass transit, leading, as we were saying, like mass transit fares rise, less people are using it, so the fares have to rise again to cover that shortfall. And money is being spent to help the few in the city who can afford to drive or from outside the city who can afford to drive and not the many who can't. And the result of that is not just that mass transit stays the same and or deteriorates slightly, but that new mass transit is not being built.
choice. Certainly when I lived in New York, I did not want the hassle of owning a car. So that's why I didn't have one. But back then, most New Yorkers could not afford to own a car. And Moses is diverting all this funding into roads and away from mass transit, leading, as we were saying, like mass transit fares rise, less people are using it, so the fares have to rise again to cover that shortfall. And money is being spent to help the few in the city who can afford to drive or from outside the city who can afford to drive and not the many who can't. And the result of that is not just that mass transit stays the same and or deteriorates slightly, but that new mass transit is not being built.|||当然，当我住在纽约时，我根本不想惹上拥有汽车的麻烦。这就是为什么我没有车。但当时，大多数纽约人根本买不起车。而摩西把所有的资金都挪到了道路建设上，远离了公共交通，正如我们刚才所说，公共交通票价上涨，使用的人变少，因此票价不得不再次上涨以弥补亏空。钱被用来帮助城市里少数买得起车的人，或者城外那些买得起车的人，而不是那些买不起车的多数人。其结果不仅是公共交通停滞不前或略有恶化，而且根本没有新的公共交通在建设。
And Kara talks about how there were plans for the fabled legendary Second Avenue subway line. Roman, you've never lived in New York, so you don't know how often this is the topic of conversation is if only we had this Second Avenue subway line. Roman, you've never lived in New York, so you don't know how often this is the topic of conversation is if only we had this second avenue subway line. Now, nearly 80 years later, it's still not fully finished yet in the way that it was talked about at the time. It was going to be this amazing line going all the way up to the city and now it goes like four extra stops on the Upper East Side, you know, and it took billions of dollars and a lot of time to get there. And Carol notes, he says,
And Kara talks about how there were plans for the fabled legendary Second Avenue subway line. Roman, you've never lived in New York, so you don't know how often this is the topic of conversation is if only we had this Second Avenue subway line. Roman, you've never lived in New York, so you don't know how often this is the topic of conversation is if only we had this second avenue subway line. Now, nearly 80 years later, it's still not fully finished yet in the way that it was talked about at the time. It was going to be this amazing line going all the way up to the city and now it goes like four extra stops on the Upper East Side, you know, and it took billions of dollars and a lot of time to get there. And Carol notes, he says,|||卡拉谈到曾有过关于传奇般的第二大道地铁线的计划。罗曼，你从未在纽约住过，所以你不知道“要是我们有这条第二大道地铁线就好了”这个话题出现的频率有多高。罗曼，你从未在纽约住过，所以你不知道“要是我们有这条第二大道地铁线就好了”这个话题出现的频率有多高。现在，将近80年过去了，它仍然没有按照当时讨论的那样完全建好。它本来应该是一条通往市中心的神奇线路，而现在它在上东区大概只多延伸了四个站，你知道的，耗费了数十亿美元和大量时间才走到这一步。卡罗指出，他说：
by building transportation facilities for the suburbs, he was ensuring that no transportation facilities would be built for the ghettos. Therefore, planners saw in the transportation field, the portion of the public helped by the use of public resources would not be the portion of the public that needed help most. So once again, like he did with parks earlier, like he did with the roads within the city.
by building transportation facilities for the suburbs, he was ensuring that no transportation facilities would be built for the ghettos. Therefore, planners saw in the transportation field, the portion of the public helped by the use of public resources would not be the portion of the public that need help most. So once again, like he did with parks earlier, like he did with the roads within the city.|||通过为郊区建设交通设施，他确保了贫民窟不会获得任何交通设施。因此，规划者在交通领域看到，通过使用公共资源而得到帮助的那部分公众，并不是最需要帮助的那部分公众。所以又一次，就像他早些时候对待公园一样，就像他对待城市内部的道路一样。
He is waiting resources towards the people who don't really need them to live their lives in the city. And the end result of this is that poor residents are cut off from the full use of their own city. There are neighborhoods that are just inaccessible for them to live in. There are parts of the city they can't get to easily. There's resources that they should be able to share in because it's part of their city and they just can't get there in an easy way. And carers make the case that it's not just that Moses through his road building is not helping these people,
He is waiting resources towards the people who don't really need them to live their lives in the city. And the end result of this is that poor residents are cut off from the full use of their own city. There are neighborhoods that are just inaccessible for them to live in. There are parts of the city they can't get to easily. There's resources that they should be able to share in because it's part of their city and they just can't get there in an easy way. And carers make the case that it's not just that Moses through his road building is not helping these people,|||他把资源倾斜给了那些在城市生活中并不真正需要这些资源的人。而这最终导致的结果是，贫困居民被剥夺了充分利用自己城市的权利。有些社区根本不适合他们居住。城市的某些部分他们无法轻易到达。有些资源本该由他们共享，因为这是他们城市的一部分，但他们就是无法以简便的方式到达那里。卡罗指出，摩西通过修路不仅没有帮助这些人，
but he is actively, maybe not deliberately hurting them by making it harder for them to take full use of this amazing city that they live in and have just as much a right to as anybody else. Yeah, yeah. And what's interesting as the number of cars has increased so much, people are starting to recognize that building more roads is not working for them. Like this is really beginning to reach the average person where they're like, I'm not buying this anymore,
but he is actively, maybe not deliberately hurting them by making it harder for them to take full use of this amazing city that they live in and have just as much a right to as anybody else. Yeah, yeah. And what's interesting as the number of cars has increased so much, people are starting to recognize that building more roads is not working for them. Like this is really beginning to reach the average person where they're like, I'm not buying this anymore,|||而且他还积极地——或许并非故意地——伤害了他们，因为他让这些人更难充分利用他们所居住的、并且拥有和任何人一样平等权利的这座伟大的城市。是的，是的。有趣的是，随着汽车数量的大幅增加，人们开始意识到修建更多的道路对他们并没有用。这真的开始触及普通人了，他们会觉得，我再也不买账了，
you know? And then the new sort of this beginning of an urbanism movement and thinkers like Lewis Mumford are presenting it and people are more actively talking about it and are more aware of it. Yeah, you start to see like letters to the editor to newspapers talking about the need to cut down on cars. The newspapers themselves don't cover this particularly much, which is something that we're gonna see
you know? And then the new sort of this beginning of an urbanism movement and thinkers like Lewis Mumford are presenting it and people are more actively talking about it and are more aware of it. Yeah, you start to see like letters to the editor to newspapers talking about the need to cut down on cars. The newspapers themselves don't cover this particularly much, which is something that we're gonna see|||你知道吗？然后这种城市主义运动的新萌芽开始出现，像刘易斯·芒福德这样的思想家也在提出这种观点，人们也更积极地讨论它，并有了更多的意识。是的，你开始看到报纸的读者来信栏目谈到需要减少汽车。报纸本身对此并没有进行太多报道，这是我们将要看到的情况——
throughout these chapters is the lack of either interest or appetite or desire in the part of the major newspaper press in covering the idea that there is a problem with trafficking the city and the problem is not just we don't have enough roads to take care of all these cars. And something that we're going to see throughout is one, this kind of failure on the parts of the papers to call real attention to this. And two, for modern readers, the continuing shock at how many newspapers were in New York at the time, which we can talk about more later. Just you read it and you're like, all these newspapers that you don't know about.
throughout these chapters is the lack of either interest or appetite or desire in the part of the major newspaper press in covering the idea that there is a problem with trafficking the city and the problem is not just we don’t have enough roads to take care of all these cars. And something that we're going to see throughout is one, this kind of failure on the parts of the papers to call real attention to this. And two, for modern readers, the continuing shock at how many newspapers were in New York at the time, which we can talk about more later. Just you read it and you're like, all these newspapers that you don't know about.|||贯穿这些章节的是主流报刊对报道“城市交通存在问题，且问题不仅仅是我们没有足够的道路来应付所有这些汽车”这一观点的缺乏兴趣、胃口或愿望。我们将一直看到的一点是，首先，报纸未能对这一点给予真正的关注。其次，对于现代读者来说，他们会持续震惊于当时纽约竟然有如此多的报纸，我们稍后可以多谈谈这一点。你只要一读就会想：天哪，有这么多你根本不知道的报纸。
And it's just you really had your choice back then. I also want to mention the, it's fun to see Lewis Mumford mentioned a couple times in this chapter. I'm a big fan of his. I love his book, The City in History. And his architectural reviews, they're like, you know, lovably curmudgeonly
And it's just you really had your choice back then. I also want to mention the, it's fun to see Lewis Mumford mentioned a couple times in this chapter. I'm a big fan of his. I love his book, The City in History. And his architectural reviews, they're like, you know, lovably curmudgeonly|||所以那时候你确实有很多选择。我还想提一下，很高兴看到刘易斯·芒福德在本章中被提及好几次。我是他的超级粉丝。我喜欢他的书《城市发展史》。他的建筑评论，你知道的，带着一种可爱的老顽固脾气，
in a way that I enjoy reading. And so like, you know, as people are recognizing that these roads are not like serving everybody, that they're not doing all they need to do, they're not really like an opposition movement that says like, build no roads. The sort of new thinking is, well, how about we build the roads, but in between that highway,
in a way that I enjoy reading. And so like, you know, as people are recognizing that these roads are not like serving everybody, that they're not doing all they need to do, they're not really like an opposition movement that says like, build no roads. The sort of new thinking is, well, how about we build the roads, but in between that highway,|||这正是我喜欢阅读的风格。所以，你知道的，当人们认识到这些道路并非在为每个人服务，它们没有发挥它们应有的全部作用时，他们并不真的像是一个高喊“不要修路”的反对派运动。这种新的思潮是：好吧，我们修路怎么样，但是在高速公路中间，
we put a train because we're gonna do it anyway. And this is like the thing, this like theoretical notion. You know, I used to, you know, the blue line in Chicago goes along the 95 in between. And it sort of makes a ton of sense. You're clearing the road, there's a middle section, it's straight, you know, like let's put a train there. But this is not ever fly on Long Island.
we put a train because we're gonna do it anyway. And this is like the thing, this like theoretical notion. You know, I used to, you know, the blue line in Chicago goes along the 95 in between. And it sort of makes a ton of sense. You're clearing the road, there's a middle section, it's straight, you know, like let's put a train there. But this is not ever fly on Long Island.|||我们修一条火车轨道，因为反正我们也要修路。这就是这种事情，这种理论上的概念。你知道的，我以前……你知道，芝加哥的蓝线沿着95号公路中间穿过。这其实非常有道理。你清理出道路，中间有一段，它是直的，你知道的，就像我们在那里修个火车轨道。但这在长岛是绝对行不通的。
No, it's true. Also in Los Angeles, there are train lines that go down the middle of freeways and they always look weird to me because I'm not used to seeing that from New York, but lots of cities have them. It's crazy. And the planners, the city planners say to Moses, look, we don't have the money to build
No, it's true. Also in Los Angeles, there are train lines that go down the middle of freeways and they always look weird to me because I'm not used to seeing that from New York, but lots of cities have them. It's crazy. And the planners, the city planners say to Moses, look, we don't have the money to build|||不，确实如此。在洛杉矶，也有火车线路穿过高速公路中间，它们在我看来总是显得很怪异，因为我从纽约来，对此很不习惯，但很多城市都有这种设计。太疯狂了。规划者们，城市规划者对摩西说，听着，我们没有资金来建造
these mass transit lines into Long Island that we'd like. It's a late 1940s. New York never has any money. America is flush with post-World War II money, but New York somehow is still, still has no money. The greatest city in the world that is always penniless, you know, always has its pockets hanging out
these mass transit lines into Long Island that we'd like. It's a late 1940s. New York never has any money. America is flush with post-World War II money, but New York somehow is still, still has no money. The greatest city in the world that is always penniless, you know, always has its pockets hanging out|||我们想要的通往长岛的公共交通线路。那是20世纪40年代末。纽约从来都没有钱。美国到处都是二战后的财富，但纽约不知怎么的，依然还是没有钱。世界上最伟大的城市却总是身无分文，你知道的，总是兜底朝天，
because there's no, there's no money and just like little moths flying out of it. But they say, look, all you have to do to make it affordable in the future for us to build those lines is as you're planning the Long Island Expressway, just, yeah, get an extra 50 more feet of right away, leave a center island so that we can build rail down there eventually. And look, it's going to lower the cost of these eventual trains. It's going
because there's no, there's no money and just like little moths flying out of it. But they say, look, all you have to do to make it affordable in the future for us to build those lines is as you're planning the Long Island Expressway, just, yeah, get an extra 50 more feet of right away, leave a center island so that we can build rail down there eventually. And look, it's going to lower the cost of these eventual trains. It's going|||因为没有钱，兜里就像有小飞蛾飞出来一样。但他们说，听着，为了让我们将来能够负担得起建设这些线路的费用，你所要做的就是在规划长岛高速公路时，顺便多争取50英尺的通行权，留出一个中央隔离带，以便我们最终能在那里修建铁路。你看，这会降低未来这些火车的成本。这会……
to lessen the disruption of the construction because it's going to be right in the middle of the road with cars on either side rather than up against people's homes. It's going to prepare the city for future development. It'll be easy, it'll be inexpensive. Carol points out the cost for all this would be borne by the city and the state, not Moses, not Triborough. You don't need federal approval. If the city doesn't do it now,
to lessen the disruption of the construction because it's going to be right in the middle of the road with cars on either side rather than up against people's homes. It's preparing the city for future development. It'll be easy, it'll be inexpensive. Carol points out the cost for all this would be borne by the city and the state, not Moses, not Triborough. You don't need federal approval. If the city doesn't do it now,|||减少建设带来的干扰，因为它将直接位于道路中间，两边都有汽车，而不是紧挨着人们的家。这是在为城市未来的发展做准备。这将很容易，也将很便宜。卡罗指出，这一切的费用将由城市和州承担，而不是由摩西承担，也不是由三区大桥局承担。你不需要联邦批准。如果城市现在不做，
you'll never be able to afford it. As you said, Roman Chicago is already doing something similar. There's literally, literally no reason at all not to do this. There is no reason not to do it, except the one reason that Moses has, which is I don't wanna do it.
you'll never be able to afford it. As you said, Roman Chicago is already doing something similar. There's literally, literally no reason at all not to do this. There is no reason not to do it, except the one reason that Moses has, which is I don't wanna do it.|||你们将永远负担不起。正如你所说，罗曼，芝加哥已经在做类似的事情了。字面意义上、绝对没有任何理由不这么做。没有任何理由不去做，除了摩西有的那唯一一个理由：我不想做。
And this is when he, Caro's got every now and then he'll introduce us to kind of like a new, what I would call a bureaucratic researcher hero. He has like his heroes who really get into research and paperwork. And he mentions F for Francis Dodd-McHugh, who's the chief of the Office of Master Planning of the City Planning Commission. And he draws up this
And this is when he, Caro's got every now and then he'll introduce us to kind of like a new, what I would call a bureaucratic researcher hero. He has like his heroes who really get into research and paperwork. And he mentions F for Francis Dodd-McHugh, who's the chief of the Office of Master Planning of the City Planning Commission. And he draws up this|||正是在这个时候，卡罗偶尔会向我们介绍一位新的、我称之为官僚研究员英雄的人物。他有一些真正深入研究和文书工作的英雄人物。他提到了弗朗西斯·多德·麦克休（Francis Dodd-McHugh），他是城市规划委员会总体规划办公室的主任。他起草了
master plan for the New York airports, where he's looking at all these new roads that Moses is planning to build to go to like Idlewild Airport, which is now JFK. And he realizes that the roads Moses building, particularly the Van Wick, it's totally inadequate for the number of people who are gonna need to go to the airport. It's inadequate, especially considering there are people who are gonna use this road who aren't going to the airport. Let's not forget about them also, there's other people.
master plan for the New York airports, where he's looking at all these new roads that Moses is planning to build to go to like Idlewild Airport, which is now JFK. And he realizes that the roads Moses building, particularly the Van Wick, it's totally inadequate for the number of people who are gonna need to go to the airport. It's inadequate, especially considering there are people who are gonna use this road who aren't going to the airport. Let's not forget about them also, there's other people.|||纽约机场的总体规划，他在规划中审视了摩西计划修建的所有通往艾德怀尔德机场（现为肯尼迪机场）的新道路。他意识到摩西修建的道路，特别是范威克高速公路，完全无法满足需要去机场的人数。这是不够的，尤其是考虑到还有一些使用这条路的人并不是去机场的。我们也不要忘记他们，还有其他人。
And Moses like, I'll widen the roads, it'll be fine. That's not gonna be sufficient either. It's tens of thousands of people above what they're actually gonna be able to carry. And once people get to Idlewild, how are they gonna get around? Where are they gonna put their cars? How are they gonna get from the parking lot to the terminal?
And Moses like, I'll widen the roads, it'll be fine. That's not gonna be sufficient either. It's tens of thousands of people above what they're actually gonna be able to carry. And once people get to Idlewild, how are they gonna get around? Where are they gonna put their cars? How are they gonna get from the parking lot to the terminal?|||而摩西则说，我会拓宽道路的，没问题的。那也依然不够。这比它们实际能够承载的人数高出几万人。一旦人们到达艾德怀尔德机场，他们将如何出行？他们把车停在哪里？他们如何从停车场前往航站楼？
And McHugh says the only real solution is some kind of big rapid transit link. Similarly, where you'd carry more people faster, you run it down the middle of the road. And Caro at one point in this, he estimates that a rapid transit trip from Penn Station in the middle of Manhattan to Idlewild Airport would take 16 minutes,
And McHugh says the only real solution is some kind of big rapid transit link. Similarly, where you'd carry more people faster, you run it down the middle of the road. And Caro at one point in this, he estimates that a rapid transit trip from Penn Station in the middle of Manhattan to Idlewild Airport would take 16 minutes,|||麦克休说，唯一的真正解决办法某种大型快速轨道交通连接。同样，如果你想更快地运送更多的人，你就把它建在道路中间。卡罗在此处的某个地方估计，从曼哈顿市中心的宾夕法尼亚车站到艾德怀尔德机场的快速交通行程将花费16分钟，
would take six minutes, which blows my mind. I can't, that's one part where I'm like, I don't know about that, I don't know. Cause right now, if you want to get from Penn Station to the airport, which I've done many times, that's a long trip. Like you're gonna have to, at some point, you have to go from the subway to the air train,
would take six minutes, which blows my mind. I can't, that's one part where I'm like, I don't know about that, I don't know. Cause right now, if you want to get from Penn Station to the airport, which I've done many times, that's a long trip. Like you're gonna have to, at some point, you have to go from the subway to the air train,|||只需要6分钟，这让我大开眼界。我不能……这是让我觉得“这我可不知道，我不知道”的一个部分。因为现在，如果你想从宾州车站去机场——我已经去过很多次了——那是一段很长的旅程。比如你必须在某个时刻从地铁换乘机场快轨。
or you have to, it's a, or you get to one of the shuttle buses. Anyway, you don't need to hear from me about how you get to the JFK airport, Penn Station, but it takes a long time. And Caro, he goes into all this detail about how relatively easy and inexpensive it would be to build those rapid transit links
或者你必须，这是一个，或者你得去坐其中一辆穿梭巴士。总之，你不需要听我唠叨怎么去肯尼迪机场或宾夕法尼亚车站，但这花的时间太长了。而卡罗深入探讨了建设这些快速交通连接会有多相对容易且便宜，
at this one point in history. While at the same time, you could use that opportunity to build a subway link between Brooklyn and Queens. He goes into a lot of detail about all this. It is such total fantasy catnip for me, certainly as a New Yorker. When I was first dating my wife, I lived in Astoria, Queens,
在历史上的这个特定时刻。与此同时，你可以借此机会在布鲁克林和皇后区之间建立一条地铁连接。他对此进行了非常详细的探讨。对于我来说，这绝对是纯粹的幻想猫薄荷，尤其是作为一个纽约人。当我第一次和我妻子约会时，我住在皇后区阿斯托里亚，
and she lived in Park Slope, Brooklyn. And the only way to get between the two was to take a train that went through Manhattan, and it took so much longer than it needed to. It's like, a couple other times later, we'll talk about points where Caro is talking about a thing that would have directly benefited my life when I lived in New York.
而她住在布鲁克林公园坡。往返两地的唯一方法是乘坐穿过曼哈顿的火车，这比实际需要的时间长得多。这就像，在稍后的其他几次中，我们会谈到卡罗所讨论的一些事情，如果它们存在的话，会直接造福我住在纽约时的生活。
And it's like you were saying, Roman earlier, that he's working on this scale, not just of geographic space, but chronological time, that he's saying this type of, this little bit of work now would in the future be so much more valuable and be worth so much more. And I tell you, Roman, I'm living proof of it, just the hours I wasted because this stuff didn't exist and McHugh says
就像你之前说的，罗曼，他在这种规模上工作，不仅是地理空间，还有时间跨度，他说这种类型的小工作在未来会变得更有价值，更有意义。我告诉你，罗曼，我就是活生生的证明，仅仅因为这些东西不存在而浪费的时间，麦克休说
Even if we don't build these transit links now same story as with the Long Island Expressway We could reserve the land for less than two million dollars This is at a time when the city is pouring 280 million dollars into Expressway construction the money the city that has no money is spending nearly three hundred million dollars on Expressway construction And she goes if we don't spend that two million dollars now We're never gonna have the chance to do this rapid transit again. And he wants to put this proposal in his plan, but he makes a mistake.
即使我们现在不建造这些交通连接——这和长岛高速公路的故事一样——我们也可以用不到两百万美元预留土地。这是在城市向高速公路建设倾注2.8亿美元的时候，一个没有钱的城市却在高速公路建设上花费近三亿美元。她说，如果我们现在不花那两百万美元，我们将永远没有机会再做这种快速交通了。他想把这个提议写进他的计划里，但他犯了一个错误。
Roman, you know what that mistake is that McHugh makes? Well, I mean, he defies Robert Moses, but he also forgets that he is a civil servant. Yeah, so he mentions it to his boss, who mentions it to Moses, and McHugh gets yelled at, the mass transit proposal is slashed from the airport plan and his salary gets slashed to the minimum and he ends up resigning from his job.
罗曼，你知道麦克休犯了什么错误吗？嗯，我的意思是，他公然挑衅罗伯特·摩西，但他同时也忘了自己是个公务员。是的，所以他把这件事提给了他的老板，老板又告诉了摩西，然后麦克休挨了训，公共交通提议被从机场计划中砍掉了，他的薪水也被削减到了最低水平，最后他辞职了。
Like it is such unnecessary retaliation from Moses. And it's all part of this big, this refusal, this refusal to share any space or any money with mass transit that at certain points almost feels like an obsession, like how Batman has all those villains that are obsessed with a specific thing. Calendar Man is all about holidays,
这简直是来自摩西的不必要的报复。这一切都是这种巨大心态的一部分，这种拒绝与公共交通分享任何空间或资金的拒绝，在某些时候几乎让人觉得是一种痴迷，就像蝙蝠侠有那些对特定事物痴迷的反派一样。钟表狂人满脑子都是节日，
and Kite Man is all about kites, and Robert Moses is all about roads. He's the Highwayman. Yeah, Highwayman, yeah, yeah. And this is another one of those things where it's like, the way that an airport functions as a spoke in a transportation system, it really only makes sense if a train goes to it.
风筝人满脑子都是风筝，而罗伯特·摩西满脑子都是道路。他就是公路人。对，公路人，对，对。这也是其中之一，就像机场作为一个交通系统中的枢纽如何运作一样，只有当火车通向它时，它才有真正的意义。
I mean, that's its peak functionality would be a train going there because taking a car and leaving it at the airport for two weeks, I mean, I do this all the time. I'm not saying like morally it's wrong necessarily. One, I'm gonna say two weeks. That's pretty nice vacation. That's pretty sweet.
我的意思是，它的巅峰功能就是有火车通往那里，因为开车去并把车停在机场两个星期，我的意思是，我经常这样做。我并不是说这在道德上一定是不对的。首先，我要说两个星期。那真是个不错的假期。那可太棒了。
Maybe a week, but. But you're right. It's a misuse of that infrastructure. For sure. And for no reason, for no reason at all. If you asked me, would you rather take a quick train to the airport and not have to worry about your car or even drive it there, I would say yes, 100,000%. That'd be fantastic.
也许一个星期，但是。但你是对的。那是对基础设施的滥用。肯定的。而且毫无理由，完全没有理由。如果你问我，你愿不愿意坐一趟快车去机场，而不必担心你的车甚至把它开到那里，我会说愿意，100,000%。那太棒了。
But it's shocking how many airports do not link to public transit in this country. That's a mistake, you know, done over and over again in the Bay Area. There have been sort of janky add-ons for, you know, a few decades, and then recently it's sort of like connected more smoothly, but it's just one of those things that if you really thought about it, you would,
但这令人震惊的是，这个国家有多少机场没有与公共交通连接。这是一个错误，你知道的，湾区一次又一次地这样做。几十年来，有一些乱七八糟的附加设施，然后最近它有点像连接得更顺畅了，但这只是那种如果你真的去想的话，你就会，
like if the FAA had the power, you know, like if they were building more airports with it, or not really, I would require it, you would, like, if the FAA had the power, you know, like if they're building more airports with or not, really, I would require it. You know, like I would require that there's a public transit link to an airport. It just makes so much sense. It's a little nuts that it is, in most cities, it is easier to get to a stadium than it is to get to an airport. You know, that it's, it's in New York, certainly it's easier to get to Yankee or stadium or city field than it is to get to the airport without using a car, at least in my experience. New Yorkers write me in, tell me if I'm wrong, if it's gotten harder to get to those
就像如果美国联邦航空管理局（FAA）有权力，你知道的，就像如果他们用它建造更多的机场，或者其实不是，我会强制要求它，你就会，就像如果FAA有权力，你知道的，就像不管他们是否在建造更多的机场，我都会强制要求它。你知道的，就像我会要求机场必须有公共交通连接一样。这太合乎逻辑了。在大多数城市，去体育场比去机场还要容易，这简直有点荒谬。你知道的，在纽约，至少根据我的经验，去洋基体育场或花旗球场肯定比不用汽车去机场要容易。纽约人写信告诉我，如果我错了，如果近年来去这些体育场变得更难了。
stadiums in recent years. And Kara talks about, we had talked about this kind of, this for lack of a better word, ghettoization of certain city residents. And he talks about how opponents of Moses saw this as an inadvertent oversight, that he just didn't care enough to look into it. But Caro is again presenting it as a deliberate objective that he wants to keep specifically poor people, but also likely non-white people from Long Island. And that that's one of his interests in not having mass transit there. And he quotes a 1945 speech that Moses gives to the Nassau Bar Association, where he literally says, figure out what sort of people you want to attract into Nassau County. By that, I mean people of what standards, what income levels, and what capacity to contribute to the source of government.
卡罗谈到了——我们之前讨论过这种可以说是对某些城市居民的“隔离化”（ghettoization）现象。他谈到摩西的反对者如何将此视为一种无意的疏忽，认为他只是不够关心去调查。但卡罗再次将其描述为一个刻意的目标，即他希望将特定的穷人，以及很可能还有非白人，排除在长岛之外。这也是他不希望那里有公共交通的利益之一。他引用了摩西1945年在拿骚律师协会发表的一篇演讲，其中他字面意思是：“弄清楚你希望吸引什么样的人来到拿骚县。我的意思是，什么标准、什么收入水平、以及对政府税收有什么贡献能力的人。”
Even if you strip that of all of the more recent kind of implications, he's still saying certain places are for certain people, and we need to build our infrastructure and arrange those places to attract only that certain type of people. We don't want those other kinds of people, which is pretty damning for a guy who is working in theory for a city and a state rather than for a constituency. Yeah, that's right. I mean, that's really, I don't know, but it's even, I don't think he has a quiet part to say out loud.
即使你剥离了所有这些更近期的暗示，他仍然在说某些地方是给某些人准备的，我们需要建设我们的基础设施并安排这些地方，只为了吸引那种特定的人。我们不想要其他类型的人，对于一个理论上为城市和州服务，而不是为某个选区服务的人来说，这相当于是致命的定论。是的，没错。我的意思是，这真的，我不知道，但这甚至——我不认为他有什么需要偷偷摸摸说出口的秘密。
There's always that phrase, he's saying the quiet part loud. But he just is this, it's just very, very clear what he is about, is about dividing this community up and really, again, just not serving the whole community. It really is. It's about funding all the resources towards the few people who have cars and those communities that they create
总有那种说法，他把本该小声说的话大声说出来了。但他就是这样，他的意图非常非常明确，就是要分裂这个社区，说真的，再次强调，就是不为整个社区服务。确实如此。这就是把所有的资源都投入到少数拥有汽车的人以及他们创造的那些社区中，
and really leaving behind all the rest of them and not just leaving behind a sort of neglect or even benevolent neglect. It's like it's true harm being done to them. It's awful, it's awful stuff. Yeah, and Carol then he goes in again to, he has a long section about how Moses's personality kind of insulates him from changing reality is from criticism and his confidence is never
而真正抛弃了其余所有人，这不仅仅是一种忽视，甚至不是仁慈的忽视。这就像是对他们造成了真正的伤害。这太糟糕了，太糟糕了。是的，然后卡罗再次深入探讨，他有一大段关于摩西的个性如何使他免受现实变化、免受批评的影响，他的自信从未
shaken because his power and arrogance keep him from learning anything that might shake it and how he's sure these roads will make his name immortal. He's like the builders of ancient Rome. And he has an article he writes about New York in the year 1999, where he's basically talking about how great his roads are and how they're, they're still going to be there. And I want to, we know this stuff about him. So I want to rush through to this amazing sentence that, that Carol has where she talks about within two weeks of its opening that Van Wyk Expressway, it's jammed with traffic. And I love this. Carol writes, traffic will flow freely. Moses had promised inappropriate adverb. And I love it. I think
动摇，因为他的权力和傲慢使他无法从任何可能动摇他的事情中吸取教训，以及他如何确信这些道路将使他的名字永垂不朽。他就像古代罗马的建造者。他写过一篇关于1999年纽约的文章，基本上是在谈论他的道路有多棒，它们将如何，它们仍将存在。我想，我们都知道他这些事迹。所以我想快进到卡罗那句惊艳的话，他说范威克高速公路开通后两周内，就交通堵塞了。我太喜欢这个了。卡罗写道：“交通将畅通无阻。”摩西曾承诺过——一个不恰当的副词。我太喜欢了。我想
that's two words. And just as, as like, as a grammar teacher, just undercutting him, just like, I love that, I just love writing, just the way he writes, inappropriate adverb. Like, yeah, it's not moving freely. And I don't have to, I'm not gonna go into a lot of detail about that. It's so funny. There's so many points in this book, rereading it again where I'm like,
那是两个词。作为一个语法老师，这简直是在拆他的台，就像，我太喜欢这个了，我就是喜欢这种写作，他写的方式，一个不恰当的副词。就像，是的，它根本没有畅通无阻。我不需要，我不会对此进行长篇大论。这太搞笑了。在这本书里有很多地方，再次重读时我都觉得，
this is a funny book. You know, it's a sad book and it's a very dense book, but there's some very funny moments in it. And all this, like, the big problem is book. It's a sad book and it's a very dense book, but there's some very funny moments in it. And all this, like the big problem is him not thinking in terms of these systems is like, once you begin to build out and extend and connect all these roads,
这是一本有趣的书。你知道，这是一本悲伤的书，也是一本非常厚重的书，但里面有一些非常有趣的时刻。所有这一切，就像，这本书最大的问题。这是一本悲伤的书，也是一本非常厚重的书，但里面有一些非常有趣的时刻。所有这一切，比如最大的问题是他没有从这些系统的角度去思考，就像，一旦你开始建设、延伸和连接所有这些道路，
they all just get worse and worse and worse. Yeah. You know, like it really just doesn't, his ability to underestimate traffic and not understand the concept of induced demand and not really, you know, learn anything and update anything in his brain is just really destroying and creating a system that,
它们只会变得越来越糟。是的。你知道，这真的就是，他对交通的低估，不理解诱发需求（induced demand）的概念，也没有真正地，你知道，在脑海中吸取任何教训并更新任何东西，这真的在摧毁并创造一个系统，
you know, just like a machinery that does not move anymore. And it seems that every one of his projects has the same exact problem. They all lead to greater congestion. They don't take congestion off of the pre-existing traffic arteries. And Caro, he gives us a lot of vehicle counts, travel times, lengths of traffic jams. This is a data mine. And these chapters, something Roman and I were talking about before recording, these chapters have a lot of information in them and a lot of
你知道的，就像一台不再运转的机器。而且似乎他的每一个项目都有完全相同的问题。它们都导致了更严重的拥堵。它们并没有缓解原有交通动脉的拥堵。卡罗为我们提供了大量的车辆统计数据、旅行时间、交通堵塞的长度。这是一个数据金矿。而这些章节，我和罗曼在录音前讨论过的内容，这些章节里面有很多信息，而且有很多
facts and figures that are not really fully necessary, it feels like at times, to make these arguments. But there's part of me that thinks that Carol is putting it in there just so it's somewhere, you know, that if it's not in this book, no one's ever going to know it. But it certainly is, at a certain point, you're like, well, yeah, I get it. The roads are really full. There's a lot of cars. He's already dead. Yeah. I mean, it has that quality of just piling on the details and I do think that, you have to imagine the book landing 1974,
事实和数字，感觉有时并不完全有必要来支持这些论点。但我心里有一部分认为，卡罗把这些放进去只是为了让它有个出处，你知道的，如果这本书里没有，就没人会知道了。但当然，在某种程度上，你会想，好吧，我懂了。道路真的很拥挤。有很多汽车。他已经死了。是的。我的意思是，它具有那种堆砌细节的特质，而且我确实认为，你必须想象这本书在1974年出版时，
Caro knows exactly what it takes, the sort of amount of shoe leather to get all this data and put it together into a cogent narrative. And he must be thinking, this is the document. There is no internet, there is no thing to look up. This is where it's going to be. It's going to get more and more scattered and lost over time.
卡罗非常清楚需要付出什么，需要多少实地调查才能获得所有这些数据并将其组合成一个连贯的叙事。他当时一定在想，这就是这份文件。没有互联网，没有什么可以查阅的。这就是记录将要保存的地方。随着时间的推移，它会变得越来越分散和丢失。
And if he doesn't put it here, it will be gone. And I think this is a real kind of the choice of a historian versus the choice of just a pure storyteller in this moment. Yeah. Not like, I think Robert Caro is an unparalleled storyteller. I'm not meaning to disparage him at all, but this is sort of like the difference between making a movie of this versus making
如果他不把它放在这里，它就会消失。我认为这确实是历史学家在这一刻的选择，与纯粹讲故事的人的选择之间的区别。是的。不是说——我认为罗伯特·卡罗是一个无与伦比的故事大王。我不是想贬低他，但这有点像拍一部电影和制作
a document for history. He's balancing those notions. He is, and I think even more than that, I feel like it's a little bit like he is putting together a scientific argument. That the myth of Moses was so strong, he felt that he needed to marshal so much evidence to prove his point that at this point it's almost like he's writing a lab or a research paper, you know, to really prove, no, no, this, this evidence supports what I'm saying. And so there's a lot here that to a modern day reader where
一份历史文献之间的区别。他在平衡这些概念。他是，而且我认为比这更甚的是，我觉得这有点像他在拼凑一个科学论证。摩西的神话太强大了，他觉得他需要调集如此多的证据来证明他的观点，以至于在这一点上，这几乎就像他在写一篇实验室报告或研究论文，你知道的，为了真正证明，不，不，这些证据支持我所说的话。所以这里有很多东西，对于现代读者来说，
I feel like everyone reading this book has already bought into the main premise by this point, you know, we have no lived experience of Robert Moses, we didn't grow up being told he's a he's an amazing man. And so it's so it feels at times like, oh, this is a lot. But I think you're right that, that Carol feels like this information needs to be out there, I need to tell it to people and it's nowhere. And if it's not here, it's never going to be anywhere. And it was just a huge burden to feel when you are a biographer, you know, when you're a history writer, this idea that, oh, well, I found this information and if I don't put it here, it's just going to disappear forever. And he's spoken about that, the feeling of horror of the idea like, if I don't get this into the book, no one's going to know it. You know, it's just going to, it's never going to reach people's awareness. Hey, though he's getting some help here because the newspapers, remember those newspapers we talked about? They've started printing stories again about traffic. It takes so long to get everywhere.
我觉得每个读这本书的人到这时候都已经接受了主要前提，你知道的，我们没有生活在罗伯特·摩西的时代，我们从小没有被灌输他是一个伟大的人。所以有时候会觉得，哦，这内容真多。但我认为你是对的，卡罗觉得这些信息需要公之于众，我需要告诉人们，而它在别处是没有的。如果它不在这里，它就永远不会在任何地方。作为一个传记作家，当你是一个历史作家时，这种感觉是一种巨大的负担，这种想法，哦，好吧，我发现了这个信息，如果我不把它放在这里，它就会永远消失。他曾谈到过那种恐惧感，如果我不能把这些写进书里，就没有人会知道了。你知道的，它就会，就永远不会进入人们的意识。嘿，不过他在这里得到了一些帮助，因为报纸——还记得我们讨论过的那些报纸吗？它们又开始刊登关于交通的故事了。去哪里都要花这么长时间。
This isn't the first time it's happened. Kara talks about how there's just this kind of like cycle each time there's a big traffic jam in the 20s, 30s, 40s, traffic is bad. Everyone gets mad about it. And then they sink into this kind of sullen, apathetic acceptance and he compares it explicitly to a lab rat getting used to electric shocks, which is such a horrifying way to think about urban life that it's just, you're just getting used to torture, you know, over time. And that there's this cycle that always ends in numbness. It goes from anger to numbness. And now we're back in that boom and bust cycle of outrage because people are back
这已经不是第一次发生了。卡罗谈到，这只是一种循环，每次在20年代、30年代、40年代出现大塞车时，交通就很糟糕。每个人都对此感到愤怒。然后他们陷入了一种闷闷不乐、麻木不仁的接受状态，他将其明确比作实验室里的老鼠习惯了电击，这对于思考城市生活来说是一种极其可怕的方式，你只是习惯了折磨，你知道的，随着时间的推移。而且存在这样一个总是以麻木告终的循环。它从愤怒走向麻木。现在我们又回到了这种愤怒的“繁荣与萧条”循环中，因为人们在经历了战争期间几年没有开车的生活后，又回到了
on the roads after a couple of years during the war of not being on the roads. And traffic is new to them. The frustration of traffic is new to them. And to those of us living in 21st century America, I feel like this boom bust outrage cycle that ends with sullen numb acceptance feels very, like, unfortunately, very real. Very real and very uncomfortable, you know? It's sort of the template to the modern condition,
路上。交通对他们来说是新鲜事。交通带来的沮丧感对他们来说是新鲜事。对于我们这些生活在21世纪美国的人来说，我觉得这种以闷闷不乐、麻木接受告终的繁荣萧条愤怒循环，让人觉得，不幸的是，非常真实。非常真实，也非常让人不舒服，对吧？这可以说是现代生活状态的模板，
for sure. Yeah. But what is very clear is even though more people are talking and writing about the fact that traffic is a problem and this sort of dependency on the car is a problem, it's still not getting through to the only man that it matters. Who would that man be?
肯定的。是的。但非常清楚的是，尽管越来越多的人在谈论和撰写关于交通是个问题以及这种对汽车的依赖是个问题的事实，但它仍然没有传达到唯一一个有关系的人那里。那个人会是谁呢？
Roman, who's that? That would be the elusive Robert Moses, who we haven't mentioned yet so far in the book. He is not changing his mind. There's nothing about it. In fact, it just kind of accelerates as much as possible. Yeah, and public awareness is slowly shifting and Tarot is looking at like the proportion of letters
罗曼，那是谁？那将是难以捉摸的罗伯特·摩西，我们在书到现在为止还没怎么提到他。他没有改变主意。没有关于这方面的任何消息。事实上，它只是在尽可能地加速。是的，公众意识在慢慢转变，卡罗在观察——比如读者来信与主流报纸社论的比例。
to the editor versus editorials in major newspapers. And he's saying, people experiencing this seem to be understanding it's a problem before the powers that be do, before the major kind of communication organs of the city. But like you said, it doesn't matter. Moses, does he just want to do anything? He fights all these proposals. There's one point where in 1952, state legislators, they suggest that a Triborough should take over the subways
他说，亲历这一切的人似乎比当权者更早认识到这是一个问题，比城市的那些主要宣传机器更早。但就像你说的，这没关系。摩西，他只是想做什么就做什么吗？他反对所有这些提案。有一次在1952年，州立法者建议三区大桥管理局接管地铁，
and use its surplus money to improve them. And Moses flies back from a vacation in the Virgin Islands to shut this down as quickly as possible. He goes, no, Triborough has no extra money. Mass transit's too expensive, we shouldn't do it. And there's just this lack of understanding at a basic foundational level. And I think maybe this is why Caro is marshaling so many facts and figures as this, to change that understanding of how necessary mass transit really is to make the city livable
并用其盈余资金来改善地铁。摩西从维尔京群岛的度假中飞回来，以最快速度叫停了这件事。他说，不，三区大桥管理局没有多余的钱。公共交通太贵了，我们不该这么做。这种在基本层面的理解缺失一直存在。我想也许这就是为什么卡罗调集了如此多的事实和数字作为证据，来改变那种认为公共交通对于使城市宜居到底有多么必要的理解，
and how roads actually function. And he quotes this article from 1951 in the Herald Tribune. Again, like New York had so many newspapers, there's no Herald Tribune anymore. Like, come on. Talking about the traffic boom in good terms, as if bridges and roads were like companies that were experiencing this post-World War II, you know, 50s boom. And it says in it, business is booming, traffic is everywhere exceeding the experts' predictions. If the present volume keeps up, all the bridge bonds will be retired by 1957
以及道路实际上是如何运作的。他引用了1951年《先驱论坛报》上的一篇文章。同样，纽约曾经有那么多报纸，现在已经没有《先驱论坛报》了。拜托。以积极的词汇谈论交通繁荣，就好像桥梁和道路就像那些经历战后繁荣的1950年代的公司一样。文章中说，业务正在蓬勃发展，交通到处都在超越专家的预测。如果目前的增长势头持续下去，所有的桥梁债券将在1957年之前全部偿还，
and all tunnel bonds by 1963. Good work, gentlemen. And it's like, no, traffic is bad. Like to look at these public works as companies that are getting a lot of customers and that's gonna increase profits and therefore that we can pay off the bonds faster is such a basic misunderstanding of what's going on here.
所有的隧道债券将在1963年之前偿还。干得好，先生们。这简直是——不，交通状况很糟糕。把这些公共工程看作是获得大量客户、从而增加利润、因此我们可以更快偿还债券的公司，这简直是对正在发生的事情的基本误解。
I totally agree. Even the notion of like, the subway system has to be net neutral, or has to make money. It's like, no, you can provide a surface, and it costs money. And that is just a thing we pay into all the time to make the city more livable.
我完全同意。甚至那种认为地铁系统必须收支平衡、或者必须赚钱的观念也是如此。就像，不对，你可以提供一项服务，而这需要花钱。这只是我们一直在投入资金以使城市更具宜居性的事情。
Like, running things as a business is the type of thinking that I'm just like, never on board for for. Like there's just some things that just that that's okay. Like we pay things that represent our values and they don't need to pay off. The post office doesn't need to make money. You know, like like subways don't need to make money. It's just like it's a crazy notion and it's like infected all parts of public life. It drives me mental. Yes, and it's not a new idea, but it's an idea that won't go away. I mean, I was just rewatching Robocop and that's entirely about why you shouldn't run a police department like it's a business. You know, there's this assumption that if something takes in some money, then it must need to pay for itself. And the idea of a free subway system,
把事情当作商业来运营，这种思维方式我简直永远无法苟同。就像有些事情，这样是可以的。我们为代表我们价值观的事情付费，它们不需要盈利。邮局不需要赚钱。你知道的，就像地铁不需要赚钱一样。这简直是一个疯狂的概念，而且它已经渗透到公共生活的各个角落。这让我快要发疯了。是的，这不是一个新想法，但这是一个挥之不去的想法。我的意思是，我刚刚在重看《机械战警》，那部电影完全讲的就是为什么你不应该像经营企业那样去经营警察局。你知道，这里有一种假设：如果某个东西能收进一些钱，那么它就必须自负盈亏。而免费地铁系统的想法，
which would be an astounding gift to all New Yorkers, it never enters into any thinking whatsoever. But this chapter, we're on the close this chapter. And we know that things, they can't get any worse, right? According to Robert Carroll, they can always get a little worse. Because as this chapter ends, Karo says, and in 1954, he took a further step, one that sealed the city's future. Bum, bum, bum. I added the bum, bum, bum.
这对于所有纽约人来说将是一份惊人的礼物，却从未进入过任何人的思考范围内。但这一章，我们要结束这一章了。我们知道事情不能再糟了，对吧？根据罗伯特·卡罗的说法，情况总是会变得更糟一点。因为正如这一章结束时，卡罗所说，在1954年，他采取了进一步的行动，这一举动封死了这座城市的未来。砰，砰，砰。这“砰，砰，砰”是我加上去的。
He didn't write that part. But it would be great if he did. You could send him some notes. That's all due. Yeah. For the new electronic edition that they just released. We will get to the bum, bum, bum after this. We will get to the bum bum bum after this.
他没写那部分。但如果他写了那就太好了。你可以给他提点意见。这都算数。是的。为了他们刚刚发布的新电子版。我们稍后会讲到那个“砰，砰，砰”。我们稍后会讲到那个“砰，砰，砰”。
Okay, now we're on chapter 40, Point of No Return. It really is what it says on the tin. He is, what he's doing is laying out this idea that his plans for Long Island and the Long Island Expressway really just dooms Long Island to what it's going to be. It's like it's going to be a traffic congestion nightmare with low density housing. I mean, he's really just setting it up. This whole chapter is about that. That's the real TLDR of this one. You're right. You basically said it, but he goes into much more detail on that, which we will too.
好了，现在我们来到第40章，“不归路”。这真的名副其实。他所做的，是阐述这样一种观点：他为长岛和长岛高速公路制定的计划，确实给长岛的未来判了死刑。它注定要成为一个低密度住宅的交通拥堵噩梦。我的意思是，他真的是在为此做铺垫。整章都在讲这个。这就是这一章真正的“太长不看”（TLDR）。你说得对。你基本上已经概括了，但他对此进行了更详细的阐述，我们也会这么做。
As the chapter starts, we're back in the 50s now. Moses is being too successful. His authorities are bringing in way more money than his actual bridges and tunnels and roads cost to operate. He's pulling in $21 million in surplus a year. He can use that to capitalize bonds worth half a billion dollars. He's got so much more money that it risks getting the attention of the government, forcing him to use that money to bail out the subways
随着这一章的开始，我们现在回到了50年代。摩西过于成功了。他的管理局带来的收入远远超过了他实际的桥梁、隧道和道路的运营成本。他每年获得2100万美元的盈余。他可以用这些钱来资本化价值五亿美元的债券。他拥有如此多的资金，以至于有可能引起政府的注意，迫使他用这笔钱来拯救地铁
or retire his bonds. And if he does either of those things, he loses the potential capitalization money that having that money allows him to. So in order to keep making money, he's got to spend all his money. It's a real Brewster's Million situation that Bob Moses finds himself in here.
或偿还他的债券。如果他做了这两件事中的任何一件，他就会失去拥有这些资金所带来的潜在资本化资金。因此，为了继续赚钱，他必须花掉他所有的资金。鲍勃·摩西发现自己陷入了一种真正的“布鲁斯特的百万横财”（Brewster's Millions）式的困境。
But the weird thing is that Robert Caro then almost immediately contradicts himself by saying also Moses construction plans were so huge that he didn't have enough money to fulfill them. He's got all these projects. He's going to build a New York Coliseum, the Throgs Neck Bridge, different expressways. He's got the Jamaica Bay Park. He's got all these enormous plans that he wants. So Robert Moses, the guy who has too much money, still needs to get more money,
但奇怪的是，罗伯特·卡罗随后几乎立刻自相矛盾地说，摩西的建设计划太宏大了，以至于他没有足够的资金来完成它们。他有这么多的项目。他要建造纽约体育馆、瑟古斯·内克大桥（Throgs Neck Bridge）、不同的高速公路。他有牙买加湾公园。他有所有这些他想要的宏伟计划。所以罗伯特·摩西，这个钱多到花不完的家伙，仍然需要更多的钱，
and he's still looking for ways to get it. And as we've seen before, he's able to take advantage of federal programs like the lobbying for his roads to be included in the federal highway bill and things like that to get access to this money. And there's another organization that he's gonna need the help of. The only, he needs, if he's gonna get highway money
而且他还在寻找获取资金的方法。正如我们以前所见，他能够利用联邦项目，比如为他的道路被纳入联邦公路法案进行游说之类的事情，来获得这些资金。还有另一个组织他将需要其帮助。唯一的，他需要，如果他想从联邦政府获得公路资金，
from the federal government, he needs to build an interstate road. Unfortunately, due to the geography of New York, there's only one state he can really put it through. Yeah, and then he can, yeah, there's only one state he can enter, and that's New Jersey, my home state, which I'll admit is not as cool as New York.
他需要建造一条州际公路。不幸的是，由于纽约的地理环境，他真正能穿过的州只有一个。是的，然后他可以，是的，他只能进入一个州，那就是新泽西州，我的家乡，我承认它没有纽约那么酷。
It's kind of like New York's little brother that like is like, hey, what about me? What about me? And New York's like, no. So I apologize to all the residents of Philadelphia who got mad at me last time. Cause reading this part, I was like, I could feel viscerally Moses' lack of interest in actually building a road into New Jersey.
它有点像纽约的小弟弟，总是说，嘿，那我呢？那我呢？而纽约则说，不。所以我向所有上次对我生气的费城居民道歉。因为读到这里时，我能真切地感受到摩西对在新泽西州修建一条道路缺乏真正的兴趣。
And I understood it. Even being from there, I understood it. It's a great state, but still, it's not a romantic state that people desire to be in. A very true story from my life is that when my parents moved from New York City, the New York City area to New Jersey, and then my mom's brother, my uncle,
我理解这一点。即使身为那儿的人，我也理解。这是一个伟大的州，但即便如此，它并不是一个人们渴望身处其中的浪漫之州。我生活中的一个真实故事是，当我的父母从纽约市，纽约市地区搬到新泽西州时，然后我妈妈的兄弟，我的舅舅，
also moved to New Jersey, my grandmother, who was a lifelong New Yorker, for years did not tell her friends that her children lived in New Jersey. Instead, she just would avoid the subject. Wow. Yeah. When you're in New York, New Jersey is...
也搬到了新泽西州，我终生都是纽约人的祖母，多年来一直没有告诉她的朋友她的孩子住在新泽西州。相反，她只是避开这个话题。哇。是的。当你在纽约时，新泽西是……
I mean, when you're in New Jersey, New York is the only place you want to be if you're in North Jersey. Don't even get me started on South Jersey. It's a different world down there. But if you're in New York, you have no interest in it. But if Moses is going to be able to build something in New Jersey, he needs to make nice with the port authority. That's right, there's another authority around, and they are bruisers. You know, as anyone who's been in Port Authority bus terminal can tell you,
我的意思是，当你在新泽西时，如果你在北泽西，纽约是你唯一想去的地方。南泽西就更不用提了。那里的世界完全不同。但如果你在纽约，你对它毫无兴趣。但如果摩西想在新泽西建造点什么，他需要与港务局（Port Authority）搞好关系。没错，周围还有另一个管理局，他们都是硬汉。正如去过港务局巴士总站的人都能告诉你的一样，
they do not have the finesse or the elegance of the Triborough Authority. So yeah, so he has to sort of mend fences there, which he always sort of butted heads. I mean, I can't remember the specific details of how the Port Authority and how Moses has tried to angle to take over more things from Port Authority at different times and then being thwarted by some other sort of schemer or another, but he has to figure it out. Yeah, they've been having turf battles all this time. It's a little bit like the scene of the being of the warriors when all the gangs are being brought together
他们没有三区大桥管理局（Triborough Authority）那种手腕或优雅。所以是的，他必须在那里修补关系，尽管他们总是意见不合。我的意思是，我不记得具体细节了，比如港务局和摩西如何在不同时期争夺对更多事物的控制权，然后又被另一个阴谋家阻挠，但他必须弄清楚这一点。是的，他们一直在进行地盘之争。这有点像电影《战士帮》中所有帮派被聚集在一起的场景，
and Cyrus is like, we could work together and it's in the gangs in the end, it doesn't work out. They've got to mend those fences and that's because Port Authority has so much money on hands. They have the potential to capitalize $700 million worth of bonds, just an astonishing amount of money in the 1950s.
塞鲁斯说，我们可以合作，但最终帮派们并没有成功。他们必须修补这些关系，那是因为港务局手头有太多的资金。他们有潜力资本化价值7亿美元的债券，在20世纪50年代这是一笔惊人的巨款。
But Port Authority, it lacks Moses' greatest strength, which is not his ability to twist the law to do whatever he wants, not his shamelessness and refusal to be bound by ethics, but his vision. And Caro describes Port Authority as long on cash and short on dreams. All they ever think about building
但港务局缺乏摩西最大的优势，这并不是他为了随心所欲而扭曲法律的能力，也不是他的厚颜无耻和拒绝受道德约束，而是他的远见。卡罗将港务局描述为“现金充裕，梦想短缺”。他们想建造的唯一东西
is revenue producing stuff. They don't have the vision for a grand system. The kind of thing that can inspire say Albany to get behind a project in the way that Moses seems to so easily generate these dreams that people just flock to. And, uh, you know, Moses has those dreams, but his dreams only involve highways and bridges and cars. No. That's it.
就是能产生收入的东西。他们没有构建宏大系统的远见。那种能够激发奥尔巴尼支持一个项目的远见，而摩西似乎能如此轻易地激发人们蜂拥而至的梦想。而且，你知道的，摩西有这些梦想，但他的梦想只涉及公路、桥梁和汽车。没了。
In different configurations though. Sometimes it's a highway leading to a bridge, sometimes a bridge leading to a highway. But luckily, the port authorities are all on board for that. Yes, because they don't just have a shared need and the need to combine money with vision and political power. Because the other thing is that Moses had so much power in Albany. They also have a shared enemy, a common enemy between the two of them, that both Triborough and Port Authority are happy to stomp into the mud. And that enemy is trains.
不过是以不同的组合形式。有时是一条通往桥梁的高速公路，有时是一座通往高速公路的桥梁。但幸运的是，港务局完全赞同这一点。是的，因为他们不仅有着共同的需求，需要将资金与远景和政治权力结合起来。因为另一件事是摩西在奥尔巴尼拥有巨大的权力。他们还有一个共同的敌人，两人之间共同的敌人，三区大桥管理局和港务局都很高兴将其踩入泥土中。那个敌人就是火车。
Yeah. No love of trains. They do not like trains. They love roads with tolls on them. They love traffic. They love tolls. Or not traffic necessarily, but they like having lots of cars going over their stuff. And so January of 1955, Tribor authority, Port authority, these two titans of roads and inconveniencing people, they released the joint study of arterial facilities that strangely enough recommends building the stuff that Moses wants to build. It's amazing. It turns out it's just the best way to do it.
是的。对火车毫无好感。他们不喜欢火车。他们喜欢收费公路。他们喜欢交通。他们喜欢收费。或者不一定是交通本身，但他们喜欢有大量的汽车开过他们的设施。所以在1955年1月，三区大桥管理局、港务局这两个道路和给人们带来不便的巨头，发布了一份联合干线设施研究报告，奇怪的是，它建议建造摩西想要建造的东西。这太神奇了。事实证明，这竟然是最好的做事方式。
Lots of expressways, even the long threatened mid Manhattan elevated expressway, which we talked about before, which thankfully was never built. And Carol lists so many potential expressways all through the city reaching out to the suburbs. And he says, this is a business arrangement. Moses doesn't have the money to build these things. Port Authority has the money, but doesn't have the power. So for instance, the Verrazano narrows bridge, they come to this agreement.
大量的高速公路，甚至包括长期受到威胁的曼哈顿中城高架高速公路——我们之前讨论过，万幸的是它从未建成。卡罗列出了穿过整个城市延伸到郊区的众多潜在高速公路。他说，这是一笔商业交易。摩西没有资金来建设这些东西。港务局有资金，但没有权力。因此，例如，韦拉扎诺海峡大桥（Verrazano Narrows Bridge），他们达成了这项协议。
Port Authority will fund the bridge. Tribal Authority will lease it and control it. And at some point, they will buy it back from the Port Authority in the future. So Moses brilliantly, it's kind of hard to know the Port Authority in the future. So Moses, brilliantly, it's kind of hard to know what Port Authority is getting really out of this except for short term amount of tolls because he's convinced his rival to fund his own project. And when the bridges are built, both authorities are raking in huge amounts of money. I guess that is what they get out of it is the money. And Carol quotes Moses describing this bridge and there's such an
港务局将为这座桥提供资金。三区大桥管理局将租用并控制它。在未来的某个时候，他们会从港务局手中把它买回来。所以摩西巧妙地——很难弄清楚港务局未来真正能从中得到什么，除了短期的通行费收入，因为他游说他的竞争对手来资助他自己的项目。当这些桥梁建成时，两个管理局都赚取了巨额资金。我想这就是他们从中得到的东西，就是钱。卡罗引用了摩西对这座桥的描述，里面有一种
unfortunate modern parallel in the way he talks about it. I don't know if you'll be able to recognize the person that it reminds me of in the way Moses talks about this bridge. He goes, there's gonna be a bridge pretty soon, the bridge of my dreams. It's gonna be the most important single piece
不幸的现代相似之处，他在谈论这座桥时的语气。我不知道你是否能认出让我想起的那个人，摩西在谈论这座桥时的样子。他说，很快就会有一座桥，我梦想中的桥。它将是世界上最重要的一处
of arterial construction in the world. It will be the longest suspension bridge in the world and the tallest. It's all superlatives when you talk about this bridge. Like everything's the best that he does. Everything's best. Everything, you know, he, he just goes just short of calling it the most beautiful bridge in the world, which he said before about his stuff.
干线建筑。它将是世界上最长的悬索桥，也是最高的。当他谈论这座桥时，全是最高级词汇。就像他做的每件事都是最好的。每件事都是最好的。每件事，你知道，他，他差一点就称它是世界上最美丽的桥梁，他以前对自己的东西也这样说过。
Yeah. And, uh, Caro talks about how it's not just Triborough and Port Authority. Moses still has this alliance of people behind him also profit, namely number one among them, people who make cars, people who sell cars, people who make money repairing cars. He is the darling of the auto industry. We'll see in 1964, Moses is going to run the New York World's Fair and we'll see what a lack of success that is in some ways. And the automakers pour millions of dollars into that. But my favorite detail here is how in 1953, Moses enters and wins an essay contest
是的。卡罗谈到，不仅仅是三区大桥管理局和港务局。摩西身后仍然有这样一个支持他的利益联盟，即汽车制造商、汽车销售商、靠修理汽车赚钱的人。他是汽车工业的宠儿。我们将在1964年看到，摩西将举办纽约世博会，从某种程度上说，那是一次多么缺乏成功的活动。而汽车制造商为此倾注了数百万万美元。但我最喜欢的细节是，在1953年，摩西参加并赢得了一场由通用汽车举办的征文比赛，
run by General Motors, and he wins a $25,000 prize. And it seems it's so funny to me, the idea of him entering a corporate essay contest. And I just imagine like some kid won second place and didn't get the $25,000, but Robert Moses walked away with it. And Carrow says, Moses is America's most vocal, effective, prestigious apologist for the automobile. He's just, he's so good at pushing cars. And the carmakers are just one of this regiment that he has that we've talked about before. Caro says, the joint program represented profit, profit from bonds, deposits, contracts, premiums,
他赢得了2万5千美元的奖金。这对我来说太搞笑了，他参加企业征文比赛的想法。我只能想象某个孩子得了第二名，没有拿到25,000美元，而罗伯特·摩西却拿走了。卡罗说，摩西是美国“最直言不讳、最有效、最具声望的汽车辩护士”。他太擅长推销汽车了。而汽车制造商只是他麾下的一个军团，我们之前已经讨论过了。卡罗说，联合计划代表着利润——来自债券、存款、合同、保费、
retainers, jobs, payoffs, bribes, Greece. It enlisted behind him all those forces in the city, banks, unions, contractors, venal politicians, venal or short-sighted public officials who put profit from public works above the public interest or the public trust. Like, look, if you've got a project that can make a lot of money, you'll have lots of people who are happy to be a part of it.
聘金、工作、回扣、贿赂、润滑费的利润。它把城市里的所有这些力量都拉拢到他身后——银行、工会、承包商、唯利是图的政客、把公共工程的利润置于公共利益或公共信托之上的唯利是图或目光短浅的公职人员。听着，如果你有一个能赚大钱的项目，你就会有很多乐意参与其中的人。
And Moses has that. And because he personally doesn't care about how much he takes in graft, as we've talked about before, he can spread it around and he can enforce loyalty if he has to. With that same old threat, if a local politician is like, maybe I don't want you to build this enormous road straight through my neighborhood, he can say, all right, then that project and all the money it represents will vanish and you just won't have it. And he institutes this kind of, I guess, informal policy where borough presidents,
而摩西拥有这一点。因为他个人并不在乎他拿了多少黑金贿赂，正如我们之前讨论过的，他可以把钱分发出去，如果有必要，他可以强行维持忠诚。用那个老套的威胁，如果地方政客说，也许我不想让你在我的社区正中间修建一条巨大的公路，他可以说，好吧，那么这个项目以及它所代表的所有资金都将消失，你将一无所有。他制定了一种，我想，非官方的政策，即区长们
they're allowed to publicly criticize Moses's plans, but in private, when they're actually voting on the board of estimate, they are not allowed to stop those plans. They don't veto those projects. They allow them to go through. And the result of this, as Caro says, is that the city would just go on building bridges,
被允许公开批评摩西的计划，但在私底下，当他们在估算委员会（Board of Estimate）实际投票时，他们不允许阻止这些计划。他们不否决这些项目。他们允许它们通过。正如卡罗所说，其结果是，这座城市将继续修建桥梁，
it would go on building highways, and building basically nothing else. Yeah, yeah. And he spent some time talking about like what you could build with this much money. You know, that's a sort of like this amazing fantasy land of, of modernizing the Long Island railroad and also, you know, new tunnels to bring trains full of people from Manhattan to New Jersey.
它将继续修建高速公路，而基本上什么都不建。是的，是的。他花了一些时间讨论你可以用这么多钱建造什么。你知道，这有点像现代化的长岛铁路，以及连接曼哈顿和新泽西的全新铁路隧道的美妙幻想世界，
You could finish that second avenue subway, all this sort of stuff that's like, there's so much you could build with this amount of money. And even though that idea of there's like, there's not the old school style corruption in the system of him taking money, there's still the same impulse is causing a kind of internal corruption.
你可以完成那条第二大道地铁，所有这些你可以用这笔钱建造的东西。尽管系统里没有老派的那种他拿钱的腐败，但同样的冲动正在导致一种内在的腐败。
The fact that this set of public transit system just does not have the same financial upside in the end. Like the margins are different. It is more of a service that you're providing than a business that you are creating. And that is the core. That is like the cancer at the center of this decision making. Yes. The quantifiable metric that they're using to judge where things are worth doing is exactly how much revenue is it gonna bring in
这套公共交通系统归根结底根本没有同等规模的财务回报。比如利润率是不一样的。它更多的是你提供的一种服务，而不是你创造的一家企业。而这才是核心。这就像是决策制定核心处的毒瘤。是的。他们用来判断事情是否值得去做所使用的可量化标准，恰恰是它能带来多少收入
for the people involved and not the metric of how much is this going to improve or assist the lives of the residents of the New York area. And I'll tell you, Roman, reading over this list of the things you could have done, I was like, that would have helped me, that would have helped me, that would have helped me. Like he specifically mentions extending the
给相关人员，而不是去衡量这会对纽约地区居民的生活带来多大改善或帮助。而且我跟你说，罗曼，读完你列出的那些本可以完成的事情，我就想：那会对我有帮助，那会对我有帮助，那会对我有帮助。比如他专门提到将
subway out to Mill Basin, far out in Brooklyn, as far as you can get Brooklyn Basin before you're in Long Island. And I'm like, yeah, I remember the day that my wife and I and our friend Sarah wanted to go to the Mill Basin deli. And it took the entire day on bus and on foot to get to this deli for lunch. Like, each time he's mentioning something, I'm like, yeah, that would have helped me. So I can tell you it would have made a measurable improvement in my life if we had had this fantasy list paid into rather than the projects that they wanted to make. And Kara says they could have taken this money and they could have spent it on an entirely new modern subway system. That these two authorities, with their power and their money in 1955,
地铁延伸到米尔盆地（Mill Basin），那是布鲁克林深处，也就是在进入长岛之前你能到达的布鲁克林的尽头。我想：对啊，我记得我和妻子还有朋友莎拉想去米尔盆地熟食店的那天。我们坐公交加步行，花了整整一天才到这家熟食店吃午饭。所以，他每提到一件事，我都觉得：对啊，那会对我有帮助。因此我可以告诉你，如果我们把钱投进这个充满幻想的愿望清单，而不是投进他们想要建造的项目里，我的生活一定会得到切实可见的改善。卡罗说，他们本可以用这些钱打造一个全新、现代化的地铁系统。这两大机构凭借他们在1955年的权力和资金，
could have so massively improved the life of the millions of people that live in the region. And instead, nearly all of it goes to car facilities. They spend so much money. They're spending $755 million on bridges, tunnels, and highways that were mentioned in that study. And that's just the money that were mentioned in that study. And that's just the money that Triborough is spending.
本可以极大地改善该地区数百万居民的生活。然而相反，几乎所有的钱都流向了汽车设施。他们花了大笔资金。他们在研究中提及的桥梁、隧道和高速公路上花费了7.55亿美元。而这还只是研究中提及的金额。这仅仅是三桥和隧道管理局（Triborough）花费的资金。
And Carro says from 1955 to 1965, there's $1.2 billion in federal and state money that goes into highways mentioned in that joint study. And over the next decade, from 1955 to 1965, they built 439 miles of new highway and they build zero new miles of railroad or subway track. And Carol says in 1974, people using subways and railroads in and around New York were still riding on tracks laid down between 1904 and 1933, the last year before Robert Moses came to
卡罗指出，从1955年到1965年，有12亿美元的联邦和州资金投入到了那项联合研究中提到的高速公路。在接下来的十年里，即1955年至1965年间，他们修建了439英里的新高速公路，而铁路或地铁轨道的新增里程为零。卡罗说，在1974年，纽约市内及其周边使用地铁和铁路的人，依然乘坐着在1904年至1933年间铺设的轨道——那是罗伯特·摩西掌权
power in the city. Not a single mile had been built since. And now it's in the 50 years since then, some new miles have been built, but certainly not. Not many. Very many. Yeah. And so we're still in New York and I say weird as if I still live there. We're still riding on, in tunnels that were built
该市之前的最后一年。自那以后，连一英里都没有新建过。如今在过去的50年里，虽然修建了一些新轨道，但绝对不多。非常少。是的。所以我们依然在纽约——我用“我们”就好像我还住在那里一样。我们依然在
a hundred, more than a hundred years ago with very little new tracks and rails. And you hear all the time stories about, uh, how the, uh, the, the machinery involved is all out of date and things like that. And there was this moment he's saying when it all could have been improved and they just didn't do it. It makes me so mad.
一百多年前（甚至一百多年前）建造的隧道里行驶，几乎没有增加新的轨道和铁轨。你时常听到这样的故事：呃，涉及的机械设备是如何全部过时之类的。他提到，当时本有一个可以让一切变得更好的时刻，而他们偏偏没有这么做。这让我太生气了。
I apologize, I'm getting all worked up, Roman. It makes me so mad. This stuff that happened 70 years ago, 60 years ago, I'm still so mad about it. And only partly because it affected me personally for years of my life. Yeah, the trains break down, the system, the switching systems are old.
我很抱歉，罗曼，我情绪有点激动。这太让我生气了。这些70年前、60年前发生的事情，我直到现在依然为此感到愤怒。部分原因确实是因为它在我的生活中曾多年对产生过直接影响。是的，火车抛锚，系统，换轨系统老旧。
Robert Shaw is robbing them right and left. Oh, you're right. The same year this book comes out, you've got literally four men hijack a subway train in maybe the greatest movie ever made. I'll say yes, I'll say it is. But here is where we get into the territory, and this is like maybe we could condense it,
罗伯特·肖（Robert Shaw）左右逢源，疯狂敛财。噢，你说得对。就在这本书出版的同一年，字面意义上有四个人劫持了一列地铁，这或许是影史上最伟大的电影。我得说是的，我赞同。但接下来我们要进入这样一个领域——也许我们可以把它浓缩一下——
where Caro gives the litany of indignities that befall people who dare to travel by train or subway. Oh, the people who have to deal with that hellish purgatory that is rail travel. We can condense it here. Because first, he talks about the subway and the Long Island Railroad, basically talking about how the trains are in bad condition,
在这里，卡罗细数了那些敢于乘火车或地铁出行的人所遭受的种种屈辱。哦，那些必须应对铁路旅行这种人间炼狱的人们。我们可以把这部分浓缩一下。因为首先，他谈到了地铁和长岛铁路，主要讲了这些火车的状况有多糟糕，
they break down all the time, they're unreliable, sometimes they just don't show up and the trains themselves are filthy. The windows are broken. The heating and the refrigeration doesn't work. And that if you want to get on a train to get to work in time, you have to show up incredibly early to get past the crowds of people who are going to build to get onto these trains. And he talks about, you know, different incidents where people get so mad at canceled trains or missed trains that they attack staff members.
它们总是抛锚、极不可靠，有时甚至根本不出现，而且火车本身肮脏不堪。窗户是破的。暖气和冷气都不起作用。如果你想按时赶上火车去上班，你就得起得奇早无比，才能挤过那些蜂拥准备上车的人群。他还谈到了一些具体的事件，比如人们对取消的火车或错过的班次愤怒至极，以至于攻击工作人员。
He talks about one train where, one Long Island railroad train where people are on it, it stops in the middle of the tracks and people get out and throw rocks at it. He goes, it was no longer unusual to see a train arrive in Jamaica being pushed along by another train. And there's this train from Babylon to Brooklyn that doesn't run for 102 consecutive days.
他提到了一趟列车，一列长岛铁路的列车，人们坐在上面，它却停在铁轨中间，乘客们纷纷下车向它扔石头。他说，看到一列由另一列车推着到达牙买加站（Jamaica）的火车已经不再罕见。还有一趟从巴比伦（Babylon）开往布鲁克林的列车，连续102天没有运行。
And it gets named the Phantom because when you show up, to take that train is just not there. And he, we're talking kind of interchangeably of the subway and the Long Island railroad. They're two different trains. But he's basically saying his version in a lot of details. There's a lot of great, it's almost Mad Magazine level, to me, like details about how disgusting
它被人们称作“幽灵”，因为当你赶到车站准备坐那趟车时，它就是不出现。我们刚才交替着谈论地铁和长岛铁路。它们是两种不同的列车。但他基本上是在详尽地表述他的版本。有很多精彩的细节，在我看来，几乎达到了《疯狂杂志》（Mad Magazine）的水平，描述了这些火车是如何恶心
and unreal how these trains are. But it's almost his version of the old Catskills joke about the food is terrible and such small portions. Like the trains are terrible and you can't rely on them to be there when you need them. It's such an uncomfortable, debilitating, in many ways, experience that people have to go through on a daily, daily basis.
且不真实。但这几乎成了他版本的关于卡兹奇山（Catskills）老笑话的写照：这里的食物太糟糕了，而且分量还那么少。就像这些火车烂透了，在你需要的时候根本指望不上它们。人们不得不日复一日地经历这种极其难受、甚至在许多方面令人身心俱疲的体验。
But that's the thing about mass transit is that the pillars of it functioning well are that it is frequent in it gets you to where you want to go. And as soon as those fail, everything else begins to fail afterward. You know, like then there is enough money to upkeep, then there's breakdown, and then everything becomes worse and worse and worse. It's a doom spiral that is just really, really hard to pull out of, unless you just make the decision of just like, no, we're going to do this because we need to do this.
但公共交通的关键在于：它良好运转的支柱是班次频繁且能把你送到想去的地方。一旦这些崩溃了，其他一切也会随之开始崩溃。你知道，比如资金不足以进行维护，接着就会发生故障，然后一切变得越来越糟。这是一个死亡螺旋，一旦陷入就真的、真的很难扭转，除非你下定决心，比如：“不，我们要这么做，因为我们必须这么做。”
It's just like, it's going, we're gonna do these things because they are hard. You know? And that's just the nature of it. Like you have to have reliable service for mass transit to work. Unfortunately, this is not a weakness that highways have. When they are unreliable, people just accept it.
就像是：它正在进行，我们要去做这些事，因为它们很难。你知道吗？这就是它的本质。为了让公共交通发挥作用，你必须拥有可靠的服务。不幸的是，这是高速公路所不具备的弱点。当高速公路不可靠时，人们只会默默接受。
The system, it has a weird way of tolerating that type of failure affordance as a design. And because you could try it at another time, and it does work, and it's sort of sporadic. But mass transit has this problem of like you get on the track and then it just, it's going in one direction. It's a kind of a ratchet and it just suffers through this, you know, just like this mania that he has for cars and this, um, this, you know, just this whole bias against mass transit.
这个系统有一种奇怪的方式，将这种类型的失效容忍度作为设计的一部分。因为你可以换个时间再试，而且它确实能起作用，而且有点零星随机。但公共交通有个问题：你一旦上了轨道，它就只能朝着一个方向开。它就像个棘轮装置，人们只能默默忍受这种状况，你知道的，正如他对汽车的这种狂热偏好，以及他对
Yeah. And, and Carol gets to at the end of this kind of long section about how crappy the subway has gotten and how crappy the Long Island railroad has gotten. He gets to this idea that the worst toll of it isn't seen in kind of sporadic violence that happens when people get mad and they get going to like train rage. And it's not, we're seen in the accidents that take place on the train because that the trains themselves are not Well maintained but in this general
公共交通的这种根深蒂固的偏见。是的。而且，在关于地铁和长岛铁路变得多么糟糕的这长长一段的末尾，卡罗谈到了这样一个观点：这种状况带来的最糟糕的代价，并不是人们因愤怒而爆发、甚至演变成“路怒”或“车怒”那种零星的暴力事件。它也不是
passivity and helplessness and kind of defeated giving in that the commuters just put up with that they just live in a state of constant discomfort and exhaustion related to the trip they have to take to get between their home and work every day and to the trip they have to take to get between their home and work every day. And a few times in this passage, Carrow repeats the phrase, get used to it, in italics. And he uses italics only when he is particularly grieved about things, you know, or only when he's particularly mad about things. And he's just appalled at the idea of getting used to misery. And he says in italics, we learn to tolerate intolerable conditions. And it feels like when I read it, there's such anger behind that.
体现在火车上发生的事故中——尽管火车本身确实没有得到良好的维护——而是体现在通勤者只能逆来顺受的那种普遍的被动、无助和绝望的妥协中。他们只是生活在因每天往返于家和工作单位之间的旅程而带来的持续不适与精疲力竭的状态中，忍受着这一切。在这段文字中，卡罗多次用斜体重复了“习惯就好”（get used to it）这个短语。只有当他对某些事情感到格外悲痛时，你知道的，或者只有当他对某些事情感到格外愤怒时，他才会使用斜体。对于“习惯苦难”这种想法，他感到震惊无比。他在斜体字中写道：我们学会了容忍不可容忍的状况。当我读到这里时，我感觉那背后的愤怒极其强烈。
Not just at the idea that people are underserved by this, that it makes people's lives more difficult, but that there's this standardization of routine discomfort that numbs you to the pain that you're feeling in your life as a result of these systems, and also ultimately numbs you to the value of your life. Because if you're living through this every day, maybe you internalize it and you think,
不仅仅是因为人们被这套系统冷落、生活变得更加艰难，更是因为这种日常不适的标准化，会麻木你对生活中因这些系统而感受到的痛苦的感知，最终也麻木了你对自身生命价值的感知。因为如果你每天都经历这一切，也许你就会内化这种感受，并认为：
maybe I don't deserve more than that. And that it is not just stealing time from people, it's not just stealing comfort from people, but stealing in a very real sense, this kind of faith in their own lives and the ability to think of their own lives being better than they are. That sense that tomorrow can be better than today.
也许我根本不值得拥有更好的生活。这不仅是在窃取人们的时间，不仅是在窃取人们的舒适，更是在极其真实意义上，窃取了人们对自己生活的信念，窃取了他们想象自己能过上更好生活的愿望。那种明天会比今天更好的信念。
I'm reading quite a lot into it, but I feel like it's mostly there, mostly there. That he seems very, very angry at the idea of people having to acclimate themselves to discomfort. And that's something that I don't hear very much in discussions of transit. Even today, it's mostly about how fast, how efficient, how much money is this gonna cost, and very rarely about what is the human experience of riding on this train or riding on this highway, which is the most important aspect of it because it's the human part of it.
我在这里过度解读了不少，但我感觉这些情绪基本都在那里，实实在在地都在那里。他似乎对人们不得不去适应不适感这件事感到非常、非常愤怒。在关于交通的讨论中，我很少听到这种声音。即便在今天，讨论也大多集中在：速度有多快、效率有多高、会花多少钱，而极少去讨论乘坐这列火车或这条高速公路到底是一种什么样的“人类体验”。而这恰恰是最重要的方面，因为这是其中属于人的部分。
And we're people. I hate to break it to you, everybody, but we're people. So the people aspect is the most important one to me. And truly this whole series of events is set in motion by the decision to do the Long Island Expressway the way it was, to not sort of think of it as a grand plan, that the Long Island Expressway creates a low density, that low density can no longer support a train
我们是人。我很抱歉打破大家的幻想，各位，我们是人。所以对我来说，人的维度才是最重要的一点。老实说，这一连串事件的导火索，正是决定以那种方式修建长岛高速公路（LIE），而不是将其视作一个宏伟的整体规划。长岛高速公路导致了低密度发展，而这种低密度再也无法支撑一条铁路，
even if they wanted to have a train after the fact. It just continues like this was set into motion. I mean, this is really what the point of no return is about. Yes, he zeros in finally after this kind of wide ranging look at rails on exactly that. It's 1955, the Long Island Expressway, and he reminds us Long Island, as the name suggests, is an island.
即便事后他们想要修建铁路也无济于事。事情就这样顺理成章地推进了。我的意思是，这正是所谓“不归路”的真正含义。是的，在对铁路进行了如此广泛的审视之后，他最终将焦点精确锁定了这一点。那是1955年，长岛高速公路项目，他提醒我们：长岛，顾名思义，是一个岛屿。
Like you can only go so far out in one direction before the land just stops and becomes water. The only way to go in the is the other direction into the city. And inevitably, that means congestion if all you have is this road to get there. And if you don't have this mass transit. And meanwhile, Long Island's population is growing and growing and growing. It's no longer the bucolic open fields and robber barren estates and small farms that Moses walked through 30 years ago in the 1920s. It's suburban sprawl. It's filling up. And again, Caro's going to get into statistics
你顺着一个方向走不了多远，陆地就会戛然而止，变成水域。唯一的出路就是反方向进入城市。而不可避免地，如果拥有的只有这条进城道路，这意味着拥堵。如果你没有这种公共交通系统的话。与此同时，长岛的人口却在不断增长、增长、再增长。这里不再是摩西三十年前的1920年代走过的田园牧歌般的开阔田野、富豪庄园和小农场。这里变成了市郊蔓延区（suburban sprawl）。它正在被填满。同样，卡罗又要搬出统计数据
and numbers. We don't have to get into all those. He does have one line. He goes, onto Long Island's potato fields was going to be dumped a population the size of Philadelphia, which look, I said a lot of things about Philadelphia. It's very useful as a metric for the number of people moving into Long Island and just that there's no way these roads can ever handle it. And he says, attempting to handle traffic in such volumes by building highways just didn't make sense. And he looks at each thing. Okay, Moses is not going to build a train.
和数字了。我们不必深究所有这些。他确实有一句名言：将有一个堪比费城人口规模的群体被倾倒进长岛的马铃薯田里。听着，我对费城没有恶意，它作为一个衡量迁入长岛人口数量的标准非常有用，只是这些道路根本无法承受如此庞大的车流。他指出，试图通过修建高速公路来应对如此巨大的交通流量根本说不通。他审视了每一项措施。好吧，摩西不打算修建铁路。
What about making it easier for buses to go through? No, he doesn't want that either. Buses are for losers. He says. He says buses are for losers. And he says once the LIE is in place, once it's built, this opportunity to change the density, to make it easier to get in and out, to make it easier to get around, is gone. If you make cars the only way to commute from this place to the city, then you lock in this development forever as just the default state of the region. And he says, build the Long Island Expressway with mass transit, or at least with provision for future installation of mass transit, and Long Island might remain a good place to live and play. Build the Long Island expressway without mass transit and Long Island would be lost, certainly for decades,
那让公交车通行更顺畅总行吧？不，他连这个也不想要。公交车是给失败者准备的，他说。他说公交车是给失败者准备的。他还说，一旦长岛高速公路（LIE）落成，一旦它建成，这种改变人口密度、让进出更便利、让出行更轻松的机会就彻底消失了。如果你让汽车成为从这个地方通勤进城的唯一方式，那么你就把这种发展形态永久锁定了，使其成为该地区的默认状态。他说：修建带有公共交通的长岛高速公路，或者至少为未来加装公共交通预留空间，长岛或许还能成为一个适合居住和玩乐的好地方。而修建没有公共交通的长岛高速公路，长岛就会走向毁灭，至少几十年内如此，
probably for centuries, possibly forever. Which sounds a little melodramatic. A lot of people do live in Long Island. Robert Carer, I think has a vacation place, has like a summer home or a weekend home in Long Island. So people do live there, but they have to put up with this abysmal traffic, this abysmal way of getting in and out to go to the city. Yeah. One of the things I actually like in this description that Robert Carr talks about is kind of ahead of its time when he's writing it in the early 1970s, is that despite what I put on the attitude of Robert Moses that buses are for losers, is that buses are kind of the greatest,
很可能是几个世纪，甚至可能是永远。这听起来有点夸张。确实有很多人住在长岛。罗伯特·卡罗，我想他在长岛有个度假屋，有个夏屋或周末住宅。所以人们确实住在那里，但他们必须忍受这种糟糕透顶的交通，忍受这种进出城市的糟糕方式。是的。事实上，罗伯特·卡罗讨论的这种描述中，我非常喜欢的一点是，当他在20世纪70年代初写下这些时，它有着超越时代的眼光。尽管罗伯特·摩西抱有“公交车是给失败者准备的”这种态度，但公交车其实是解决这些问题最伟大、
most flexible way to solve these problems. And to have like a rapid transit lane that's devoted to buses is extremely effective, low cost way to like unmake a lot of these mistakes that people made with roads, like other cities like Medellin, like they've just totally revolutionized traffic by putting in dedicated
最具灵活性的方式。拥有专属公交的快速公交车道（BRT），是一种极其有效且低成本的方式，能够扭转人们在道路规划上犯下的许多错误。就像其他城市（如麦德林）通过引入专用
bus lanes. And he kind of presents that as an idea here as a way to be the remedy for this. But it just goes nowhere because Robert Moses just doesn't believe in it. But I love, you can tell that he is paying attention to Louis Mumford in this time. Like he's aware of this, the thinking that's going on. And it strikes me as being very early in, you know, kind of a popular nonfiction book to be talking about this in these ways. I find it pretty prescient. Yeah. I think so too. One thing that is, and we'll talk about bridges and buses in a moment because we're about to get to one of the
公交车道，彻底革新了交通状况。他在这里把这个想法作为解决问题的一种对策提了出来。但这个方案最终不了了之，因为罗伯特·摩西根本不相信它。不过我喜欢的一点是，你能看出他在那个时期一直在关注刘易斯·芒福德（Lewis Mumford）。他意识到了当时正在进行的这种思考。在一本探讨此类议题的通俗非虚构读物中，能这么早就以这种方式展开探讨，这让我觉得非常深刻。我发现这相当有远见。是的，我也这么认为。有一件事——我们稍后会讨论桥梁和公交车，因为我们即将接触到其中更具争议的
more controversial parts of it. But one thing that I wonder, and this is something Carol could not have been prescient about, but I was thinking about today is I wonder if these sections read a little differently and I wonder if the experience is a little different now. In the world we live in now where the option of remote work or at least part-time remote work is a thing that people are living with, that Robert Carrow is taking it as such a given that you have a job, you need to go to that job And so if you live in Long Island, you're probably commuting to Manhattan We're somewhere in the New York area and you cannot get out of it. And I wonder if that is in some way
部分之一——但有一件事我一直在琢磨：这是卡罗当时不可能具有先见之明的地方，但我今天一直在思考，我不知道这些章节在今天读起来是否会有些许不同，我不知道现在的体验是否有所不同。在我们今天生活的世界里，远程工作（或至少是部分时间远程工作）的选择已经成为人们生活的一部分。罗伯特·卡罗当时却把“你必须有工作、你必须去上班”视为一种绝对的前提。因此，如果你住在长岛，你很可能就要通勤去曼哈顿，或者纽约地区的某个地方，而且你根本无法摆脱这种生活方式。我在想，这是否在某种程度上
Alleviating things a little bit probably not at the scale necessary like the traffic on the LA is still ridiculous But I wonder if that if these sections read differently to a younger person who is like, well, why do I have to go in to my job? Why can't I do it from home? Which of course in 1974 and certainly in 1955 when the LIE was built was impossible. You could not do that. I mean, what it points out to me
稍微缓解了一些问题？可能并没有达到所需要的规模——长岛高速公路上的交通依然荒谬绝伦——但我很好奇，对于一个年轻的现代人来说，当他们读到这些章节时，是否会有不同的感受。他们会想：“为什么我非得去公司上班？为什么我不能在家办公？”当然，在1974年，更不用说在1955年长岛高速公路修建之时，这是绝对不可能的。你当时根本做不到这一点。我的意思是，这向我指出的
is I would sort of like flip that and say essentially like, given the flexibility of work or the greater flexibility of work today, it really points out how it was an even worse decision in 1955 to make these choices. And that there probably is a greater spread of people on Long Island just working nearby or working at home than there was then.
是——我会把这种逻辑倒过来思考并说：本质上，鉴于今天工作的灵活性或更高的灵活性，这恰恰凸显了1955年做出这些选择是多么糟糕的决定。如今在长岛，可能确实有更多的人选择在附近工作或在家办公，比当年要多。
But that just goes to show the degree in which Moses had blinders on about the sort of whole issue, the whole problem. Yeah, because you can't, in 1955, you can't call and be like, boss, I'm going to work from home today. And be like, how? All the paper is here. Like, there's no, I think the only people working from home in Long Island at the time were comic book artists. And they still had to drive in with their art to hand it into the editor, you know. The, and of course, it's the same story here that we talked about before. You don't have to build the tracks right now.
但这恰恰说明了摩西在整个议题、整个问题上是有多么盲目。是的，因为在1955年，你不可能打电话说：“老板，我今天要在家里办公。”对方会问：“怎么办公？所有的纸质文件都在这儿呢。”当时的办公室里没有……我想长岛当时唯一在家工作的只有漫画家。而且他们还得开车把画作送到编辑手里，你知道的。而且，当然，这里的故事和我们之前讨论的一样：你现在根本不需要把轨道修好。
Just leave that space in the middle of the road, and we can build the tracks later, and he just doesn't want to do it. And the study that like shows even bending over backwards for Moses to put rails in the worst possible light, the study still shows just how much cheaper and more efficient, more effective it would be, but Moses just doesn't want to do it. So he just starts building. And by the time that the big proposal for a rail line is finished, the proposal has to say, our own proposal is obsolete because the road is already too far ahead to do anything, doesn't matter, and this gets no mention in the newspapers. It's so easily buried, the idea that anybody considered doing this before the road started being built.
只要在路中央留出那个空间，我们以后再铺轨道就行了，可他偏偏就是不肯这么做。即使是那份研究报告——它甚至做出了极大让步，试图把摩西的铁路方案放在最糟糕的角度来看待——依然表明修建铁路是多么便宜、高效和有效，但摩西就是不想这么做。于是他开始大兴土木。等到大型铁路方案终于完成时，方案却不得不这样写：我们自己的方案已经过时了，因为道路建设已经遥遥领先，做什么都无济于事了，而且这件事在报纸上根本没有激起半点水花。这种“在道路开建前曾有人考虑过修建铁路”的想法，就这样被轻而易举地掩埋了。
Yeah, it's the classic steak driving move that he does. Before he can sort of respond to any criticism, before anything can be done, the system is working so slowly that he just starts building things, and therefore, it's a fait accompli. There's no way that you can actually put in a railroad at this point. And again, this is like the thinking of this,
是的，这就是他惯用的那种“生米煮成熟饭”的伎俩。在任何批评声来得及反应之前，在任何事情来得及改变之前，官僚系统的运作虽然缓慢，但他却已经开始大兴土木了，因此一切成了既定事实。此时此刻，你根本不可能再把铁路塞进去了。再说，这种思维方式，
it sort of gets me sort of incensed the way when you think about all those potential subways and rail lines that could have made your life better. Like I think about this, you know, like if going back and thinking about, oh, the entire highway system, like what if they just put a rail line between every median?
每当我想到那些本可以让你的生活变得更好的潜在地铁和铁路线时，就会让我怒火中烧。就像我有时会想，你知道的：如果回过头来想想，哦，整个高速公路系统——如果在每条道路的隔离带中间都修建一条铁路线，会怎么样？
Like, you know, what if they did that? What could we have today? It makes so much sense. And I don't know if I've ever really thought about it that way that you could, in a widespread way, think about every road is having a train line next to it would be kind of a stunning achievement. We would be able to have a totally different life now.
就像，你知道的，如果他们那样做了呢？我们今天会拥有什么？这太合乎情理了。我不知道自己是否真的曾这样思考过：如果在广泛的范围内，让每条道路旁边都伴有一条铁路线，那将是一项惊人的成就。我们今天的生活将完全不同。
It would be amazing. Roman, don't, I'm already sad enough about the stuff that didn't get built that Carol mentions in the book. Don't mention even bigger things that would make life even better and easier that we don't have. It would just change the nature of the whole country and in these ways that would be really amazing.
那将是惊人的。罗曼，别说了——对于卡罗在书中提到那些未能建成的设施，我已经够伤心的了。别再提那些会让生活变得更好、更轻松却偏偏没有的宏大构想了。那将彻底改变整个国家的面貌，而且会以一种真正令人惊叹的方式。
And it would have been so easy and cheap. Like it just like the lack of forward thinking about that is kind of blows my mind. I mean, I guess the only argument is what you're describing. It's not technically socialism, but it sounds close enough to it that it's making me uncomfortable. So, no, but you're right.
而且本可以如此轻松且廉价。那种缺乏远见的做法简直让我大开眼界。我的意思是，唯一的争论点大概就是你所描述的那种情况。这在技术上虽然不是社会主义，但听起来已经足够接近了，让我感到有些不适。所以，好吧，不过你说得对。
It would have been, it just, I mean, it all comes down to, I think, that one of the things that I think Caro is so aware of in this, that all decisions made about the way we live are decisions. They're all choices and none of them are inevitable. And if you have someone who's sufficiently forward thinking, you can make amazing choices and decisions and you end up with something like Jones Beach that otherwise wouldn't exist.
这本可以……我的意思是，这一切归根结底，我认为，正如卡罗在书中意识到的那样：我们生活方式的每一个决定其实都是决定。它们全都是选择，没有哪个是不可避免的。如果你有一个具备足够远见的人，你就能做出惊人的选择和决定，最终你就会得到琼斯海滩（Jones Beach）这样否则根本不会存在的东西。
And if you have someone who is very far seeking but is making bad choices and decisions, then you get the Long Island Expressway with no trains on it at all, which I hate to, I hate to spoil this for you, Roman, but it opens up and it is almost instantly congested. And just year after year is, is Carol Quote's drivers calling it the world's longest parking lot. Yeah. Moses solution, you guessed it, make it bigger. And that, which makes it even worse because now while they're finishing the later stages
而如果你有一个志向高远但却做出糟糕选择和决定的人，那么你就会得到一条连一根铁轨都没有的长岛高速公路。我不愿——我不愿扫你的兴，罗曼，但它刚一通车，几乎立刻就陷入了拥堵。而且年复一年，正如卡罗引用司机们的话所说，它成了“世界上最长的停车场”。是的。摩西的解决办法，你猜到了：把它扩建得更大。而这反而让情况变得更糟，因为当他们在进行长岛高速公路后期工程收尾的时候，
of the LIE, they are rebuilding the later stages of the LIE, they are rebuilding the earlier stages of it to make them wider. And that construction work only adds to the amount of traffic. And Carol says in 1974, when he was writing this book, there are still plans to widen the Long Island Expressway that will stretch out to the end of the century.
他们正在重建长岛高速公路的后期路段，同时又在回过头来把前期路段拓宽。这种建设工程只会进一步加剧交通拥堵。卡罗在1974年写这本书时指出，当时依然有将长岛高速公路进一步拓宽、一直延伸到世纪末的计划。
And I don't know if they, I assume they finished at some point, but I don't, maybe they didn't. Maybe it's one of those things like in a Borges story where as soon as they're done with it, they just start rebuilding it again, you know. Who knows if it's the same road anymore? Yeah, yeah, it's crazy. And, you know, he's describing it like you said, there's this island, it's an island with a choke point. And by the time you get to the, you extend it out to the east, the west is insufficient to do the job. And so they just keep building it, widen it again.
我不知道他们后来——我假设他们在某个时候完成了，但我不知道，也许他们根本没完成。也许这就跟博尔赫斯（Borges）小说里的情节一样：刚修好，他们就立刻开始重新翻修了，你知道的。谁知道这到底还是不是原来的那条路？是的，是的，太疯狂了。而且，正如你所说，他描述了这样一个地方：这是一个岛，一个带有交通瓶颈的岛。当你把它向东延伸时，西边的容量根本无法胜任这项工作。于是他们就只能不断修建、再次拓宽。
And it's just one of those things that is just, again, really, really upsetting. Like this is the thing that he can somehow wrap his mind around changing or improving, but he can't conceive of a world in which, when you improved it, you could just make a place for a rail line or make the overpasses taller, which gets us to one of the major talking points when it comes to this book, which is the height of the underpasses
这就是那种再次让人感到非常、非常沮丧的事情。这是他不知为何能转过弯来去改变或改进的东西，但他却根本无法想象这样一个世界：当你在改进它的时候，可以顺便为铁路线留出空间，或者把立交桥修得更高一些。这就引出了本书最主要的争论点之一，那就是立交桥的净空高度——
like where cars are going through, the bridge is going over them, they are not very tall. They're not tall enough specifically for buses to go under them on any outer lanes. Yes. And a bus can go, technically a bus can go through the center lanes, but as Carol says, any bus line manager is not going to send their buses down a highway where there's only one lane basically that they can use in each direction. What if the bus breaks down? What if there's a lot of traffic? They've got to keep up a schedule. And there's been a ton of argument one way or the other about whether this height for bridge was standard practice at the time, whether it's unfair to accuse Moses of deliberately keeping buses off, whether it's unfair to read a racial element to that or a class element to that.
也就是汽车穿行的桥梁、跨越它们的桥梁，它们的高度并不高。具体来说，它们的高度不足以让公交车在任何外侧车道通过。是的。虽然从技术上讲，公交车可以通过中央车道，但正如卡罗所说，任何公交车公司的经理都不会把他们的公交车派往这样一条高速公路上：在那里，每个方向基本上只有一条车道是它们可以使用的。如果公交车抛锚了怎么办？如果交通非常拥堵怎么办？他们必须维持时刻表。关于这种桥梁高度在当时是否属于标准做法、指责摩西故意把公交车挡在外面是否不公、以及其中是否包含种族或阶层因素，各方已经有过铺天盖地的争论。
And it's always surprised me the controversy of it because in that section, Carol literally quotes Sid Shapiro, Moses right- man saying, yeah, we kept the bridges too low so that buses couldn't go through and kind of reminiscing in a happy way about the few buses that tried and had their roofs smashed in, you know, or he touched out one where the top was rolled back like a can of sardines. And it's like, I don't know, if you got it straight from the guy who was working with Moses, then it seems like whether other people in other places were doing that, I feel like that's all you need. That's as close as you're going to get to Moses saying, yeah, this is why I did it.
这场争议总是让我感到惊讶，因为在该章节中，卡罗字面意义上引用了西德·夏皮罗（Sid Shapiro，摩西的得力助手）的话，对方说：“没错，我们把桥建得很低，这样公交车就过不去。”并且还带着快乐的回忆，谈起那些试图通过却被削掉车顶的稀少公交车，你知道的，或者他提到了一辆车顶像沙丁鱼罐头一样被掀开的公交车。我想，如果这些话直接来自跟摩西共事的人，那么无论其他地方的其他人当时在做什么，我觉得这就已经足够了。这就是你能得到的最接近摩西亲口承认的证据：“没错，这就是我这么干的原因。”
Yeah. And him, you know, like sort of being very, very clear about using the roads as a way to sort of gatekeep people from being in different places. He's very explicit about that as a motivation for him when he builds things and when he's talking to like the Nassau County officials, you know? And so to have it expressed in that way, like his intent, he always had this part of his sort of intention
是的。而且他——你知道的——非常、非常明确地将道路作为把不同群体隔离开来的守门工具。当他建造这些设施以及与拿骚县（Nassau County）官员交谈时，他把这作为自己的一种明确动机，你知道吗？因此，当它以这种方式表达出来时——他的意图——他在建造事物时，心里一直存着这样的部分。让西德·夏皮罗谈论它，让它们在重建时稍微改变一点——也许在后续的一些立交桥中有所增加，稍微拔高了一点——但我觉得，我不明白。
when he built things to have Sid Shapiro talk about it, to have them like change a little bit, maybe when they get rebuilt, you know, there's like some increase in some of them to get a little taller for later, you know, overpasses, but like it's, I don't get it. Like, like, like I don't get what sort of daylight there is here to sort of create a kind of doubt. I don't get what sort of daylight there is here to sort of create a kind of doubt. I don't know.
就像，我完全搞不懂这里到底有什么可以辩解的灰色地带，能让人产生某种怀疑。我搞不懂这里到底有什么可以辩解的灰色地带，能让人产生某种怀疑。我不知道。
I wonder if it's just a human need to kind of poke holes in things, that there's so much that's claimed by this book and so much that's backed up, to be able to find something that feels like you could say, mm, this is not true. And then to use that as the loose thread
我在想，这或许只是人类天生的一种挑刺需求：这本书里有太多的断言，也有太多的证据支撑，人们总希望能挑出一处感觉可以反驳的地方，说：“嗯，这不是真的。”然后把这作为线头，
that you're gonna pull out and unravel the rest with. But I don't know, it's one of those things that I've never quite understood the arguments against taking Sid Shapiro at his word and taking Caro at his word that Sid Shapiro said this thing. And so it's strange that this is one of the controversial parts,
去抽丝剥茧，试图把其余的部分全部解体。但我不知道，这是我一直无法完全理解的那些论点之一：为什么人们要去反驳西德·夏皮罗原话不假、卡罗引述西德·夏皮罗的话不假的事实。所以很奇怪，这居然成了颇具争议的部分之一，
but people get very agitated about bridges, I guess. Maybe they feel very sensitive about bridge heights. I feel like what people are reacting to is the collapsing of the narrative of Moses didn't want black people at Jones Beach and therefore made the bridges too short for buses. And then people go, but there were bus lines that kind of made it go, but there were bus lines
但大家似乎对桥梁问题情绪异常激动，我猜。也许他们对桥梁高度有着某种高度的敏感。我觉得人们的反应，其实是对这种简化版叙事的反弹：即“摩西不希望黑人去琼斯海滩，因此故意把桥修得太低不让公交车通过”。然后有人就会说：“不对，当时其实有一些公交车线路……”
that kind of made it there, but they weren't very extensive. And it's kind of like, yeah, but there was a black section of Jones Beach. And like, but what they're arguing against, I think is that collapsed version, you know, told, you know, like around a campfire. The shorthand. Yeah, around the campfire.
勉强能通过，但它们的覆盖范围并不广泛。这就有点像：“对，但琼斯海滩其实曾有一个专门供黑人使用的区域。”我认为他们反驳的，其实是那种经过层层简化、在营火晚会上传播的版本。断章取义的简略版。是的，营火晚会上的传言。
Yeah, and the scariest story is told at infrastructure camp. Yeah. And I think that's what they're reacting to and mainly trying to, in their way, they're trying to add nuance to that narrative that feels too collapsed and too simple. But I think that when you take in the book as a whole and the section as a whole,
是的，基础设施营火晚会上流传的最吓人的故事。我想这就是他们的反应，他们试图以自己的方式，为那种过于简化、流于表面的叙事增添一些细微的差别。但我觉得，当你把整本书和这一整章结合起来看时，
it just has so much support in it. And even if there are other bridges and other things that are low and they weren't forward thinking in the same way, it was clear that they were taking advantage of that convention to still get these same ends. So I think that's kind of where it lands. It just is really about people objecting
它背后有着极其坚实的支撑。即便还有其他的桥梁和其他地方高度较低且没有同样的前瞻性思维，但很明显，他们确实在利用这种惯例来达到同样的目的。所以我想这就是症结所在。这其实是关于人们在反对
to the shorthand version of this rather than what's actually written. And what's actually written is like a quote from Sid Shapiro, like laughing about it. Like it's hard to argue that. Yeah, to me it's just funny that this is one of the big things that people go after in the book. It feels a little bit like in online debates,
这种简化的说法，而不是反对实际写下来的文字。而实际写下来的文字分明是西德·夏皮罗对此发出嘲笑的引语。这实在很难反驳。是的，在我看来，滑稽的是，这居然成了人们在书中揪住不放的大问题之一。这感觉有点像我们在网络辩论中看到的现象：
you'll see someone refer to an AR-15 as an assault rifle and somebody will say, that's not what the AR stands for, you don't even know what you're talking about. It's like, you're right, I got the initials wrong on that. Therefore, people don't get hurt with guns, you're right. They're wonderful, because I didn't know the terminology properly,
你会看到有人把AR-15步枪称为突击步枪，然后就有人跳出来说：“那根本不是AR代表的意思，你根本不知道自己在胡说八道。”这就好像在说：“没错，我确实把首字母缩写弄错了。所以，人们不会被枪支伤害，你是对的。枪真是太棒了，因为我不懂专业术语，
you beat me. And somehow arguing that this doesn't, this is just like a little star in the constellation of what Robert Moses did. And it fits as part of that completely. Like it is not a deviation from the rest of his patterns and behavior. It's really right there. And so again, it's like picking it out as its own thing is strange to me because all of this short-sighted thinking, all of this classism, all of this like non-system thinking and not caring about how these pieces fit together and serve a whole community is just,
你把我击败了。”不知为何，去争辩这件事并不成立，或者把它当作罗伯特·摩西所作所为这一浩瀚星图中的一颗小星。它完全是其中有机的一部分。这与他的其他行为模式和行事风格并无偏差。它就明摆在那里。所以再次强调，把它单拎出来作为异类来批判让我觉得很奇怪，因为这种目光短浅的思维、这种精英主义、这种缺乏系统性的思考，以及不关心这些碎片如何拼合在一块并为一个完整的社区服务的态度，
is a part of his whole career for decades and decades. And so if it was somehow a deviation, is a part of his whole career for decades and decades. And so if it was somehow a deviation, then it seems like it's sort of more right for criticism, but it really just sort of fits in with everything else. Yeah, like you're saying, it fits with Moses' desires, his preferences, like his overall themes. And what Caro is basically saying at the end of this chapter is that he has had the foresight
贯穿了他长达数十年的整个职业生涯。所以，如果它真的是某种偏差，那它似乎才更应该成为被批评的靶子，但它实际上完美契合了他所做的一切。是的，正如你所说，它完全契合摩西的愿望、他的偏好，以及他的整体主题。卡罗在本章末尾基本上要表达的是：他拥有远见
to lock in those desires for future generations, that by building this way, he has made it so that future generations have to travel the way Robert Moses would prefer to them to travel. And in Caro's view that says doomed Long Island to a messy and congestion-based development pattern, I honestly don't know if that's changed since then. Maybe Long Island has opened up and become a traveler's paradise. I'll never know. I just refuse to find out.
将这些愿望永久封存并强加给子孙后代；通过这种方式建构城市，他迫使未来的世代必须按照罗伯特·摩西所期望的方式出行。在卡罗看来，这注定了长岛将走向混乱且以拥堵为特征的发展模式。我老实说不知道自那以后这种情况是否发生了改变。也许长岛已经敞开胸怀，变成了旅行者的天堂。我永远不会知道了。我只是拒绝去寻找答案。
In this chapter, in ending on that point of Moses, through his use of concrete and steel, has locked in a way of living for generations, if not centuries, that he wants people to have, even if they don't necessarily want it, even if it's damaging to them. We have reached the capstone and the end of the Moses triumphant section of the book. This is the Act 2, in which Moses has had his power, enhanced it, and wrecks havoc with it. We saw Act 1, in which young Moses learned the ways of power and gained that power.
在本章中，以摩西通过混凝土和钢筋将一种生活方式锁定给世世代代——甚至延续几个世纪——这一观点作结：这是他希望人们过上的生活，即便人们并不一定想要，即便这种生活对他们有害。我们已经迎来了本书“摩西凯旋”部分的巅峰与尾声。这是第二幕，在这一幕中，摩西掌握了权力，不断巩固权力，并用它肆虐破坏。我们看过了第一幕，年轻的摩西在那里摸索权力的运作方式并赢得了权力。
This has been the end of Act 2, in which he has reached the ways of power and gained that power. This has been the end of Act 2, in which he has reached the apex of that power and used it to decide how people living in Long Island now will get in and out of New York, which the way I put it just now doesn't sound like a major victory, but it is. Trust me, there's millions of people that he's dealing with. Now we're about to enter Act 3, Moses's hubristic downfall. And reading the book again, spoiler as we get into this, it strikes me that this downfall section, you want it to be because the system rises up, some brave hero is able to turn the tide and get him. But more than anything, it seems to be because Moses is just getting older and he's losing his faculties and he
这是第二幕的尾声，在这一幕中，他达到了权力的巅峰，并利用它来决定今天生活在长岛的人们将如何进出纽约。我刚才的表达听起来可能不像什么伟大的胜利，但它确实是。相信我，他面对的是数百万民众。现在，我们即将进入第三幕：摩西因傲慢而导致的垮台。再次重读这本书时——剧透一下，当我们进入这部分时——给我的感觉是，这个走向垮台的部分，你会希望它是由于体制的奋起反抗、某个勇敢的英雄力挽狂澜将他拉下马。但相比之下，它更像是由于摩西日渐年迈、各项机能衰退，他已经
can't navigate the system the way he used to. And I think that is part of Caro's point is that the system did not self-correct here. Moses just overreached by aging out of his potential, his highest level of power. And we're going to see it, but you kind of, I'm going to warn people, they're not going to get the downfall that they want, which is for Moses to be pushed out by a crowd of well-meaning protesters or things like that, or to be pushed out by a crowd of well-meaning, you know, protesters or things like that, or, you know, to be put on trial or something. Instead, it's going to be much, much slimier and more self-destructive and a
无法像过去那样在官僚体制中翻云覆雨了。我认为这也是卡罗观点的一部分：体制在这里并没有自我纠错。摩西只是因为年事已高、超出了其潜力与权力巅峰的支撑极限而走向了过度扩张。我们将看到这一过程，但我得提前警告各位读者，他们不会得到他们期望的那种垮台——那种由一群心怀善意的抗议者等把摩西赶下台的结局，或者被一群心怀善意的抗议者等推翻的结局，亦或是被送上法庭审判的结局。相反，这个过程会变得极其、极其龌龊，且充满自我毁灭性
little bit less satisfying. Roman, do you feel the same way? Well, I would sort of add one other thing, which is he does seem to have worse and worse ability to deal with the public, but the public is somehow has the platform, has the will, has a bit of the organization to kind of give him a few flesh wounds along the way. I mean, and they seem to be landing more. I mean, like famously, the Jane Jacobs chapter. I mean, like, famously, you know, the Jane Jacobs chapter
稍微有点不够尽兴。罗曼，你也有同感吗？嗯，我差不多要补充另一件事，那就是他在处理公众关系方面的能力似乎越来越差，但公众不知为何却拥有了发声的平台、意愿以及一些组织能力，能在这一过程中给他造成一些皮外伤。我的意思是，而且这些攻击似乎越来越有效了。我的意思是，就像大名鼎鼎的简·雅各布斯那一章。我的意思是，像大名鼎鼎的，你知道的，简·雅各布斯那一章
of this was taken out. That would have happened probably a little bit... Right, right, I'm trying to... Where would it happen? But it would have been... Yeah, it would have been a little bit later. It would have been like the early 60s, late 50s, I think, was the fight over the lower Manhattan Expressway, I think.
的内容被删掉了。那件事大概发生在……对，对，我在想……那会发生在什么地方？但它应该……对，应该会稍微晚一点。我记得大概是60年代初、50年代末，那场关于下曼哈顿高速公路的论战，我觉得。
But it's clear that there is, even in these chapters, it's clear that there is, even in these chapters, it's clear that there is opposition forming in the public. They're not really identifying it as Robert Moses is the culprit. When people are talking about traffic is bad and traffic and the cars aren't the solution and the expressways aren't the solution, they're not really tying that to Robert Moses in the papers.
但很显然，即便在这些章节里，公众中也明显正在形成反对势力。他们并没有真正把罗伯特·摩西视为罪魁祸首。当人们在报纸上讨论交通状况有多糟糕、交通和汽车并不是解决问题的办法、高速公路也不是解决办法时，他们并没有真正把这些与罗伯特·摩西联系起来。
But like they'll begin to, and then there'll be some dumb like follies that he'll make later on where he's like, you know, like where he's just making bad decisions that are, that have bad PR, which is something that he wouldn't have done earlier on, you know, like he's so full of himself that he just doesn't think bad press relates to him, but he does get a bit on that later on, but I do think that there's
但他们会开始这样做的，然后他会在晚些时候犯下一些愚蠢的错误，比如他会做出一些糟糕的决策，带来不好的公关效果——这是他在早期不会做的事，你知道的，他太自负了，根本不认为负面报道会波及到自己，但他在后来确实为此吃了不少苦头，不过我认为，
a little bit more agency in the public to take him on. And that sort of like runs against him being a little less savvy and a little less able to take care of it. And then he runs against a, you know, later on an equally arrogant person. Yeah, I think you're right. You know, I think I was overstating things by saying that it was just his own kind of folly and not the system. I think this is something that I should point out later after we've talked about it more,
公众对抗他的自主性确实增强了一些。这就和他变得不那么精明、不太能够掌控局势形成了一种对立。然后，他随后又碰上了一个同样傲慢的人。是的，我觉得你说得对。你知道的，我之前说这只是他个人的某种愚蠢行为而不是体制的问题，这话确实有点夸大其词了。我想这是我稍后在我们讨论得更多时应该指出的，
but I'm almost inevitably going to forget. So I'm gonna mention it now, because this is something I should say next episode, is that Robert Moses has been having his way with the city in large part because he has been doing damaging things to the lower classes, and he's been doing helpful things to the upper classes. But there's one class that he has kind of had a good reputation
但我几乎肯定会忘。所以我现在就把它提出来，因为这是我下一集应该说的话，那就是罗伯特·摩西之所以能在城市里为所欲为，很大程度上是因为他一直在对下层阶级做着破坏性的事，同时又在为上层阶级做着有益的事。但有一个阶级，他与之保持着不错的声誉，
with but other than kind of Jones beaches, Jones, Jones beaches and playgrounds things like that. He hasn't had as much interaction with other than building roads and that's the middle class. And the middle and the upper middle class, once he starts rubbing them the wrong way and getting on their bad side that you're, I think you're right that that that's what really starts to hasten his downfall. Yeah, and the middle class in the 50s and 60s is growing, and they're going to be a really powerful voting block in setting the opinions and the agenda for things.
除了琼斯海滩、琼斯海滩和游乐场之类的事情之外。除了修建道路，他与该阶层的互动并不多，那就是中产阶级。当中产阶级和中上阶级开始对他产生反感、惹恼了他们之后，我想你是对的，这才是真正开始加速他走向垮台的原因。是的，50年代和60年代的中产阶级正在壮大，他们将成为一支非常强大的投票力量，决定各种事物的观点和议程。
And that's the sort of golden age of the middle class. And as he's getting weaker, they're able to find sort of like chinks in his armor at the same time. And I think both things are working in concert to bring him to his loss of power, which is part seven, which happens next after the break. Beautiful segue. Radio, 20 years. Okay, now we're up to part seven, the loss of power. We have made it. Elliot, Kaelin, we're already here. It feels so good to finally be at this section, the loss of power.
那是中产阶级所谓的黄金时代。而当他变得虚弱时，他们同时也能够在他的盔甲上找到裂痕。我认为这两件事正在协同发挥作用，导致他失去了权力，也就是第七部分，将在中场休息后紧接着开始。漂亮的过渡。广播，20年。好了，现在我们讲到第七部分，权力的丧失。我们终于做到了。埃利奥特、凯琳，我们已经到这里了。终于来到这一章节——权力的丧失，感觉真是太棒了。
It doesn't feel so, not in that I want to be done with the book. I'm loving reading through this book, talking about this book, but it feels so good to finally see the words, the loss of power and be like, wait a minute, but that must be referring to Robert Moses losing power. Except for the process of him losing power still represents a bunch of misery. And so actually like chapter 41, rumors and reports of rumors is actually one of the more
这种感觉并非是因为我想快点读完这本书。我很喜欢阅读这本书，谈论这本书，但终于看到“权力的丧失”这几个字时，那种感觉太棒了，会让人觉得：等一下，这一定是指罗伯特·摩西失去了权力。然而他失去权力的过程仍然伴随着一连串的苦难。所以实际上，就像第41章《传言与传言的报告》其实是其中最痛苦的章节之一。
miserable chapters. Yes, that's true. In terms of its detail. So, you know, we've been talking about roads all this time, but what we have not yet really spent a lot of time on, and you know, Caro hasn't spent a lot of time on, is that he's also the director of the Mayor's Slum Clearance Committee,
是的，确实如此。就其细节而言。所以，你知道的，我们一直在谈论道路，但我们尚未真正花大量时间探讨的，也是卡罗没有花大量时间探讨的是，他同时也是市长贫民窟清清除委员会的主任，
and he has this massive power over public housing. In fact, I have now read this book three times. I don't fully understand his role in public housing completely to tell you the truth. I think that is mostly by design, Roman. So this period, we should remember, in the 50s leading into the 60s, this idea of slum clearance and the rebuilding
他对公共住房拥有巨大的权力。事实上，我已经读了这本书三遍了。老实说，我并没有完全理解他在公共住房中扮演的角色。我想这主要是刻意安排的，罗曼。所以我们应该记住，在50年代到60年代这段时期，这种贫民窟清除以及城市社区重建以消除城市衰败的理念非常盛行。
of the city's neighborhoods so that you could eliminate blight was something that was really big. The idea that there were poor parts of a city, there are rich parts, there are middle-class parts. What if we could get rid of the poor parts? What these, you know, what used to be called kind of like the tenement areas are now seen as slums. And I think a big part of that is because
当时人们认为城市里有贫困区、富裕区、中产阶级区。如果我们能摆脱贫困区会怎么样呢？这些过去被称为贫民窟区域的地方现在被视为贫民窟。我认为很大一部分原因是因为
they are now often populated by people of color rather than, say, immigrants from Germany or Italy who at the time when they came in were not really accepted, but there was still a greater visual link, let's say, with the powers that be. But setting all that aside, everyone's talking about slum clearance. Let's get the poor out of this bad housing and into better housing, or as Moses would say, let's get them out of this bad housing and then question mark, question mark, question mark. And as the mayor's slum clearance committee director, it's another one of these big overall czar positions where he is not directly overseeing each individual project, but he is overseeing the assigning of slum clearance projects to private developers through the federal kind of Title I program where you
它们现在往往居住着有色人种，而不是像当年刚来时虽未被真正接受、但与当权者在视觉上仍有更大关联的德国或意大利移民。但抛开这些不谈，每个人都在谈论贫民窟清除。让我们把穷人搬出这糟糕的住房，搬进更好的住房；或者正如摩西所说，让我们把他们搬出这糟糕的住房，然后是问号、问号、问号。作为市长贫民窟清除委员会的主任，这是又一个那种总体上的沙皇式职位，他并不直接监督每个具体的项目，而是通过联邦的“第一篇章”计划，监督将贫民窟清除项目分配给私人开发商。通过该计划，你可以获得联邦资金，我认为是由开发商将私人住宅改建为新的住宅开发项目。
can get federal money for, I think, conversions by a developer of private residences into a new housing development. And Carol's talked earlier about this idea that of eminent domain that Moses is taking advantage with his roads, the idea that like you can take land from a private owner and use it for the public good. And this housing development slum clearance is a further step in that where you are taking private buildings away from private owners and then handing them to other private owners in theory as a public good in order to create better housing for citizens and residents. And it's another one of these things that, oh, he's a big hero.
卡罗之前讨论过这一概念，即摩西在修建道路时利用了土地征用权（Eminent Domain），即你可以从私人业主手中征收土地并将其用于公共利益。而这种住房开发和贫民窟清除则是更进一步的做法，即你从私人业主手中夺走私有建筑，然后将其理论上作为公共利益交予其他私人业主，以便为市民和居民创造更好的住房。这也是那种“哦，他是大英雄，他在清除贫民窟，他在建造所有这些新住房，纽约正处于住房危机中，你知道的，它需要更多住房”的事情之一。每个人都理所当然地认为他说一切进展顺利，而报纸也顺着这种说法进行报道。但正如卡罗所说，少数孤立但敏锐的观察者开始发现关于贫民窟清除令人极为不安的线索，
He's clearing out the slums. He's building all this new housing. New York is in a housing crisis. You know, it needs more. And everyone just takes it for granted that he says it's going great. And the newspapers just kind of run with that. But as Caro says, a few isolated, but perceptive observers were getting to notice clues to something very disturbing about slum clearance and
在这里，卡罗开始构建这种类似“复仇者联盟”风格的改革家阵容，他们每个人都有自己的小分队、自己的小冒险，通过同样的方式去了解贫民窟清除计划存在的问题。你拥有维权律师奥滕丝·盖布尔（Hortense Gable）。她帮助创立了纽约州住房歧视委员会，她是中产阶级，但她开始与黑人和波多黎各裔纽约人交谈并倾听他们的心声，这些正受到住房政策影响的人是以前的改革家们所没有真正关注的。过去的改革家们也持有“我们知道什么最好，把我们认为最好的东西给这些人”的态度。他们的思维方式和摩西类似，而卡罗将其描绘成了一种区别：这种新一代的维权人士在某些方面正顺应着他们试图服务的民众的领导，她开始走入
here, Caro starts constructing this little like Avengers style cast of reformers who each get like their own little sex, their own little adventure where they're learning about the problems with the slum clearance programs in the same way. You've got activist lawyer Hortense Gable. She helps found the New York State Committee on Discrimination and Housing, and she is middle class, but she starts talking to and listening to black and Puerto Rican New Yorkers who are being affected by the housing policies in a way that previous reformers hadn't really. Previous reformers had also been of the like, we know what's best, give these people the things that we think are best. They kind of thought the way that Moses thought, and Kara was kind of portraying this as a difference in a way that this new breed of activist is taking the lead of the people they're trying to serve in some ways. And she starts going
正在建造的建筑物中，并对其中的一些情况感到震惊。有一个时刻让我感到非常害怕，仅仅是因为它所暗示的含义——她正在其中一间公寓里，走进浴室整理头发，结果照镜子时发现根本没有镜子。那只有一个通往隔壁公寓的洞。这让我感到极其震惊，他们居然会觉得：“对，对，我们就留了一个洞在两间公寓之间。”城市规划委员会成员劳伦斯·奥顿（Lawrence Orton）开始质疑摩西用来证明被驱逐家庭已经获得新的、公平住房的数据。
into the buildings that are being built and she is horrified by some of them. There's a moment that I find so scary just from the implications of it where she's in one of these apartments and she goes into the bathroom to check her hair and she looks in the mirror and there is no mirror. There's just a hole looking into the next apartment. That's astonishing to me that they're just like, yeah, yeah, we just left a hole there between these two apartments. There's city planning commission member Lawrence Orton. He starts questioning the statistics that most is using to show that the families that have been evicted are being given new, equitable housing.
他知道城里根本没有建造足够的公共住房来满足这些流离失所居民的需求。还有联邦住房与家居融资署地区委员会的沃尔特·弗里德（Walter Fried）。他注意到自己在西90街的社区里的建筑变得越来越破败，越来越多的人挤进这些建筑里。到1953年夏天，他很清楚，这些贫困的有色人种、黑人和波多黎各居民正被附近这个由摩西控制的巨大城市更新项目赶出家园。他距离该项目工地越近，社区的状况就越糟糕，
And he knows there's simply not enough public housing in the city being built to meet the needs of these displaced residents. And there's Walter Fried, Regional Council of the Federal Housing and Home Finance Agency. And he's noticing that the buildings in his own neighborhood in the West 90s are getting seedier, that more people are crowding into them. And by the summer of 1953, it's clear to him that these poor people of color, black and Puerto Rican residents, are being pushed out of their homes by this huge Moses controlled urban renewal project right nearby. And the closer he gets to the site of that project, the worse the state of the neighborhood
他意识到这个贫民窟清除项目根本不是在清除贫民窟。它只是把它压扁，让它向外扩散。就像你在三明治上抹了太多花生酱然后把它压扁一样，花生酱并没有被清除掉，
gets. And he's realizing this slum clearance project is not clearing out a slum. It's just kind of like smooshing it down so it spreads outward. Like if you put too much peanut butter on a sandwich and you smoosh it down, it's not like the peanut butter gets cleared away,
它只是溢出来了。所以，对这些人的不同经历来说，就像三个盲人摸象的古老寓言一样。他们都摸到了这个问题的不同部分，并没有完全看清它们是如何联系在一起的，但他们明白这一切都与摩西的住房开发项目有关——这些项目并没有兑现其承诺，即把人们重新安置在更好的地方。
like it just overflows. So it's appearing to each of these people in different instances, like the old proverb of the three blind men with the elephant. They're all feeling different parts of this problem and not quite seeing how they connect, but understanding it's all part of one thing related to Moses's housing developments, not doing what they're promising to do, which is to rehouse people in better places.
是的，没错。他们，他们，他们正在收集一些小细节，如果你没有亲临实地，你可能根本不会注意到。最明显的一点就是这种想法：好吧，这些附近变得越来越破败的地方之所以破败，是因为城市没有去维护这些空间，以容纳所有额外的人口。
Yeah, that's right. They're, they're, they're picking up little bits of things that you maybe wouldn't notice if you weren't on the ground. That's the thing that's really clear, this idea of like, well, these places that are nearby that are getting more run down, are getting more run down because the city's not taking care of those spaces to accommodate all the extra people
这些人现在被塞进额外的地方，被那些趁火打劫的房东分割开来。他们提到，你知道的，看到屋外垃圾桶的数量远超公寓楼外应有的数量，这表明本来一个地方住5个人，现在有12个人住在那里。
which are now being crammed into extra places, being divided up by landlords taking advantage. And they mentioned, you know, seeing way more garbage cans than you would expect outside of an apartment building, indicating that instead of, you know, five people living in a place, like 12 people are living in a place.
这一切都再次表明，这是一个掌权者，他既没有考虑整体，也没有考虑其他人的痛苦。是的。这些都是我们在卡罗讲述受其直接影响的人的故事中以前注意到的事情。我们要在这里看到的区别的一部分是，正如我们在中场休息前所提到的，注意到这一点的是中产阶级。其中两个人是律师。两个人拥有政府官方职务。
And this is all just like, again, this is like a person who is in charge, who is not thinking about the whole and also not thinking about the suffering of other people. Yes. And these are things that we've noticed before in the stories that Carol tells of the people being affected directly by them. And part of the difference here that we're going to see is that, as we mentioned before the break, these are middle class people that are noticing this. Two of these people are lawyers. Two of them have official positions in government. That makes all the difference that these are people who have access and also the space
这造成了完全不同的结果——这些人拥有特权，而且他们的生活中有足够的空间（因为他们生活得很舒适，我不得不假设，即使算不上大富大贵，他们的生活也足够舒适），可以投入心思和精力去思考正在发生的事情以及如何将其拼凑起来，而不是仅仅在陷入困境时疲于奔命、苦苦求生。我想提两件事。第一，我喜欢卡罗撰写每一个部分的方式。他以类似呼应的短语开始每一节。第一节是“对于奥滕丝·盖布尔来说，那是传言”，然后讲述她的故事。对于劳伦斯·奥顿来说，那是统计数据，然后讲述他的部分。对于沃尔特·弗里德来说，那是垃圾桶，然后讲述他的部分，这太棒了。
in their life because they're living comfortably, I have to assume, if not wealthily, they're living comfortably enough to give thought and energy to what's being done and how to put it together as opposed to just trying to survive while they are being put in a difficult position. And I want to mention two things. One is I love the way that Caro writes each of these sections. He starts each of them with a similar mirroring phrase. The first one goes, for Hortense Gable, it was rumors and it goes through hers. For Lawrence Orton, it was statistics and goes through his section. For Walter Fried, it was garbage cans and goes through his section, which is great.
也很有趣，第三条规则就在那里。第三个很有趣。但对我而言，这展示了卡罗如何在文学层面上和更宏大的层面上进行创作。他不仅仅是为了把每个部分都写得引人入胜，而是将它们以一种在整本书中以分形方式放大的方式联系起来，我认为在脑海中以这种方式把握全局、把握整个设计真是太惊人了。但在这里，他也谈到了城市衰败（blight）的概念。我们在上一章中讨论过，
Also funny, it's rule three is right there. The third one is the funny one. But it shows you how, to me, how Caro is working on a literary scale and on a larger scale. He's not just writing each of these sections to be good reading, but he's connecting them in a way that he is, it's just magnified fractally throughout the book, which I think is so amazing to hold the whole thing in his head in that way, the whole design. But here he's also talking about that idea of blight. And we talked about in the last chapter
他如何使用了一些语言，其边缘让我们对他在描述城市衰败时的措辞感到有些不舒服。我觉得在这里他没有陷入同样的问题。感觉他在这里说得很清楚，衰败并不是由社区里的穷人造成的问题。而是这些人无法获得充足的住房、充足的资源的问题，
about how he was using some language that kind of edged into where we were feeling uncomfortable about how he was describing blight. And I feel like here he is not falling into that same problem. It feels like here is making it clear, blight is not a problem caused by the poor people in the neighborhood. It's the problem of those people not having access to adequate housing, adequate resources
而且摩西的贫民窟清除“第一篇章”项目正在将这些贫民窟的前居民推入更糟糕的住房中，并且这正在使过度拥挤和问题进一步扩散。所以我认为，尽管我们在上一章对他的某些语言感到有些不适，但我重新阅读这一章时，我觉得：哦，卡罗先生，是的，你回到了坚实的立场上。现场的人不是问题所在，
and that Moses slum clearance title one projects are pushing former residents of those slums into worse housing and it's spreading the overcrowding and the problems farther. So I think he's, he's for all the like kind of queasiness that we had about some of his language in the last chapter, I feel like reading this chapter over again, I was like, oh, Mr. Caro, yeah, you're back on firm ground. It's not the people on the ground that are a problem,
制定决策的高层人员才是问题所在。他们才是问题所在。其中一部分是通过这些十字军式人物的眼睛讲述的，他们有时间和同情心，他们已经进化到能够吸纳人们的个人经历，而不会将社区的失败视为个人的失败。
it's the people making decisions above them. They're the problem. And part of that is told through the eyes of these crusaders who have the time and the empathy and they've just evolved to take people's individual experiences and not see the failure of a neighborhood as the failure of individuals.
这实际上是像罗伯特·摩西这样的人以及城市的失败。他们指出，他们可能会去一个破旧的社区，但每次走进一户人家，他们都看到家里很可爱、受到了很好的照顾。这些人真的很想拥有美好的事物，但体制对他们太不公平了。这进一步激励了他们的行动，
It's really the failure of people like Robert Moses and the city pointing out that they might go to a kind of a rundown neighborhood, but every time they go into a home, they see that the home is lovely and cared for. And these folks really want to have nice things, but the system is really stacked against them. And this is further motivating their actions to
认识到这不是任何人应得的遭遇。这是强加给他们的。某种程度上，这是所有这些中最令人欣慰的部分，那就是有这样一群人存在，你知道的，他们是摩西的对立面。是的。尽管我们听说过关于人们需要被迁出贫民窟的各种说法，但这些激进主义者在与当地人交谈时也清楚地意识到，这些是贫困社区，这些社区中公众无法控制的部分、或是个人家庭无法控制的部分虽然破旧或不干净，但他们的房子很干净，里面很干净，而且他们不想离开这些地方。这里是他们的社区，
recognize that this isn't a thing that anyone deserves. It's a thing being done to them. And it's sort of, that's the heartening part of all this, is that there's these people out there that are, you know, the antithesis of Moses. Yeah. And for all that we've heard about how people need to be cleared out of slums, it becomes clear to these activists, too, as they talk to people there, that these are poor neighborhoods, these are neighborhoods that the public at parts of them that individual families can't control are run down or not clean, but their houses are clean and the insides are clean and also they don't want to leave these places. This is where their communities
他们担心被重新安置到更小、更贵的地方，这很难。那里的居民不想离开这些地方。他们更愿意改善自己居住的房屋并获得获得资源的途径来做到这一点。但是，他们的恐惧是他们将被迫离开并像风中残烛一样四散各处，而激进主义者们，他们正在全力以赴。你知道的，他们正在行动，
are. They're worried about being relocated to places that are even smaller, more expensive, and it's tough. They, the people there don't want to leave those places. They prefer to have the homes they live in improved and being given access to the resources to do that. But, uh, their fear is that they're going to be forced out and kind of scattered to the winds and the activists are, uh, they're on top of it. You know, they're, they're out there.
他们正试图让报纸进行报道。他们去了《纽约时报》。《纽约时报》对这个故事感兴趣吗？罗曼？不，先生。他们不感兴趣。不，他们的态度是：我们不是调查性报纸，也许你可以把这带到别处去。这就像，好吧，记者除了调查还能做什么呢？你知道吗？
They're trying to get the newspapers to cover it. They go to the New York times. Is the New York times interested in this story? Roman? No, sir. They're not. No, they're like, we're not an investigative paper, maybe take it somewhere else. It's like, well, what do you do?
是的。所以他们开始以自己的方式做事。城市规划委员会的奥顿，我真的很喜欢他在这里所做的事。他是在总规划部门工作，而这个部门一直没有人关注。我们在之前的节目中讨论过纽约没有总体建筑规划。摩西非常成功地阻止了这种情况的发生。
What does a reporter do other than investigate? You know? Yeah. And so what they start to do things in their own way. And Orton from the city planning commission, I really love what he's doing here. Where he, so he works in the master plan unit, which nobody has been paying attention to. We talked in earlier episodes on New York does not have a master building plan. Moses very successfully stopped that from happening.
但有这个总规划部门，他心想，反正没有人关注我们，我们可以为所欲为。所以他们基本上变成了一个驱逐数据收集单位，研究有多少人被驱逐，他们后来发生了什么，或者对城市造成的后果。奥顿的行事风格就像地下抵抗组织的一员，老实说，我觉得这有点可爱。奥顿使用的是糟糕的数据、不完整的数据。唯一可能掌握准确数字的人是在兰德尔岛（Randall's Island），
But there's this master plan unit and he's like, well, nobody pays attention to us. We can do whatever we want. So they just become kind of an eviction data collecting unit, uh, and looking at how many people have been evicted, what happens to them afterwards, or the consequences for the city and Orton acts like he's the member of like an underground resistance, uh, team, which I find kind of adorable to be honest. And Orton is working with bad data, incomplete data. The only people who may have the right numbers are people at Randall's Island,
也许是在三区大桥（Triborough），而摩西和他的手下利用他们的影响力将这些统计数据排除在公众视线之外。所以他们只能使用他们能从三区大桥获得的统计数据，而这些数据是通过泛泛而谈而不是实际统计被人为保持在很低的水平。即便采用这种最低限度的估计，奥顿的团队也表示，自二战结束以来的七年里，纽约市有170,000人因这些公共工程而流离失所。卡罗非常喜欢列清单，所以他写道：这个数字比奥尔巴尼、菲尼克斯、小石城、萨克拉门托、塔拉哈西、托皮卡、巴吞鲁日、特伦顿、圣达菲的总人口还要多。
maybe people in Tribro and Moses and his men have used their influence to keep those statistics out of the public eye. And so they're working with just the statistics they can get from Triborough, which are deliberately kept low by generalizing rather than actually counting people. And even with that low end estimate, Orton's group says that 170,000 people have been displaced in New York City for these public works in the seven years since the end of World War II. And Caro, he loves lists. So he goes, more people than lived in Albany, Phoenix, Little Rock, Sacramento, Tallahassee, Topeka, Baton Rouge, Trenton, Santa Fe.
我就说到这里，但这（你知道的，相当于一个规模不错的小城市的人口）已经被赶走，而流离失所的人中，黑人、波多黎各人和穷人的比例高得惊人。奥顿的这项调查证实了自由主义者的怀疑。他们发现，虽然摩西一直承诺重新安置居民，但他通常只是像我们所看到的，把他们从一个刚被拆毁的建筑物搬到下一个建筑物。三分之一的居民档案上标着“失踪，下落不明”。卡罗写道，摩西其实根本无法知道人们去住的住所是否比他们离开的地方更好或相当，
And I'll stop it there, but this, you know, a good sized, you know, small city of people have been removed and a remarkably disproportionate number of those displaced people are black or Puerto Rican and poor. And this is this this Orton survey that confirms the suspicions of the liberals. And they find that while Moses has been promising to relocate people, he usually just, as we've seen, moves them from one pre-demolished building to the next. And a third of the resident files are marked disappeared, whereabouts unknown. And Caro writes about how Moses couldn't really know if the living quarters that people were going to were better or equivalent where they left,
因为他甚至不知道那些住所是什么样的。他不知道这些人去了哪里。所以当他说“哦，是的，每个人最终都住进了更好的住房”时，给人的感觉是：这绝无可能。但可以肯定的是，他们的处境不会比他们被迫离开时的处境更好。这与我们在东特里蒙特（East Tremont）看到的情况有相似之处，
because he doesn't even know where those living quarters are. He doesn't know where these people went to. So when he's saying, oh yeah, everyone ended up in better housing, it's like, there's no way. But it's a safe bet that they're not moving into a better situation than the one that they were forced out of. And there's this parallel here with what we saw in East Tremont, where
许多这样的社区，激进主义者发现，尽管有种种缺陷，但居民们依然珍视它们，而局外人则不然。局外人是做决定的人，但这里的居民有一种更强烈无助感，因为他们知道作为有色人种，他们在这个体制中、在他们自己的未来中所拥有的发言权甚至更少，在城市其他地方获得住房的机会也更少。真的，这些人才是处于最大劣势、最容易受到这种贫民窟清除影响、被推向越来越糟糕的居住环境的人。
a lot of these neighborhoods, the activists are finding, are valued by their residents, even with their flaws, but not by outsiders. And the outsider is the ones making the decisions, but the residents here have an even greater sense of helplessness because they know as people of color, disproportionately, they have even less of a say in this system, in their own future, and even less access to housing in the rest of the city. It's really, these are the people who are really at the biggest disadvantage and the most vulnerable to this kind of slum clearance, pushing them into worse and worse living situations.
是的，这真是太悲剧了。就像所有那种霸凌一样，诸如“你必须在10天内搬走”之类的话。这完全是胡扯。所有这类事情。我甚至不知道。比如我是一个经济条件很好的人。如果伯克利市在我的门上贴了一张纸条，
Yeah, it's really tragic stuff. Like all that sort of bullying, the sort of like, you need to be out in 10 days. That's completely bogus. All that sort of stuff. I don't even know. Like I'm a person of great means. If somebody, if the city of Berkeley put a thing
说我必须在10天内搬走，我会他妈的彻底崩溃的，你知道吗？这太悲惨了。你知道的，就像道路一样，糟糕的思维、糟糕的规划是一回事。这种在家里感觉不到安全感的事情——家真的是感到安全的精神核心，
on my door that said you had to be out in 10 days, I would freak the fuck out, you know? And it's just miserable. You know, it's in one of these things like the roads, the bad thinking, the bad planning is one thing. This kind of not feeling safe and secure in your home, which is really the emotional center of feeling safe in your home
能够在一天结束时放松下来——对于一个健康的人的生活来说是如此基础，你知道吗？想到他们一直处于紧张状态，而他却对此视若无睹。我的意思是，他正在做的事情之一就是，你知道的，他把可用单位数量进行了三倍、四倍、甚至五倍的计算。所以他建造了一些东西，并且说：
and being able to relax at the end of a day is so fundamental to a healthy person's life, you know? And to think about that they're on edge all the time and then he treats it as nothing. I mean, one of the things that he's doing is he's, you know, like triple and quadruple and maybe quintuple counting what's available. So he's building things and he's like,
是的，我们为人们提供了大约一千套可用住房。但他没有说的是，这些其实已经被承诺给别人了，而且，你知道的，这就像他在试图解释这些事情时玩的一场把戏。这种行为太恶劣了。真的很恶劣，而且他并非对问题一无所知。我认为这正是问题的一部分，并不是说
yeah, we got like a thousand units available for people. But he's like, he's not, they've already been promised and that, you know, it's kind of like, he's just doing this shell game when he's trying to answer for this stuff. And it's just gross behavior. It's really gross and he's not oblivious to the problem. I think that's part of the issue is it's not like
他会觉得：“哦，我没有意识到这一点。我还以为我们干得很好呢。”不，他很清楚自己在做什么。他知道即使是他建造的住房，其定价也太高了，他驱逐的人根本买不起。他正在用中产阶级的住房取代穷人的住房。这些事实是他可以获得的，因为他正在隐瞒这些事实。你不会得到那种自由主义者的梦想：
he's like, oh, I didn't realize that. I thought we were doing great. No, he knows what he's doing. He knows that even the housing that they are producing is priced at a point that is too high for the people he's evicting to afford. That he is replacing housing for the poor with housing for the middle class. And these facts are available to him because he's hiding these facts. It's not like you get the liberal
去找他说：“你注意到这个了吗？”然后他回答：“哦，不，我从来没意识到这一点，伙计们，关掉它，关掉它。”相反，他的态度是：“对，我知道，我知道我在做什么，我不在乎。”因此，激进主义者开始撰写这些报告。奥顿让他的总规划部门撰写了一份报告。另一个团体——女性城市俱乐部（Women's City Club）撰写了一份报告，但没有人看到这些报告，尤其是奥顿的报告。摩西大概听到了风声，
dream of going to him and saying like, did you notice this? And him going, Oh no, I never realized that guys shut it down. Shut it down. Instead. He's like, yeah, I know, I know what I'm doing and I don't care. Uh, And so activists, they start writing up these reports. Orton has his master plan unit write report. This other group, the Women's City Club, they write a report and nobody sees these reports, especially with the Orton report. Moses, I guess caught wind of it
他在城市规划委员会的盟友推迟了该报告发布达九个月之久，并对其进行了重写，以支持摩西的住房工作。他们极大地改变了这份报告的基调，以至于奥顿不得不表示：“我必须能够对我团队撰写而被你们修改过的报告写一份少数派反驳意见。”而在女性城市俱乐部的报告方面，摩西的律师塞缪尔·罗森曼（Samuel Rosenman）——我想我们之前提到过他，他曾是总统的耳语者之类的人物，
and his allies in the city planning commission, they delay the release of that report for nine months and they rewrite it to be supportive of Moses's housing work. And they so changed the tenor of this report that Orton is like, I need to be able to write a minority rebuttal to the report that my team wrote that you changed. And in the case of the report from the Women's City Club, Moses' lawyer, Samuel Rosenman, who I think we mentioned before, who was like, had the ear of presidents and things like that,
是纽约一位备受尊敬的人物——发表了他自己的公开反驳，提供了第二套相互冲突的事实。所以市里的记者们心想：我不知道该选择哪套事实，是这个女性俱乐部，还是这个作为民主政府建制派中备受尊敬一员的家伙？我想我们还是不要理会它好了。报纸要么将这些报告埋没，要么完全无视它们。如果他们报道了，他们就会以摩西的人故意插入的转移视线的提议为首要内容，声称他们可能会提高城市的电话税来支付住房费用。所以，如果这些关于住房开发项目如何在极大程度上辜负了城市居民的报告有任何报道的话，那也全都是关于我们不想支付更高的电话税。就好像
a very respected figure in New York, he releases his own public rebuttal of that that provides a second set of conflicting facts. So city reporters are like, I don't know which facts to choose from, this women's club or this guy who's a well-respected part of the democratic government establishment. I guess we just won't deal with it. And the newspapers either bury or ignore the reports completely. If they cover it, they lead with this proposal that Moses people inserted deliberately as a diversion saying they might increase the city tax on telephones to pay for housing. So if there's any coverage of these reports about how massively the housing developments are failing people of the city, it is about how we don't want to pay higher tax on telephones. Like it's
这是某种完全不相关、并非真实的提议。在某个时候，《纽约时报》引用了摩西对奥顿反驳的回应。而奥顿的反应是：直到在《纽约时报》上看到引用，我甚至不知道他写过回应。甚至没有人告诉我他对我的反驳进行了反驳。报纸最终根本不在乎穷人的遭遇。卡罗写道，这是一句让人心碎的话。卡罗写道：穷人的命运在纽约市从来都不是新闻。现在依然不是新闻。
something, some totally irrelevant, not real proposal. And at one point the New York Times quotes Moses's reply to the Orton rebuttal. And Orton is like, I don't even know he had written a reply until it was quoted in the New York Times. Like no one even told me that he rebutted my rebuttal. And the paper is ultimately, they don't care what happens to poor people. Caro says, this is a heartbreaking sentence. Caro says, the fate of poor people had never been news in New York city. It still was not news.
这感觉就像……这真是一个极其悲伤的、
And it's like, oh, that's so like, it's such a, it's such a sad, um, kind of. Truthful statement of the abdication of any sort of power to take care of people who desperately need that help. That just like, yeah, news in New York City is not that people are poor and poor people get pushed around. Like that's not news. People either assume it
关于彻底放弃照顾那些极度需要帮助的人的权力的真实陈述。这就好像：是的，纽约市的新闻不是穷人很穷、穷人被欺负。那不是新闻。人们要么默认这一点，
or they don't wanna know about it or they don't care about it. And just such a, that sentence when I was rereading this chapter, it just was like a, it was just sprung out at me. It hit me so hard, you know, cause it's still true, you know, to such a great extent. For sure, for sure. And here me so hard, you know, because it's still true, you know, to such a great extent. For sure, for sure.
要么不想知道，要么根本不在乎。当我重读这一章节时，这句话简直像从纸面上跳出来一样，狠狠地撞击着我，让我感触极深，你知道吗？因为它在很大程度上依然是真实的。确实如此，确实如此。
And here in all this, you know, dealing with Title One and independent developers is where a lot of sort of old fashioned corruption happens and skimming. And it seems like this might be something that could build into a scandal, although it somehow doesn't, but I still don't like, could you describe what the scandal that's potentially happening here? I would love to, I would love to.
而在这所有的一切中，你知道的，处理“第一篇章”和独立开发商的事情，正是许多老式腐败和中饱私囊发生的地方。这看起来似乎是一件可能演变成丑闻的事情，尽管它不知为何没有演变成丑闻，但我还是想问——你能描述一下这里潜在发生的丑闻是什么吗？我很乐意，我很乐意。
So there's in 1954, the Senate actually like investigated one of the projects that was being done to look at the books. And we get a cameo in the book from Senator Prescott Bush, who when this book was written was not yet the father and grandfather of presidents of the United States of America. He's just a senator. And they talk about how, for instance, real estate worth $15 million on the open market had been given to developers for $1 million.
所以在1954年，参议院实际上调查了正在进行的一个项目，以审查账目。我们在书中迎来了一个客串人物——参议尔·普雷斯科特·布什（Senator Prescott Bush），当本书撰写时，他尚未成为美利坚合众国总统的父亲和祖父。他当时只是一名参议员。他们讨论了例如公开市场上价值1500万美元的房地产以100万美元的价格送给了开发商。
And in the time that these developers have been mandated to tear down 338 buildings, they've torn down 58. And the other 280 are not only still standing, the developers are running them and collecting rent from the tenants. And so essentially, developers who have promised to tear down buildings and build new, better buildings are instead just taking over the management of those buildings and raising the rents and refusing to maintain the buildings. So people are paying more for worse living in slums.
而在开发商被强制要求拆除338栋建筑的这段时间里，他们拆除了58栋。其余的280栋不仅依然矗立，开发商还在经营它们并向租户收租。所以本质上，承诺拆除建筑并建造新的、更好的建筑的开发商，实际上只是接管了这些建筑的管理，提高租金，并拒绝维护建筑。因此，人们为贫民窟里更糟糕的居住条件支付了更多的费用。
And then there's just classic stuff. There's fake legal fees. You put your family members on the staff of this development company and pay them money. And there's a great one that I love that I want to read to you on page 981 about this guy, Caspert, who's running one of these. And it says, Caspert had skimmed off for himself and his family $115,000 in less than a year. He set up a separate corporation headed by his son-in-law. Manhattan town sold the son-in-law's corporation all the gas stoves and refrigerators in the tenements for $33,000 and then rented them right back from the corporation, paying it
然后是一些经典的把戏。虚假的法律费用。你把你的家庭成员安排在这个开发公司的员工名单上并付给他们薪水。有一个我很喜欢、想在第981页读给你们听的精彩例子，关于一个名叫卡斯珀（Caspert）的家伙，他负责其中一个项目。书中写道：卡斯珀在不到一年的时间里为自己和家人中饱私囊了115,000美元。他成立了一家由他的女婿领导的独立公司。曼哈顿镇（Manhattan Town）以33,000美元的价格将贫民窟里所有的燃气灶和电冰箱卖给了女婿的公司，然后又马上从该公司租回，
in effect for the privilege of using what had been its own appliances. And they're able to make so much money just corruptly milking what the city and the federal government are pouring into this and turning into the most basic kind of graft. And by then, it says, eventually, financially, this development project, Manhattan Town in this case, it was backwards started from. It had made no progress. But his son-in-law had pocketed $115,000. So it's a success as far as the Casper family is concerned. That's right. And so it's that kind of classic graft, you know? Yeah, yeah, yeah.
实际上是为使用原本属于它自己的家电这一特权向其支付费用。他们能够通过腐败地榨取城市和联邦政府倾注到这里的资金赚取如此巨额的财富，并将其变成最基础的营私舞弊。到那时，书中说，最终在财务上，这个开发项目——本案中的曼哈顿镇——它是倒退着开始的。它没有任何进展。但他的女婿却把115,000美元揣进了口袋。所以就卡斯珀家族而言，这是一个成功的项目。没错。所以这就是那种经典的营私舞弊，你知道的？是的，是的，是的。
But none of this corruption, even though it has sent hearings, even though it's written about a little bit, even though it probably isn't written about enough, none of this blows back to Robert Moses, the head of all this. Yes. And Robert Moses is both the beneficiary and the shield for these projects in that way.
但所有这些腐败，尽管它引发了听证会，尽管它被写进了一些报道中，尽管它可能没有得到足够的报道，这一切都没有波及到罗伯特·摩西——这一切的负责人。是的。而罗伯特·摩西既是这些项目的受益者，也是这些项目的保护伞。
I think there's this understanding still, there's this assumption if incorruptible Robert Moses, the people's public servant, the man with the parks, if he's in charge of it, these things must be going fine. His words still carry his weight. If he says it's fine, it must be fine. And there's such an ingested assumed assumption on the part that's with the most redundant, I think I could possibly say assumed assumption.
人们仍然存在这种理解、这种假设：如果不可腐败的罗伯特·摩西、人民的公仆、拥有公园的人在负责此事，这些事情肯定进展顺利。他的话依然分量十足。如果他说没问题，那就一定没问题。报纸编辑们在很大程度上有一种内化了的、理所当然的假设——我用的词可能是“假设的假设”里最冗余的一个了，
There's such an understanding on the part of the editors at newspapers that Robert Moses is incorruptible that that they tell the reporters, there's not really, probably not a story here. This is probably a bad apple, you know, this one bad apple that maybe most didn't know about, or they're so afraid of his power in the political world that they won't go after it. And so he's able to keep his name out of the official proceedings because he's so powerful and he's able to keep his name out of the papers because he's seen as such a saint, you know, that why would you bother to investigate him? Yeah, yeah. When all these facts are complicated, the trail is hard to follow. They land on
报纸编辑们从心底里认为罗伯特·摩西是不可腐败的，以至于他们告诉记者：这里大概没什么新闻价值。这可能只是一颗老鼠屎，你知道的，也许摩西并不知道，或者他们太害怕他在政治世界中的权力，以至于不敢对穷追猛打。所以他能够凭借自己的强大权力将自己的名字排除在官方程序之外，并且由于他被视为圣人一般的存在，他能够让自己的名字远离报纸，你知道的，为什么还要费心去调查他呢？是的，是的。当所有这些事实都错综复杂、线索难以追踪时，他们最终得出的
this one fact, this foundational, what they think is a foundational truth is that it can't really be all that bad because Moses is the one in charge. And that is what they rely on to the detriment of the entire city and to all these people. It really is a failure on the part of the people who should be reporting these types of things. And it's the kind of thing that we still see in reporting today quite a bit, which I'm sure we'll talk about later in the episode, where just as Moses has cut himself off from new information, and this has meant that his work is at best stale, at worst destructive,
是一个事实，一个他们认为是基础真理的事实，那就是事情不可能那么糟糕，因为摩西是负责人。而这正是他们所依赖的，结果却损害了整个城市和所有这些人的利益。这确实是那些本该报道这类事情的人的失职。这也正是我们在今天的报道中经常看到的那种情况，我确信我们会在本集的后面讨论这一点，正如摩西将自己与新信息隔绝开来，这意味着他的工作往好了说是陈旧过时的，往坏了说是具有破坏性的，
that the people in charge at these newspaper organizations, they've cut themselves off from the possibility of new information. Like Robert Moses, they understand him, they know him, they've known him for years. It's not worth looking in and finding something new. And so they miss out on this enormous scandal, this enormous story. And so from 1952 to 1956, there are, as Carus says, rumors and reports of rumors of the damage that Moses is doing to the people in these slum clearance housing projects. But the papers barely touch it and Moses's reputation remains firm and the rest of the book kind of seems to bear out the idea that again it's because the things he is doing are affecting the poor. They're affecting the people at the bottom
这些报纸机构的负责人也将自己与获得新信息的可能性隔绝开来。就像罗伯特·摩西一样，他们理解他，他们了解他，他们认识他多年了。不值得再去深入调查并发现什么新东西。因此，他们错过了这个巨大的丑闻、这个巨大的故事。所以从1952年到1956年，正如卡罗所说，关于摩西对这些贫民窟清除住房项目中的人们造成的损害，一直有传言和关于传言的报告。但报纸几乎从不触及它，摩西的声誉依然稳固，而书的其余部分似乎也印证了这样一个观点：再次是因为他所做的事情影响的是穷人。他们影响的是处于底层的人民。
of the ladder who the people at other rungs of the ladder, unless they are particularly empathetic or open-hearted people, do not care about. But, but, Caro ends this chapter with a little, there's like a little glimmer of hope in there. He says, before the people would be willing to look at Moses's program straight on, they would have to look at Moses straight on. And before the public could do that, there would have to be an issue that would show him so clearly for what he was, that there could be no mistake. And in this next chapter, Roman, in the next episode, we will cover that mistake and we will find that it is maybe
梯子不被其它梯子上的人（除非他们特别有同情心或心胸开阔）所关心。但是，但是，卡罗在这一章的结尾留住了一点，里面有一点希望的微光。他说，在人们愿意直面摩西的计划之前，他们必须直面摩西本人。在公众能够做到这一点之前，必须出现一个问题，能如此清晰地展现他的本来面目，以至于不会有任何误解。在下一章中，罗曼，在下一集里，我们将讲述这个错误，我们会发现它可能
the least of all the things that Robert Moses did that was wrong, but it'll happen. It'll happen in the next episode. It's so funny and weird and it feels so true that the thing that brings someone down or just like really does have a sort of mortal wound to him is something that just matters so much less than everything else horrible that he's done.
是罗伯特·摩西所做错的事情中最小的一件，但它还是会发生。它将在下一集里发生。这真是太有趣、太诡异了，而且感觉又是那么真实：那个能让人垮台或者对其实质上造成致命打击的事情，竟然是一件比他做过的一切其他可怕事情相比显得那么微不足道的事情。
All these things, it's the Capone tax evasion charge of Robert Moses to a certain extent. But that's one of the lessons of the book I feel like it's not talked about too much at least in my hearing about it There's so much talk about cities and how they work and things like that But the idea that the things that get noticed are less about what's being done than about who they're being done to And the victim matters even more in some cases than the act Especially that victim has connections to the news media,
所有这些事情，在某种程度上就是罗伯特·摩西的卡彭逃税指控。但我觉得这也是这本书的教训之一，至少在我的听闻中，人们对此谈论得不多。关于城市及其运作方式等等的讨论有很多。但这种观念是：受关注的事情更多关乎它们是对谁做的，而不是正在做什么。在某些情况下，受害者甚至比行为本身更重要，特别是当这个受害者与新闻媒体有人脉关系时，
as we'll see in the next chapter. That's right. But we will get to more of the loss of power next time. [♪ MUSIC PLAYING FADES OUT, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES OUT, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES OUT, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES Chief of Mother Jones and one of your fellow book club participants. And now our conversation with Clara Jeffery. Clara has been with Mother Jones for more than 20 years and has been editor-in-chief since 2015. Clara now oversees the Center for Investigative Reporting, which produces the exceptional radio show and podcast Reveal after that organization merged with Mother Jones this year. Earlier in her career while she was at Harper's Magazine, Clara edited several essays by the
正如我们在下一章中将看到的。没错。但我们下次会探讨更多关于权力的丧失。[♪ 音乐渐弱，音乐渐强，音乐渐弱，音乐渐强，音乐渐弱，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强《琼斯母亲》的主编兼你的书友会成员之一。现在我们与克拉拉·杰弗里的对话。克拉拉在《琼斯母亲》工作了20多年，自2015年起担任总编辑。在今年该组织与《琼斯母亲》合并后，克拉拉现在监督着调查报道中心（Center for Investigative Reporting），该中心制作了出色的广播节目和播客《揭露》（Reveal）。在她职业生涯的早期，当她在《哈珀斯杂志》时，克拉拉编辑了几篇由
great investigative journalist Barbara Ehrenreich from when Ehrenreich went undercover as a low-wage worker to expose the impact of welfare reform on the working poor. Those essays later became part of Ehrenreich's seminal 2001 book, Nickel and Dimed. To me, Mother Jones and CIR do the reporting that's closest to what the power broker did when it was published, reporting that drills down deep and explains systems that challenges the status quo, that holds the powerful accountable and focuses on the humanity of the people affected. Well, thank you so much for being on the Nine-Nine for some visible breakdown of the Power Broker. It's just a pleasure to have you here.
伟大的调查记者芭芭拉·埃伦赖希撰写的文章，当时埃伦赖希进行了卧底采访，成为一名低薪工人，以揭露福利改革对工作贫困人群的影响。这些文章后来成为了埃伦赖希2001年开创性著作《我在底层的生活》（Nickel and Dimed）的一部分。对我来说，《琼斯母亲》和调查报道中心所做的报道，最接近于《权力掮客》出版时所做的那种报道，这种报道深入挖掘并解释了体制，挑战现状，追究当权者的责任，并聚焦于受影响人群的人性。嗯，非常感谢你来到“九九”（Nine-Nine）节目，对《权力掮客》进行一些深入剖析。很高兴你能来到这里。
Well, I'm really excited to be part of the carousons. It's the amount, the volume of material to ingest the book itself, your guys' podcasts, their movies, there are articles. It's just a phenomenal upwelling of interest about this book, you know, which is beloved by many for decades, but it's really kind of nice to have this national reading project that you guys have convened. I've been so heartened by people like taking this on
嗯，我真的很高兴能成为卡罗颂（carousons）的一员。这本书本身的材料体量、你们的播客、电影、还有文章。关于这本书的兴趣真的是井喷式爆发，你知道的，几十年来它一直被许多人热爱，但你们召集了这样一个全国性的阅读项目，真的挺不错的。人们能够接受这一点，
and taking it to their heart and taking on the task of reading this true tour de force of journalism. And, you know, one of the reasons I wanna talk to you is you've been on the front lines of this fight for a long time for championing investigative journalism in society and making sure that we have a healthy ecosystem. And so when you read this book, how does it make you feel as someone
并且把它记在心里，承担起阅读这部真正的卓越新闻巨著的任务，这让我深受鼓舞。你知道，我想和你聊聊的原因之一是，你长期以来一直处于这场斗争的前沿，在社会上捍卫调查新闻，并确保我们拥有一个健康的生态系统。所以当你读这本书时，作为一个人，它带给你怎样的感受
who is always thinking about stuff like this, fighting to keep Mother Jones alive, often from existential threats, like from people trying to sue it Jones alive, often from existential threats, like from people trying to sue it out of existence. So how do you feel when you read The Power Broker? I mean, first of all, just like utter admiration for the work involved by Caro, by Robert Gottlieb as editor,
你总是思考这类事情，努力让《琼斯母亲》存续下去，常常面临生存威胁，比如来自那些试图通过诉讼让它消亡的人。那么，当你读到《权力掮客》时，你有什么感觉？我的意思是，首先，对卡罗、作为编辑的罗伯特·戈特利布所投入的工作，
everybody else in Ina Caro, helping her husband with research for 40 years now. You know, just everyone I'm sure at Knopf and the publishers. I will admit, I can't, I don't know if I'm the only one, but I don't think you can read the power broker and kind of contemplate this all as a journalist or a, you know, public policy person and not feel a great sense of imposter syndrome. You're like,
还有伊娜·卡罗等所有人，40年来一直在协助她的丈夫进行研究。你知道，我确信克诺夫（Knopf）和出版商里的每个人都是如此。我承认，我不知道我是不是唯一的一个，但我不认为你作为一个记者或公共政策人士，在阅读《权力掮客》并思考这一切时，不会产生强烈的虚假综合征（imposter syndrome）。你会觉得，
my God, what have I been doing with my life? I will answer that for you. You've been doing play. I'll take the other side of this debate. Not enough. Not enough. Never enough. I think one of the things in kind of contemplating this, it's how indefatigable Moses is, Cairo is, Gottlieb is in this weird troika, you know, speaking as an editor, I throw the editor in there too, but like, and that just an obsessiveness, which is a hallmark of investigative journalists and lots of different kinds of journalists, but I think particularly investigative journalists, it's a personality trait that has many great qualities about it and also we're a little squirrely sometimes. So just contemplating the full sweep of the book
我的天哪，我这一生都在干些什么？我来为你回答这个问题。你一直在玩耍。我来持这场辩论的另一方。还不够。还不够。永远都不够。我认为在思考这件事时，其中一点就是摩西、卡罗、戈特利布在这个奇怪的三人组合中是多么的不知疲倦，你知道的，作为一个编辑，我也把编辑加进去了，但是，那种痴迷，这是调查记者和许多不同类型记者的标志，但我认为特别是调查记者，这是一种具有很多优秀品质的个性特质，有时我们也显得有点古怪。所以，只要一想到这本书的全貌，
and how much it has really just influenced so many people, I think both directly, people who remember reading it or are reading it now, and indirectly, because I think that demonstration down to the detail of every little deal and every little inch of land he wrested from somebody or another in one way or another. And to tell that all compellingly, you know, it is really awe inspiring. One of the things that comes up a lot when Elliot and I are discussing the book
以及它究竟对如此多的人产生了怎样的影响，我认为既有直接的影响——那些记得读过它或现在正在读它的人，也有间接的影响，因为我认为这种将每一个小交易和从某人那里以某种方式强夺来的每一英寸土地的细节展示到极致的做法。而且要把这一切讲得引人入胜，你知道，这真的是令人敬畏。当埃利奥特和我讨论这本书时，经常出现的一件事是
when we're doing the summaries, is I'll read a paragraph that is just, you know, he just put together all the facts and figures of this one little highway. And I think about him assembling that information before the internet, before he wrote it down himself, because he became like the source of it all after a certain point,
我们在做总结时，我会读到一个段落，你知道的，他只是把这个小小的高速公路的所有事实和数字拼凑在一起。我想到他在互联网出现之前，在他自己把它写下来之前，他是如何收集这些信息的，因为在某个时间点之后，他成为了这一切的源泉，
and just how hard one of these single paragraphs that he just tosses off is. It's so nice to be around another journalist who understands how hard some of these – when you go through a book of 1,200 pages, noting that there's a single paragraph in, you know, Chapter 40, that probably would take me three months to assemble, maybe. It's staggering. It is, and it's the sort of particular kind of detail that you find by combing through files and bills and et cetera. But then also just his, you know, whatever, 500 plus interviews. And clearly he interviewed some of these folks multiple times.
而他随手写下的这短短的每一个段落又是多么来之不易。能和另一位了解其中艰辛的同行在一起是多么美好——当你通读一本1200页的书时，注意到第40章左右有一个段落，我大概需要花三个月才能拼凑出来，也许吧。这太震撼了。确实如此，这是你在翻阅档案、法案等资料时发现的那种特定细节。但随后还有他的，不管怎样，500多次采访。显然，他曾多次采访其中的一些人。
And she, you know, sometimes really acknowledges and other times is a little bit more coy about it. But to combine both of those skills, which not journalists often sort of go down one route or the other. Either sort of personality driven journalism, or really in the details and the weeds. And you know, it takes a special talent to fuse those so well, and to make it a compelling psychological study and not just of him, like, you know, LaGuardia, and Al Smith, and you know, all these people that you're just really pulled along by the human drama, as well as you're getting to know, like, the exact cement mix of some overpass or whatever.
而她，你知道，有时确实承认这一点，有时则对此更为含蓄。但能将这两种技能结合起来，大多数记者通常只会走其中一条路线。要么是注重个性的新闻，要么是真正深入细节和琐事。而且你知道，需要一种特殊的才能才能把它们融合得如此完美，并把它写成一个引人入胜的心理学研究，不仅是关于他个人的，比如拉瓜迪亚、阿尔·史密斯，还有所有这些人，你真的会被人类的戏剧性所吸引，同时你也能了解，比如某个立交桥的具体水泥配比之类的东西。
And, you know, exactly how, you know, and exactly what way he filleted, you know, assemblymen to get what he wants. So, yeah, just truly awesome. Yeah, yeah. That's a relief to me, because I was worried that you were going to say that, as an investigative
而且，你知道，准确地知道，以及他是如何通过剥离（filleted）议员来得到他想要的东西的。所以，是的，真的是令人惊叹。是的，是的。这对我来说是个解脱，因为我担心你会说，作为一个调查
reporter you'd be looking through it at times being like, that's not how I would have done that. Oh, this isn't how I would do it. Oh, that's not the same way that when I watch a comedy show on TV my wife hates it because I just sit there going like, not how I would have written that. Do you ever have that moment when looking through it or is it just such a monumental work that you can't even find a single crack in its edifice. I mean I think there's some cracks in its edifice but it's more like you know in contemplating what he ended up cutting and some of the stuff that he didn't cut.
记者，你有时会浏览它并觉得：“这不是我会做的那样。”哦，这不是我会做的。哦，这就像我在电视上看喜剧节目时，我妻子讨厌它，因为我只会坐在那里说：“这不是我会写的那样。”你在浏览它时有过这种时刻吗，还是说它是一部如此丰碑式的著作，以至于你甚至在它的宏大建筑中找不到哪怕一条裂缝？我的意思是，我认为它的建筑中确实有一些裂缝，但更像是，你知道的，在思考他最终剪掉了什么以及他没有剪掉的一些东西时。
You know I think in in the documentary Turn Every Page which is about him and his editor Bob Gottlieb which is about him and his editor, about Gottlieb. He, well, you know, Gottlieb is talking about being a completist himself. And in that conversation, he sort of is indicating things that he might have wanted to cut, and he doesn't exactly spell out what that is. But it seems to be the sort of summation pieces at kind of the end of every chapter or the sort of like, let me once again step back and tell you the sheer awesomeness of the power that that Robert Moses had assembled. And yet, I mean, I think for a book this ginormous, people even, you know, back in the 70s were probably reading were probably reading it, not as one big sit-down experience
你知道，我认为在纪录片《翻过每一页》（Turn Every Page）中，那是关于他和他的编辑鲍勃·戈特利布的，那是关于他和他的编辑戈特利布的。他，嗯，你知道，戈特利布在谈到自己是一个力求完美的人（completist）。在那个对话中，他某种程度上暗示了他可能想要剪掉的东西，他并没有确切地说明那是什么。但它似乎是每个章节末尾的那种总结性片段，或者那种“让我再次退后一步，告诉你罗伯特·摩西所聚集的权力的纯粹威严”之类的东西。然而，我的意思是，我认为对于一本如此庞大的书来说，人们甚至在70年代可能也在阅读
with this 12 pound tome in your lap or whatever, but, okay, now I'm going to take on a chapter or two, and it does allow you to come back to the book having been away for a while and not lose the threads. So even there, if I had to pick a sniggle, I guess it would be that, but it's so minor in the scheme of things. Yeah.
阅读它，不是作为一个一次性读完的宏大体验，手里拿着这本12磅重的巨著之类的，而是，好吧，现在我要读一两章，它确实能让你在离开一段时间后重新回到书中，而不会失去线索。所以即使在那里，如果我非得挑刺的话，我想大概就是这个，但在整个宏大计划中它是如此微不足道。是的。
You know, speaking about this relationship of the editor and the author, another fundamental text in my life was Barbara Ehrenreich's Nickel and Dime, which you served as the editor at Harper's when it was developing into the book it became. Can you talk about that process of working with someone and having it kind of work for a magazine and then become a book, what that was like? Yeah. I mean, I worked on a couple of the, it's sort of, there's sort of three parts to the book and I worked on two out of three of them when I was at Harper's.
你知道的，说到编辑和作者这种关系，我生命中的另一个基本文本是芭芭拉·埃伦赖希的《我在底层的生活》，当它发展成为后来的那本书时，你曾在《哈珀斯》担任编辑。你能谈谈与某人合作的过程，以及它如何在杂志上发表然后变成一本书，那是一种怎样的体验吗？是的。我的意思是，我参与了其中几部分的编辑，这本书大致分为三个部分，当我在《哈珀斯》时，我参与了其中两个部分的编辑。
You know, and the first being a sort of going undercover as it were, as a, you know, as a waitress in a chain restaurant. And it was really fascinating. That kind of thing had become silver boatin. Any kind of undercover work sort of went through this, like, oh no, the grand poobas of journalism say we can't do that. She had the idea that she wanted to do it, and then we talked through a lot. I remember one of the interesting, I was a very young editor and she was already a superstar. But one of the things that I had to sort of reinforce is like you actually have to back up and say,
你知道，第一部分是某种卧底采访，作为一个连锁餐厅的服务员。这真的很吸引人。那种事情曾一度风靡。任何类型的卧底工作都经历过这样的阶段，比如：“哦不，新闻界的大佬们说我们不能那样做。”她萌生了想要这样做的想法，然后我们进行了深入的讨论。我记得其中有趣的一点是，我是一个非常年轻的编辑，而她已经是超级巨星了。但我不得不强化的一点是：你实际上必须后退一步，然后说：
now I'm doing exactly what maybe Kara would want. You have to back up and say why this is important. You have to back up and also admit that like what maybe Carol would want. or know that they were going back to their literary life. And it was interesting that, I remember having a discussion with her, she's like, do I really need to do that? I'm like, I do really think you need to do that. Maybe a little bit generational,
现在我正在做卡罗可能想要的事情。你必须后退一步，说明为什么这很重要。你必须后退一步，同时也承认，比如说卡罗可能想要什么。或者知道他们将重回文学生活。很有趣的是，我记得曾与她讨论过，她说：“我真的需要那样做吗？”我说：“我真的认为你需要那样做。”也许这有点代沟，
I feel like that's the kind of thing a young person would tell me now. They're like, I really gotta get in there and admit your privilege. That wasn't even the vocabulary that we had back then, but it was part of that conversation for sure. I'd worked on several other pieces with her that were about vaguely defense industry stuff and another piece that did a big bunch of pieces on pinkwashing and breast cancer,
我觉得这就是年轻人现在会对我说的那种话。他们会说：“我真的得深入进去，承认你的特权。”当时我们甚至没有这种词汇，但这绝对是那次对话的一部分。我曾与她合作过其他几篇文章，大致是关于国防工业相关的事情，还有另一篇文章，写了一大堆关于粉红清洗和乳腺癌的文章，
which then became a book for her down the road. Her writing was always lovely and her thought process was always fantastic. So it was just those little tweaks of often like, you need to provide more context or like, you may not come off so great in this way, if you phrase it just in this manner. And very gracious at taking input. That's what I was gonna ask. No push over mind you, but gracious.
这后来成为了她日后的一本书。她的文笔总是很优美，她的思考过程也总是棒极了。所以这只是那些常常需要的微小调整，比如：“你需要提供更多的背景信息”或者“如果你只用这种方式表述，你在这方面可能显得不那么好。”而且她非常大度，能够接受意见。这就是我要问的。请注意，她绝不是一个好捏的软柿子，但她很大度。
Yeah. And what are those conversations like? Like, do you get to a point where you build a rapport, where that works and you can be very blunt, or do you always have to be kind of circumspect in your sort of criticism so that everyone feels okay in the end? I think that very much varies by the author that you're working with, partly their personality and how yours interacts, like how much experience they have, how insecure versus overly secure sometimes people are. So you are often playing a little bit of shrink, where, you know, kind of your job is to get
是的。那样的对话是怎样的？比如说，你们会达到这样一种默契吗：建立起一种关系，这种关系行之有效，你可以非常直言不讳，还是说你在批评时总是必须小心翼翼，以便最后每个人都感觉良好？我认为这很大程度上取决于与你合作的作者，部分取决于他们的性格以及你们如何互动，比如他们有多少经验，人们有时会有多不安全感与过度安全感。所以你常常扮演一点心理医生的角色，你知道的，你的工作某种程度上就是激发出
the best work out of them and help support them in that process and not let them do things that would damage the project or damage their own reputation. I think sadly that latter part has gotten a little bit lost in some corners of journalism where having someone get messy on the page is sort of the goal rather than keeping people from sort of self-harm in a writerly way. But yeah, so it's always partly shrink and supporter and then you're always kind of cracking the whip a little bit, right? There's always a deadline of some sort.
他们最好的作品并在这一过程中支持他们，不让他们做那些会损害项目或损害他们自己声誉的事情。我很遗憾地看到，在新闻业的某些角落，后一部分有点迷失了，让人在纸面上变得一团糟似乎成了目标，而不是阻止人们以一种写作者的方式进行自我伤害。所以，是的，它部分总是心理医生和支持者，然后你总是有点在挥舞鞭子，对吧？总是有某种截止日期。
Bob Caro doesn't have one, but I think most other people do. a deadline of some sort. Bob Caro doesn't have one, but I think most other people do. And the way the industry has become, I mean, I think just another thing reading this book in the LBJ books is just like, wow, even if it was Bob Caro, would this happen now? Just on an industry economics point and that's really kind of tragic to think about that there's just not, you know, the economy of the business or the priorities of the business have kind of changed whether it's in books or magazines or newspapers or whatever and still a lot of great stuff being done but some things it's hard to imagine would still happen. Yeah, you really do feel it of a, there's parts of the book where you feel like it's
鲍勃·卡罗没有截止日期，但我认为大多数其他人都有。某种截止日期。鲍勃·卡罗没有截止日期，但我认为大多数其他人都有。而这个行业现状的发展，我的意思是，我认为读这本书和LBJ（约翰逊）书籍的另一件事就是：哇，即使是鲍勃·卡罗，现在还会发生这种事吗？仅从行业经济学的角度来看，想到这一点确实有点悲剧，那就是没有，你知道的，商业经济学或商业的优先级已经改变了，无论是在书本、杂志还是报纸或其他方面，虽然仍有很多伟大的作品在做，但有些事情很难想象还会发生。是的，你确实能感受到，在书中的某些部分，你会觉得
super relevant to today, it has a ton of lessons in of the book would feel like it's super relevant to today. It has a ton of lessons in it. I mean, we talk about them all the time. It also does feel like a product of a different era of of just imagining this book hitting the shelves. Like I can't remember the last time something like this like sort of came out of nowhere, a big tome about something came out of nowhere and surprised people as a bestseller. Maybe that book, Capital, that came out 10 years ago, that was also big and dense and seemed very challenging in some ways. But still, this is a rare example of a kind of excellence that you do worry doesn't have the chance to get past the seedling stage in today's world. And it's really interesting. I wasn't able to find that much about exactly, like it seemed to take off right away
对今天来说超级相关，它里面有很多教训。这本书会让人觉得对今天来说超级相关。它里面有很多教训。我的意思是，我们一直在谈论它们。它也确实感觉像是不同时代的产物——仅仅想象这本书上架的情景。我不记得上一次有什么像这样的东西——某种凭空出现的东西，一本关于某事的厚重大部头凭空出现并作为畅销书让人大吃一惊，是什么时候了。也许是10年前出版的那本《资本论》，它也很宏大、厚重，在某些方面显得非常具有挑战性。但即便如此，这仍然是一种卓越的罕见例子，让人禁不住担心它在当今世界没有机会越过萌芽阶段。这真的很有趣。我找不到太多关于确切情况的资料，它似乎立刻就火了，
and maybe because it's in New York and because Gottlieb was his editor and because all of these things, and Nesbitt was his agent, that was going to happen. But it is kind of phenomenal that it didn't happen, I don't think, so far as I can tell,
也许是因为它在纽约，因为戈特利布是他的编辑，因为所有这些事情，还有内斯比特（Nesbitt）是他的经纪人，这是注定要发生的。但这种事情没有发生确实有点惊人，据我所知，
because a lot of people were having their suspicions confirmed It is kind of phenomenal that it didn't happen, I don't think, so far as I can tell, because a lot of people were having their suspicions confirmed. Like, there are a lot of books that come out that are like, hey, everyone knows this thing is bad. Let me show you how bad it is or why it's bad or maybe good. And this felt like it was, the entire topic was not very well understood even by journalists and scholars of the time but you know I say that you guys are now the experts so please correct me if I've flavoring under it.
因为很多人的怀疑得到了证实。这种事情没有发生确实有点惊人，据我所知，因为很多人的怀疑得到了证实。就像有很多书出版时都在说：“嘿，大家都知道这东西很糟糕。让我来向你展示它有多糟糕，或者为什么它很糟糕，或者也许是好的。”而这本书给人的感觉是，整个主题甚至连当时的记者和学者都不是非常了解，但我说你们现在是专家了，所以如果我理解有偏差请纠正我。
No it certainly seems like it wasn't that's one of the one of the exciting things about the book or one of the interesting things about the book now looking at it on its 50th anniversary is it's so become the default way of thinking among so many people about these topics and at the time it very much wasn't and it's one of those things where also you were saying how would something like this happen today and I kind of feel like it almost didn't happen then a book like this and there was a certain amount of novelty I think when it came out of are you gonna read this huge book about Robert Moses the parks commissioner you're going to can you believe this read this huge book about Robert Moses, the parks commissioner? You're going to. Can you believe this is this book is about Robert Moses? That like Robert
不，它当然看起来不是这样的，这本书现在的兴奋点之一，或者说这本书在迎来出版50周年之际有趣的地方之一，就是它已经成为许多人思考这些主题时的默认方式，而在当时绝非如此。而且这也是那种情况之一，正如你刚才所说，这样的事情今天怎么可能会发生？我甚至觉得当时它几乎没有发生过，像这样的一本书，当它出版时确实带有一种新鲜感：你会读这本关于公园专员罗伯特·摩西的巨著吗？你会去——你能相信吗？读这本关于公园专员罗伯特·摩西的巨著。你会去的。你能相信吗，这本书是关于罗伯特·摩西的？就像罗伯特
Moses now he's, you know, it's because the caro view, which is not as as straightforwardly flat as it's often taken to be, but the caro view of this guy did more harm than good likely, you know, or did a lot of harm is so taken now that at the time it was almost like not not just, oh, are you going to read this whole book of harm, is so taken out, that at the time it was almost like not just, ugh, are you gonna read this whole book demonizing Robert Moses? But literally, are you gonna read this whole book about the most boring man in the world, Robert Moses?
摩西现在，你知道的，这是因为卡罗的观点——这个观点并不像人们通常认为的那样直白扁平——卡罗对这家伙的观点是：他带来的危害可能大于好处，你知道的，或者带来了巨大的危害——现在已经被如此广泛地接受，以至于在当时，这几乎就像不仅是“噢，你要读这整本充满危害的书吗？”而且在当时，这几乎就像不仅是“呃，你要读这本把罗伯特·摩西妖魔化的巨著吗？”而是字面意义上的：“你要读这本关于世界上最无聊的人罗伯特·摩西的巨著吗？”
And so, like, that it has this uphill battle of even just getting people interested. And Caro talks about how people would say to him, no one's gonna read this book. No one's gonna, and not because he wrote it or because it's big, no one's gonna read a book on this topic, because it's so, so boring. But I feel like every now and then there's one of those,
所以，它甚至在让人产生兴趣这方面就经历了一场上坡战。卡罗谈到人们会对他说：“没人会读这本书。没人会——”不是因为他写了这本书或者因为它很大，而是没人会读一本关于这个主题的书，因为它太无聊了。但我觉得时不时地就会有这样一本书，
just the right book at the right time hits it, where a book that should exist in academic libraries only if the normal rules of market economics applied suddenly becomes this enormous thing. And with a book like this, it's gotta be partly because it's such a rich, it's such a satisfying read, I think. But it's true. It's a funny thing that exactly what you're saying, that like at the time, it wasn't just that people liked Robert Moses, it was people didn't even think about him. It was not even an interesting topic, you know?
在正确的时间碰上一本正确的书，如果按照正常市场经济规律，本该只存在于学术图书馆的书，突然变成了如此巨大的轰动。而对于这样一本书来说，部分原因一定是因为它如此丰富，我认为它是一本非常令人满意的读物。但确实如此。这真是一件有趣的事，正如你所说，在当时，不仅人们喜欢罗伯特·摩西，而且人们甚至根本不考虑他。这甚至不是一个有趣的话题，你知道吗？
Yeah, and I mean, I can only imagine it was very much helped along. Like if Robert Moses had happened in LA or Chicago or another great, huge, important city, but maybe not the heart of where publishing is. Yeah, that would people have been like, wait a minute, that's why I don't have a playground? Or that's why I can't get to the airport by the subway? So I think there was, I have no doubt that that kind of helped accelerate the uptake of the subway. So I think there was, you know, I have no doubt that that kind of helped
是的，我的意思是，我只能想象它得到了巨大的推动。就像如果罗伯特·摩西发生在洛杉矶或芝加哥或其他伟大、巨大、重要的城市，但也许不是出版业的心脏地带。是的，人们会说：“等等，这就是为什么我没有游乐场的原因吗？”或者“这就是为什么我无法乘地铁去机场的原因吗？”所以我认为，毫无疑问，这种事情有助于加速地铁的普及。所以我认为，你知道的，毫无疑问，这种事情有助于
accelerate the uptake of the book. But you know, it's also remarkable that he just, you know, he pretty much just had written it. And then he's like, Hey, I need an agent. Hey, I need an editor. And then he, you know, kind of got the best of the best on both counts. And, you know, that also feels like, on the one hand, like, yes, this work totally deserves that, that rare purchase in the industry, but also feels very serendipitous, like, could it just not happened? Yeah. And a good reminder, too, that it's for all Robert Caro is responsible for this book, that how many other people were involved in that making it
加速这本书的普及。但你知道，这也是非凡的，他几乎只是把它写完了。然后他说：“嘿，我需要一个经纪人。嘿，我需要一个编辑。”然后他，你知道的，在这两方面都找到了最好中的最好。而且，你知道的，这也让人觉得，一方面，是的，这项作品完全值得在行业中获得那种罕见的成功，但另一方面也感觉非常机缘巧合，难道它就可能不会发生吗？是的。这也是一个很好的提醒，那就是尽管罗伯特·摩西（应为罗伯特·卡罗）对这本书负有责任，但还有多少其他人参与了它的制作
and bringing it to fruition, his agent, his editor, his wife, how many people were necessary to then lift up this book that Robert Caro's name is on the cover of, you know, because he wrote it, but it was not a one person job to get a book like this off the ground, not just because it's enormous, you know, it's very hard to lift a book like this by yourself. You know? Well, I think it's really notable. I just want to highlight that for a whole bunch of reasons, like feminism and the need for two incomes,
并使其成为现实——他的经纪人、他的编辑、他的妻子，有多少人是必要的，才能举起这本书，这本书的封面上印着罗伯特·卡罗的名字，你知道的，因为是他写的，但让这样一本书问世绝不是一个人的工作，不仅因为它太庞大了，你知道的，你很难靠自己一个人举起这样一本书，你知道吗？嗯，我认为这非常值得注意。我只想为了诸多原因强调这一点，比如女权主义和对双份收入的需求，
like having your wife be your research assistant, not, and maybe they figured out a way to pay her directly through the contract, but like that is a thing that wouldn't happen today for mostly good reasons, but who knows how that would have ended up without such a steady research partner who literally knew him better than anyone and could go, because it doesn't seem like he's a guy who trusts a lot
比如让你的妻子做你的研究助理，而不是——也许他们想出了通过合同直接付薪给她的方法，但这在今天是不会发生的事情，这主要是出于好原因，但谁知道如果没有这样一个坚定的研究伙伴，事情会如何收场呢？她字面意义上比任何人都了解他，并且能够去——因为他看起来不像是一个会信任很多
of people to go figure something out for him. So it literally took being married to a, you know, presumably world-class researcher to kind of help get this over the line and the LBJ books as well. Very much so. Along the lines of how of changing people's minds, basically, Robert Carrow, you feel it in The Power Broker, how hard he's pushing to at least bring to the attention of the people reading this book what Robert Moses was responsible for and to change the general myth about him. And Mother Jones is often, if it's like doing kind of similar work of trying to push people so that their assumptions aren't taken for granted as assumptions, but instead question
人去为他弄清某事的人。所以这字面意义上需要与一个，你知道的，可以说是世界级的研究员结婚，才能帮助把这件事推过终点线，LBJ的书籍也是如此。确实如此。顺着改变人们观点的思路，基本上，罗伯特·卡罗，你在《权力掮客》中能感受到，他有多么努力地去至少引起阅读这本书的人的注意，让他们了解罗伯特·摩西所应承担的责任，并改变关于他的普遍神话。而《琼斯母亲》通常也是如此，如果它在做类似的工作，试图推动人们，使他们的假设不被理所当然地视为假设，而是去质疑
them, what does it feel like to be doing that work? Because it's not just a work of reporting, but a work of trying to kind of move the reader to a place beyond being informed to understanding something in a different way. And do you feel a kinship with the book in that way? Or what's that kind of work like? Yeah, I think, you know, the work that we do, the work that Kara does, and, you know, many other journalists, but like, you know, we were into systemic stuff before systemic was a buzzword. So it's not, you know, it's not just the, it's not just looking at the sort of individual, like, how did this contract come about? How did this person become the underling that helped him push this through? But, you know, and I think Caro is very insistent in a way
它们，做那样的感觉是怎样的？因为这不仅是一项报道工作，也是一项试图将读者从“被告知”带到一个能以不同方式“理解”某事的地方的工作。你在这方面对这本书有种亲近感吗？或者那是一种什么样的工作？是的，我认为，你知道的，我们做的工作，卡罗做的工作，以及，你知道的，许多其他记者，但是，你知道的，我们在“系统性”成为流行语之前就已经涉足系统性问题了。所以它不是，你知道的，它不仅仅是，它不仅仅是看待那种个体性的东西，比如：这个合同是如何产生的？这个人是如何成为帮他把这个推行下去的下属的？但是，你知道的，我认为卡罗以一种非常坚定的方式
that because it was sort of, you know, it wasn't the first book they'd ever done. I mean, Upton Sinclair is right there however many years earlier. But there is a way that he's just really insistent that not only that you know what happened, but why it happens and the sort of failings of other bodies and people to stop this person from doing all the harm that he did do.
因为这不是他们做过的第一本书。我的意思是，厄普顿·辛克莱在多少年前就已经出现了。但有一种方式，他是如此坚定：不仅要让你知道发生了什么，还要知道为什么会发生，以及其他机构和个人未能阻止这个人做出他所做的一切危害的那些过失。
And not that he only did harm. You know, I think that that's important. And, you know, you get this incredible Shakespearean arc of his temperament and his kind of ego. And that really helps draw you through like if he were just a supervillain at the beginning of the book, I think a lot of people wouldn't be as interested because more complicated villains are better villains, generally. So in that sense, I think, to
并不是说他只做了坏事。你知道的，我认为这很重要。而且，你知道的，你会得到他性格和某种自我意识中那种不可思议的莎士比亚式的弧光。这确实有助于吸引你一直读下去——如果他在书的开头只是一个超级大反派，我想很多人就不会那么感兴趣了，因为通常更复杂的反派才是更好的反派。所以在那种意义上，我认为，
again, like weave that sort of psychological profile together with the incredible investigative reporting. He's not the only one who has done it, but does it incredibly well. Yeah. In the section that we're talking about in this episode, there's a lot, and actually it's throughout the book, but there's a lot of the New York Times in particular
再次将那种心理侧写与不可思议的调查报道编织在一起。他不是唯一一个做到这一点的人，但他做得好得不可思议。是的。在我们这集讨论的这一部分中，有很多内容——实际上贯穿整本书——但其中有很多关于《纽约时报》尤其
failing to hold Robert Moses into account. And I mean, this is a time period where there was maybe like 27 local New York newspapers. You know what I mean? Like, you know, there's a lot of newspapers back then. And still, the degree to which one, you know, big news entity, not sort of seeing the story here or not valuing it or not agreeing with the criticism really set the agenda for what the city did. And it strikes me that today, it's like in terms of the news media, it's even worse.
未能追究罗伯特·摩西责任的内容。我的意思是，这是一个时期，当时可能大约有27份纽约本地报纸。你知道我的意思吗？就像，你知道的，当时有很多报纸。即便如此，某一个（你知道的）大型新闻实体，没有看到这个故事，或者不珍视它，或者不同意批评意见，却在很大程度上为这座城市采取的行动设定了议程。这让我想起，今天，在新闻媒体方面，情况甚至更糟。
There's just like fewer people doing the work. When you hear, like I'm not one of these new jerk, like the media gets it wrong type of people at all. I'm a big supporter, like tons of people who make news and who write the news, investigate the news. But could you reflect on this idea of like what it means to not have a diverse sort of body of work or people working to hold power know, hold power accountable.
做这项工作的人更少了。当你听到——我根本不是那种一听到“媒体搞砸了”就条件反射的人。我是个坚定的支持者，有大量制作新闻、撰写新闻、调查新闻的人。但你能反思一下这种观点吗：没有一个多元化的工作群体或致力于追究权力责任的人，这意味着什么？
Yeah. I mean, let's, let's first start with the failings of the media back then about Caro. And, and as you say, sorry about Moses. Yes. Um, that as you say, the Times was probably the worst offender, maybe mostly because it then as now was the most important of the papers. You know, and it seems like this really started with, uh, if a Jenny, am I pronouncing her name right? Um, Salzburg, who like, see, I say if, if a gene and you say something, but Elliott says it differently too.
是的。我的意思是，让我们，让我们首先从当年媒体对卡罗的过失开始。正如你所说，对不起，是关于摩西的。是的。嗯，正如你所说，《时报》可能是最糟糕的罪魁祸首，也许主要是因为它当时和现在一样，是所有报纸中最重要的一份。你知道的，这似乎真的始于，呃，伊菲琴妮（Ifigenia），我是不是把她的名字读对了？呃，萨尔茨堡（Salzburg），就像，看，我说伊菲琴妮，而你说别的，但埃利奥特读得也不一样。
I remember like, well, too I remember like I looked up also the Greek pronunciation I'm like I'm not touching that like I'm completely mangled out if I try but I'm I say I say if EG which was her record EG is a great it's like yeah it's a great rap name the owner of the times and I'm sitting out rhymes that kind kind of stuff. Yeah, she's, you know, it was early. It was early. It was primitive hip hop, but she was on the forefront. Yeah. That she, you know, she was a great Parks lover and booster and so really admired not
我记得就像——我也查了希腊语的发音，我想：“我才不碰那个呢，如果我试的话，我完全会把它念得面目全非。”但我说——我说伊菲格（Ifieg），这其实是个很棒的说唱歌手名字。这就像，是的，这是一个伟大的说唱歌手名字，报纸的所有者，我正坐在那儿想韵脚呢，诸如此类。是的，她，你知道的，这很早。这很早。这是原始嘻哈，但她走在前沿。是的。她，你知道的，她是一个伟大的公园爱好者和支持者，所以非常钦佩
everything, but mostly what he did with the Parks stuff. And then that just set the glide path to being blind or throwing her hands up at everything else because both that work was so important to her. And then once the Times, I think, had kind of got into this, you know, my view about him, I was thinking about how different actually reporting was back then. Because say you were even a reporter who got on a story about Moses, you know, 10, 20 years into his power. If you're a Times reporter, the place that you go look for what to think about him, what to know about him, would have been your own clip archives that would have been brought
并不是所有的东西，但主要是他对公园的事情所做的一切。然后这就为对其他事情视而不见或双手一摊奠定了滑行路径，因为这两项工作对她来说太重要了。一旦《时报》——我认为——已经陷入了这种状态，我对他的看法，我一直在思考当年的实际报道是多么不同。因为假设你甚至是一个报道摩西故事的记者，你知道的，在他掌权10年、20年之后。如果你是一个《时报》的记者，你去寻找对他的看法、了解他的地方，将会是你自己的剪报档案，这些档案会被带给你
up to you in some kind of folder by like the people who work in the morgue, what they call the clip room. front that they would be kind of relying on their past work. And so, you know, once there's a bias or a blind spot, that just gets reinforced. And, you know, I think we we see that time and again by the media in general and specifically. And then, you know, and then there's a sort of listening to the money men, right? I mean, that's always been a problem, just like, well, these are the people who have the money and the power and they say this is good. And so we're all for it.
由在资料室（morgue）工作的人以某种文件夹的形式呈递给你，他们把那叫做剪报室。他们会在某种程度上依赖他们过去的工作。所以，你知道的，一旦存在偏见或盲点，就会得到强化。而且，你知道的，我认为我们一次又一次地从整体媒体和特定媒体中看到这一点。然后，你知道的，然后还有那种听取金钱大鳄意见的做法，对吧？我的意思是，这一直是个问题，就像：好吧，这些人有钱有势，他们说这是好的，所以我们完全赞成。
I think what was interesting about these chapters is These are the people who have the money and the power, and they say this is good, and so we're all for it. I think what was interesting about these chapters is, it was the women's, the women's, WWC, right, the Women's Council. Yeah, yeah, yeah. That did the investigating in the sort of, the low income areas, yeah. The Women's City Club, yeah.
我认为这些章节有趣的地方在于：这些人有钱有势，他们说这是好的，所以我们完全赞成。我认为这些章节有趣的地方在于，是女性的，女性的，WWC，对吧，妇女联合会（Women's Council）。是的，是的，是的。她们在低收入地区进行了调查，是的。妇女城市俱乐部（Women's City Club），是的。
Women's City Club, there you go. Who went out and did their own investigation, and not journalists, like, but did their own investigation, and not journalists, like, but did their own investigation to track down what happened to the tenants of the various Title I housing projects that were being displaced. They were told they were going to get, you know, some kind of new housing that would be as good or better
妇女城市俱乐部，就是这样。她们走出去进行了自己的调查，而且不是记者，就像，但进行了自己的调查，追踪了正在流离失所的各种第一章（Title I）住房项目的租户身上发生了什么。她们被告知将会得到，你知道的，某种与她们被赶出的住房一样好或更好的新住房，但实际发生的事情是怎样的。这些女性真的做了一项英勇的工作，再次声明，不是专业记者，不是，你知道的，在当时的习俗中，可能不是很多女性经常会去做的事情，却发现了这些极好的东西。然后她们去了所有的报纸，
than the housing that they had booted from, what actually happened. And these women really did like a heroic job, again, not professional journalists, not, you know, in the mores of the times, probably not a thing that a lot of women went out to do that often, and found this great stuff. And then they went to all the papers,
报纸在这里和那里做了一点报道，但似乎大多耸耸肩不予理睬。所以再次，在，你知道的，现在她们会有其他渠道——在这里和那里做一点报道，但似乎大多耸耸肩不予理睬。所以再次，现在她们会有其他渠道来利用这一点，她们会拍TikTok（抖音），我不知道她们会做什么。她们会设法把这些信息传播出去，希望如此。但在当时，情况就是这样。
and the papers did a little bit here and there, but seemed to mostly shrug it off. And so again, like in, you know, now they would have kind of other venues bit here and there, but seemed to mostly shrug it off. And so again, now they would have other venues to maybe take that, they'd make a TikTok, I don't know what they do. They'd get that information out somehow, hopefully. But at the time, that was sort of it.
你可以去找记者——几乎全都是男性——然后把你准备好的档案交给他，他们会严肃对待你，或者不严肃对待你，如果在那里发现干扰，他们愿意与编辑抗争，或者不愿意。所以这在某种程度上就是当时的结构。我的意思是，今天，老实说，当我看到人们——当然是在社交媒体上——为一篇时机糟糕的头条新闻或诸如此类的事情而情绪激昂时，我所担心的是
You could go to the reporters, almost all of whom were men, and give them the dossier that you had prepared, and they would take you seriously or not, reporters, almost all of whom were men, and give them the dossier that you had prepared and they would take you seriously or not and be willing to run up against their editors or not if they found interference there. So that sort of impart the structure back then. I mean today, honestly, what I'm worried about when people get, certainly on social media, spin themselves up about a terrible timed headline or this, that, or the other.
你可以去找记者——他们几乎全都是男性——把准备好的材料交给他，他们或许会认真对待，或许不会，记者几乎全都是男性，把准备好的材料交给他，他们或许会认真对待，或许不会，如果遇到干涉，他们是否愿意顶住编辑的压力也未可知。所以这就是当时那种结构的大致情况。我的意思是，说实话，今天当人们在社交媒体上因为一个时机糟糕的标题或者诸如此类的事情而情绪激动、自寻烦恼时，我真正担心的是这些。
Robert Carroll first got into this, he's like a reporter at Newsday, and some day where everybody else was out the company picnic and he was the only guy like left on the city desk and someone's like, I got a big dossier on some, you know, regional airport situation. And he tried to call the like investigative editors and reporters and everyone was at the picnic. And so like, eventually, he just goes and looks through all this stuff. And that's, you know, in his telling, that's how he got this bug. And there aren't there aren't a lot of reporters out there in the world who And there aren't a lot of reporters out there in the world who get to spend days and weeks combing through papers. I mean, a lot of places, nobody's going to city council meetings, nobody's going to zoning board meetings, there's just nothing.
罗伯特·卡罗最初入行时，在《纽约新闻报》当记者。有一次，公司举行野餐，所有人都去了，只有他一个人留在城市新闻台值班。有人打电话来说，他手里有一份关于某个区域机场情况的大型材料。卡罗试图打电话给调查编辑和记者，但大家都去野餐了。于是，最后他只好自己去翻看所有这些资料。按他自己的说法，他就是这样染上了调查报道这个“瘾”。世界上并没有多少记者能够有幸花上几天甚至几周的时间去仔细翻阅文件。我的意思是，在很多地方，没有人去参加市议会会议，没有人去参加区划委员会会议，那里简直一片空白。
And so I'm much more worried about the, in the broadest view, that the problem with the media right now is that it's sort of like, if you imagine a marine food web or something, and you might be focused on the tuna or the whale or whatever, but if there's no plankton, all of that stuff eventually runs into real trouble. And that, I think, is the largest problem. Yes, there's still biased and blindspots. You know, journalists are humans, but it's just, you know, I mean, it's hundreds of thousands of jobs
因此，从最宏观的角度来看，我更担心的是，当前媒体的问题在于，如果你想象一个海洋食物网之类的东西，你可能会把注意力放在金枪鱼、鲸鱼或别的什么动物上，但如果没有浮游生物，所有这些生物最终都会陷入真正的困境。我认为，这才是最核心的问题。是的，媒体仍然存在偏见和盲区。你知道，记者也是人，但关键是，仅在过去十年里，
in the last decade alone all across the country. Yeah. I mean, that's what I read into this when he has these criticisms of the New York Times is not so much that the fix was in or some kind of thing. It is about that sort of institutional legacy, the trust of institutions. So when Robert Moses says something, a few rabble rousers doesn't really merit. And the fact that all this information is funneled towards a couple people with their biases and
全美就有成千上万个工作岗位消失了。是的。我的意思是，当我读到他对《纽约时报》的这些批评时，我的理解并不是说有什么内幕交易或诸如此类的事情。这更多关乎那种体制的传承以及对体制的信任。所以当罗伯特·摩西发表言论时，几个持异见者的反抗其实并不算什么。然而，所有这些信息都被汇集到少数带有自身偏见的人手中，
therefore the best remedy for that is having a lot of people with a lot of different biases. Like you're not going to eliminate the biases, but it's nice to have a bunch of people who they're, you know, cause other biases like mine would be like, Oh yeah, let's take that fucker down. I mean, that would be my instinct is to not believe them rather than to believe him.
因此，解决这个问题的最好方法是拥有大量持有各种不同偏见的人。你不可能消除偏见，但如果能有一群人，他们会产生其他的偏见——比如我的偏见可能会是：“哦，对，让我们把那个混蛋搞垮。”我的直觉往往是去怀疑他们，而不是相信他们。
And I wouldn't be a responsible steward of a paper if I always acted on that impulse either, but there's enough papers that it doesn't, that it sort of all comes out in the wash, you know. But the idea that there was that choke point then and now so much of our like, you know, the New York Times is there to defend our democracy is like the last one on the wall type of thing is really scares the crap out of me. Yeah, I mean, again, it's, you know, I think mostly what the Times does is great.
如果我总是凭这种冲动行事，我也就不配做一个对报纸负责的管理者了，但只要报纸数量足够多，这种影响最终就会在整体中被平衡掉，你知道的。然而，过去存在那样一个信息咽喉，而现在我们的许多观念——比如“《纽约时报》的存在是为了捍卫我们的民主，它是最后的坚守者”——这种想法真的把我吓坏了。是的，我的意思是，再说一次，我认为《时报》做的大多数事情都非常棒。
And it's just that we need more than just the Times. And whether it's just the Times there, nothing is a check on the Times. And, you know, they're so much bigger than even the next biggest paper in both reach and influence. That it's, you know, it's also an ecosystem where everyone's trying to get to the Times. I mean, not everyone, but like, you know, that's where the career paths go.
只是我们需要的不光是《时报》。如果只有《时报》在那儿，就没有什么东西能够对《时报》形成制约。而且，你知道的，无论是在影响力还是覆盖范围上，它都比排在它后面的第二大报纸庞大得多。这就形成了一种生态系统：每个人都想挤进《时报》。我的意思是，也不是所有人，但你知道的，那是职业生涯的必经之路。
And that also really has a sort of punishing effect on really important, you know, journalism that isn't based in New York, that, you know, requires a different type of person to go out and report it different life experiences. So yeah, it's, it's a little grim out there for the media. Yeah, it feels a little bit like the New York Times is like the United States of America of newspapers, where it's the it's much bigger than any of the other ones. It feels a little bit like the New York Times is like the United States of America of newspapers, where it's much bigger than any of the other ones. It's much more powerful than the other ones,
这也对那些并非立足于纽约、极其重要的、需要不同类型的人去实地报道、需要不同人生经历的真正好的新闻，产生了一种惩罚性的效果。所以，是的，对于媒体来说，目前的处境确实有点严峻。是的，感觉《纽约时报》就像是报纸界的“美利坚合众国”，它比其他任何报纸都要大得多。感觉《纽约时报》就像是报纸界的“美利坚合众国”，它比其他任何报纸都要庞大得多。它比其他报纸强大得多，
but it's imperfect. Like the idea that there should be a perfect paper that does everything you want it to do is an insane notion. Especially when you look back in The Power Broker and you're like, oh, they've kind of always been like this. Like it's always been a flawed newspaper. And I remember 20 years ago,
但它并不完美。认为应该有一份完美的报纸来满足你所有的期望，这种想法简直荒谬绝伦。特别是当你回看《权力掮客》时，你会发现：哦，他们一直以来差不多就是这样的。它从来就不是一份完美的报纸。我记得20年岁时，
coming out of college and reading the Times' coverage of whether there were weapons of mass destruction in Iraq and at the time being like, how could the Times do this? And it's frustrating to feel like it's 50 years after the fact. And I'm still kind of frustrated with the New York Times for the same things back then. But again, it's only, they're only people, you know, I shouldn't expect so much of them just because they have the word New York in their name. But I do, you know. Yeah, and I think there was a line in there that was like, the fate of poor people had never been a subject of news in New York City. And it wasn't now. And I, I, I think that
刚大学毕业的我读着《时报》关于伊拉克是否存在大规模杀伤性问题的报道，当时就在想：怎么能这样呢？《时报》怎么能这么做？而50年后的今天，这种感觉依然令人沮丧。对于当年《纽约时报》犯下的那些老毛病，我至今仍感到有些沮丧。不过话说回来，他们也只是凡人，你知道的，我不该仅仅因为他们名字里带有“纽约”两个字，就对他们抱有那么高的期望。但我偏偏就是抱了期望。是的，我记得里面有一句话是这样的：穷人的命运在纽约市从来都不是新闻的主题。现在也不是。而且，我、我、我认为
that is still true. Again, in part because they're, you know, even with a time, there's just not enough people going out and covering all these little things that would lead you to the big story necessarily. But also that, you know, those aren't the stories that are going to get you a lot of attention most of the time. Yes, if you produce the power broker, you'll get some attention, but the individual stories that might lead you there if you're a beat reporter, are probably not the most well read,
这种情况至今依然存在。一方面是因为，即使对于《时报》来说，也没有足够的人去实地采访和报道所有这些小事情——而这些小事情本来是必然会引导你走向大新闻的。但另一方面也是因为，大多数时候，这些并不是那种能为你赢得大量关注的故事。是的，如果你写出了《权力掮客》，你会获得一些关注，但如果你是一个跑口记者，那些可能引领你走向大事件的零星报道，很可能并不是阅读量最大、
well regarded, well shared. And that those amplification incentive factors are even greater in social media era, for sure. When I think about the qualities that are like the hallmarks of a Mother Jones, a Big Mother Jones story, it shares a lot of the DNA of the power broker. Like it has a sort of a humanist point of view. It's about systems and trying to get an investigation
最受推崇或分享最多的。而在社交媒体时代，这种放大效应和激励机制无疑更加明显。当我思考那些堪称《琼斯母亲》杂志标志的报道时，我发现它们带有许多《权力掮客》的基因。比如它拥有一种人道主义的视角。它关乎体制，关乎如何进行调查，
to get the facts and sort of reveal the system. But that is a rarer and rarer position that magazines occupy. How do you keep that going? You know, what is the underlying principle that keeps that, you know, to be the forefront of what Mother Jones does? I mean, it's really interesting.
以弄清真相并揭露体制的运作方式。但对于杂志而言，这种立场已经变得越来越稀缺。你们是如何维持这种风格的呢？你知道，支撑这种风格成为《琼斯母亲》杂志核心宗旨的根本原则是什么？我的意思是，这真的非常有趣。
In some ways, I think it's almost driven by the products that you have. For, you know, we have a magazine, and that's, you know, been a staple, and now we have a long-form radio show that does, you know, in a very different way, I think it's almost driven by the products that you have. We have a magazine, and that's been a staple, and now we have a long-form radio show that does in very different way, but same sort of intensive investigative journalism. And because we have those things, we have the muscle memory, We do a lot of short video. We do a lot of daily news reporting. But it's harder and harder to access workplaces
在某种程度上，我认为这几乎是由你们拥有的产品所驱动的。比如，我们有一本杂志，这是一直以来的核心支柱，而现在我们还有一档深度广播节目，它以一种非常不同的方式……我认为这几乎是由你们的产品所驱动的。我们有一本杂志，一直是我们的核心，现在我们还有一档深度广播节目，它以截然不同但同样是深入调查的方式进行新闻报道。正因为我们拥有这些，我们才保留了这种肌肉记忆。我们做了很多短视频。我们做了大量日常新闻报道。但是，想要进入那些
that kind of operate in longer form, more in-depth work. There are just, again, fewer of them. So I think that that's part of it. And then I think Mother Jones has always held up as his mission, like looking out know, looking out for the little guy, like looking out for the people that are getting quashed by whatever it is. Sometimes it's government, sometimes it's private industry,
能够从事更长篇幅、更深度报道的工作场所，变得越来越难了。再次强调，这样的地方越来越少了。所以我觉得这是原因之一。然后我认为，《琼斯母亲》一直将“为底层发声”奉为自己的使命，也就是关注那些被各种力量压榨的人们。有时是政府，有时是私人企业，
but like a lot of the great work that we do comes from just asking like, what's happening to these people or why, you know, why are we hearing about this amazing thing and what's the underside to that? You know, for example, we did a few years ago, Shane Bauer, um, did this fantastic piece where he went again, undercover in a private prison and we had done a lot of private prison reporting.
但我们的许多优秀作品都源于这样简单的发问：这些人身上到底发生了什么？或者说，为什么我们听到的都是这些了不起的事情，而背后的阴暗面是什么？比如，几年前，肖恩·鲍尔（Shane Bauer）完成了一篇极其精彩的报道，他再次潜入一家私营监狱当卧底，而我们之前已经做过很多关于私营监狱的报道。
And, um, he is a delightful madman who wanted to do this. And, um, there were many nights for more than a year, But I was going to say that seems like the scariest possible, or one of the two or three scariest possible assignments I can imagine. Yes. Unless it was like you're going to live in a den of tigers for like a year. And he also went undercover with a militia. So, you know, it wasn't his only piece like that for us. Every now and then you hear about a job and you're like, I am not cut out to do that job.
而且，他是一个可爱至极的狂人，一心想做这件事。在一年多的时间里，有很多个夜晚……我是想说，这听起来像是我想象中极其可怕、或者说最可怕的两三个任务之一。是的。除非任务是“去虎穴里生活一年”。而且他还曾作为卧底混入一个民兵组织。所以，这并不是他为我们做的唯一此类报道。你偶尔会听到某种工作，然后心想：我可干不了这活儿。
I'm glad somebody else is. Yeah. Yeah. And I think one of the most interesting things about that work, for example, was that Shane had been held in captivity by Iran for more than a year. So he had been in solitary confinement. He had his own personal crazy journey through one of the worst prisons in the world. But that said, he brought a real sense of humanity to the guards who he realized are all earning nine bucks an hour and are really not that much different
庆幸还有别人愿意干。是的。是的。我认为这项工作最有趣的地方之一在于，肖恩此前曾被伊朗扣押长达一年多。所以他曾被关过单人禁闭。他经历过个人极其疯狂的一段旅程，关押在世界上最糟糕的监狱之一。即便如此，他对那些狱警依然抱有一种真正的人性关怀。他意识到这些狱警每小时只挣九块钱，其实跟他们看守的囚犯并没有太大的区别，
than the prisoners that are guarding. Their economic circumstances aren't that different. These are the only jobs around. What does it mean to have to do that kind of a job, and especially in a facility that's so under-resourced, as many of them are? And I think that, too, is really having that kind of eye for the humanity, even in the things that you find to be suspect or corrupt in some way, which I think Caro is also really good at.
他们的经济状况相差无几。这只是当地仅有的工作岗位。不得不做这样一份工作意味着什么？特别是在一个资源极度匮乏的设施里——许多监狱都是如此。我认为，这也是那种对人性的敏锐洞察力的体现，即使在你发现某些事物可疑或某种程度上腐败时也是如此，而我认为卡罗在这方面也非常出色。
I mean, Moses himself, I think, becomes an increasingly remote figure when it comes to sympathy from the reader. But we get to know him better and better. And that is just so important to this kind of work. Yeah. And you know the human he was when he started, which makes the whole narrative arc so, so compelling is that you sense his idealism and his vision for seeing things that no one
我的意思是，随着读者对摩西的了解加深，摩西本人对读者来说似乎变得越来越缺乏同理心。但我们对他却越来越了解。而这对于这种类型的创作来说至关重要。是的。而且你知道他刚开始时是个怎样的人，这使得整个叙事弧光变得极其引人入胜——你能感受到他的理想主义，感受到他那种能够看到别人
else can see. And it's one of the things that I think when people are craving a modern day Moses in terms of they're like people who can get stuff done and who can dream big and build big things and create their megopolises. Libertarian sea studs. I think that's what they're drawn to. If it was just the latter part,
看不到的东西的远见。这就是为什么当人们渴望现代版的摩西时——那种能把事情办成、敢想敢干、能够建造宏伟工程并创建超级大都市的人——我猜这就是吸引他们的地方。自由主义的海上家园（Seasteads）。我认为这正是吸引他们的原因。如果只有后面那一部分，
I don't know if they would be quite as drawn to it. But I am struck by this idea, you know, like, one of the things I've been trying to articulate to people, I've been interviewed a lot about this sort of anniversary. I've noticed, Roman, I'll get a lot of Google alerts that are like, oh, Roman Mars is talking about this thing. And I'm like, oh, okay, interesting.
我不知道人们是否还会如此被吸引。但我对这样一个想法深有感触，你知道的，我一直在试图向人们阐述这一点——最近关于这个纪念日，我接受了很多采访。罗曼，我注意到我会收到很多谷歌快讯，内容都是“哦，罗曼·马尔斯在谈论这件事”。然后我想：“哦，好吧，真有意思。”
I was involved in that podcast. I'm just kidding, mostly. But one of the things I've said in every one of them that's never been picked up on, because it's not a very good sound bite, is I think one of the underlying benefits to people reading this book is not learning how studies are built or how power is done or this sort of deep exploration of this man, Robert Moses.
我确实参与了那个播客。开个玩笑，其实大部分都是。但在我接受的每一次采访中，我都会提到一个观点，却从来没有被媒体报道过，因为这句话很不适合做精辟的引语：我认为人们阅读这本书的根本收益之一，并不是学习城市是如何建造的、权力是如何运作的，或者对罗伯特·摩西这个人进行这种深度的探索。
It's actually sitting in the company of this really thoughtful humanist in the form of Robert Caro and the way he sees the world and that that is what is so uplifting and profound about the book when so much of it can be dire and and very devastating to read. I think one of the things I love most about this book is that he does center the little people he does a great job at finding you know, I don't know if it was really women who again and again were like the people kind of jumping in
而是去陪伴这样一位真正富有思想的人道主义者——也就是罗伯特·卡罗，去体味他看待世界的方式。正是这种视角，才让这本书在充满绝望和毁灭性阅读体验的同时，显得如此振奋人心且意义深远。我认为我最喜欢这本书的一点，是他在书中真正关注了小人物。他非常擅长寻找……你知道的，我不确定这是否真的是那些女性——她们一次又一次地站出来，
Robert Moses' way, but he does a great job of, of, you know, whether it's the Women's City Club or the, yeah, the Tremont folks who are, you know, housewives kind of leading the charge there. And, you know, really goes out and leading the charge there and, you know, really goes out and finds them and treats them with dignity and respect and does the careful work of taking them seriously and really understanding their circumstances and I, you know, there's a version of this book that would still be
挡在罗伯特·摩西的路上。但无论是妇女城市俱乐部（Women's City Club），还是特里蒙特（Tremont）那些带头抗争的家庭主妇，他都把她们描写得极其出色。他确实走出去寻找这些人，给予他们尊严和尊重，认真地对待他们，真正去理解他们的处境。你知道的，这本书完全可以写成另一个版本，
very good but didn't accomplish that and And I think that is the difference maker, honestly, in this. I mean, the majesty of it all, for sure. But it's those small, intimate details and stories and the sort of sympathy and empathy that he brings to folks that he may not have had all that much in common with before or known much about, but he's going to go spend eight months on that avenue to figure out who everybody was involved in that movement, and he manages to pull that off so well.
尽管仍然会很优秀，但却无法达到这种效果。说实话，这正是本书的点睛之笔。当然，宏大的叙事也很壮丽，但正是那些细微、亲密的细节和故事，以及他对他可能原本并不熟悉、也没有太多共同点的人所流露出的同情与共情，让他能够抽出八个月的时间去深入那条大街，弄清楚所有参与这场运动的人都是谁，而他居然把这一切写得如此完美。
Yeah, there's a lot of the retrospectives that have been coming out, especially now there's also a lot of articles coming out that are like 50 years on, the power broker doesn't do everything right, and it's like, well, yeah, of course, it's a book and also it's 50, it's a half a century old. So, but I've seen a number of times and also in the contemporary reviews of it, they accuse it of pushing the kind of great man view of history that Moses is this great world changer and everyone else is just kind of in his wake. And it feels like that's such a misreading to me of so much of the book because he does highlight so many other human beings. They don't get the same amount of space as Robert Moses does.
是的，有很多回顾性文章不断涌现，特别是现在也有很多文章指出，半个世纪过去了，《权力掮客》里有些东西并没有写对。这就好比：废话，当然了，这不仅是一本书，而且它已经有半个世纪的历史了。不过，我多次看到——包括在当时的同时代书评中——人们指责它推崇历史上的“英雄史观”，认为摩西是那个改变世界的伟大人物，而其他所有人都只是他身后的随从。在我看来，这种观点对书中内容的理解存在巨大的偏差，因为他在书中着墨突出了那么多其他的人物。虽然他们没有获得与罗伯特·摩西等同的篇幅，
And each of these people is someone who is striving to accomplish something, is fighting for either their own livelihood or to get some kind of truth out. And we've seen them a number of times in the series, these like little biographies of these kind of heroes that that Carol is clearly bringing up who are usually people who do a lot of research and a lot of investigation. He likes people who go and look up answers to questions or talk to people to get the answers to questions, but that it is such a hidden beneath this kind of argument about why this way of running a city and constructing a city isn't there. There's this kind of hidden celebration of and constructing a city isn't there. There's this kind of hidden celebration
但这些人物中的每一个人都在努力成就一番事业，要么在为自己的生计而奋斗，要么在努力揭露某种真相。我们在整个系列中多次看到，卡罗显然是在着力刻画这些英雄人物的小传，他们通常都是那些做了大量研究和调查的人。他喜欢那些去寻找问题答案、或通过与人交谈来探寻答案的人。但在关于“为什么这种城市运营和建设方式行不通”的论述背后，隐藏着一种对普通人的赞美——
of ordinary people who are either doing a job that is trying to make a difference or forced out of their normal lives in order to end making a difference in that way. And there's something very exciting about it that it makes it feel so much more like the portrait of a city, you know, than just this one guy and the clay that he's working with.
这些人要么在从事试图带来改变的工作，要么是被迫离开正常生活以那种方式去创造改变。这其中有一种非常激动人心的特质，让它感觉更像是一座城市的肖像，而不单单是某个家伙和他手头泥巴的故事。
You know, it's something that Carol does so well that now reading other biographies, I do miss it. If there's like a three sentence sketch of some person, I'm like, what about, you know, what about that person's dreams? What about the rest of their life? You know? Yeah. I mean, this book really contains multitudes. Like they're, you know, full on, you know, profile worthy books in there's certainly of LaGuardia and L. Smith, but others along the way. And it's just like, wow, that's, I really felt I learned more about,
你知道的，这是卡罗非常擅长的一点，以至于现在读其他传记时，我都会怀念这种写法。如果书中只有三句话来勾勒某个人物，我就会想：那个人梦想呢？他的余生呢？你知道吗？是的。我的意思是，这本书真的包罗万象。比如里面有绝对值得为其立传的完整人物画像，当然有拉瓜迪亚（LaGuardia）和埃尔·史密斯（Al Smith），还有沿途遇到的其他人。感觉就像是：哇，这让我觉得自己对
you know, many, many mayors, even the really, uh, even, I've come, I've come to really love him for all the wrong reasons, I guess. Um, then I, you know, then I, then I had known even when I lived in New York. So I think that's really rewarding. I'm curious what you guys think if the kind of critique of Moses and everything that Moses stood for kind of set the country and maybe particularly sort of more progressive folks down a path
许多许多市长——甚至包括那些……我甚至出于各种“错误”的原因开始真正喜爱他——了解得更多了，比我住在纽约时了解得还要多。所以我认为这真的很有收获。我很想听听你们的看法：对摩西及其所代表的一切的批判，是否让国家——或许尤其是那些更具进步倾向的人们——走上了一条
where they're so suspicious of any development, any massive projects, be they public, private, a hybrid, that that's part of why we kind of find ourselves where we are, which is stuff is crumbling, nothing's getting built, you know, everything is being held up in a community meeting, which of course, even though Jane Jacobs isn't mentioned in this book, that ultimately this sort of, you know, city is a collection of neighborhoods that all need to be listened to. If you think that that, you know, we're in a weird moment where it's not like anyone wants a Moses, but we also don't want paralysis.
对任何开发项目、任何大规模项目（无论是公私合营还是混合项目）都抱有极度怀疑的道路？这是否正是我们今天陷入这种境地的部分原因：基础设施正在崩塌，什么都建不成，（你知道的）一切都被没完没了的社区会议给耽搁了？当然，尽管简·雅各布斯（Jane Jacobs）在这本书中没有被提及，但其核心理念最终是：城市是由需要被倾听的各个街区组成的集合。如果你认为我们正处于一个奇怪的时刻——没有人真正想要一个摩西，但我们也不想要陷入瘫痪状态。
I, Roman may disagree with me, but I am going to draw a parallel between We've so we clashed so many times on this show the I'm gonna draw parallel between the way people talk about Robert Caro's critique of Moses that it's elevating him in too much importance And it's making him too much that the single the single thing the single source of it all and I think that that criticism of the book commits the same sin when you look at the history of the United States since this book was written, and it's like, it's not like America didn't need Robert Caro to make it distrust authority, you know, like Watergate and the Vietnam War and so forth did that. And America didn't need Robert Caro to make it dislike large spending on public works projects, because Ronald Reagan did plenty of that. It feels like it is the same way people will make the criticism. They'll say Robert Moses is a symptom. He's an avatar
罗曼可能会不同意我的看法，但我打算做一个类比。我们在节目中已经交锋过无数次了……我打算把人们谈论罗伯特·卡罗对摩西的批判的方式——认为它赋予了摩西过高的重要性，把他塑造成了唯一的、一切问题的根源——与此进行类比。我认为对这本书的这种批评犯了同样的错误。当你回顾这本书问世以来的美国历史时就会发现，美国并不需要罗伯特·卡罗来教导它不信任权威，水门事件、越南战争等历史事件就已经做到了这一点。美国也不需要罗伯特·卡罗来教导它厌恶公共工程的大笔开支，因为罗纳德·里根在这方面已经做了足够多。这就好比人们提出的另一种批评：他们会说罗伯特·卡罗只是个表象，他是
of the larger thinking of the time rather than the source of it. I think you could look at the book kind of the same way in some ways, and that to elevate, maybe it has an outsized proportional importance to urban planners, you know, but that kind of work would only be in this state if America had been driving in that direction to a certain amount anyway. So as much as I love this book, I feel like I can't give it all the credit or nor blame for what's going on. Roman, what do you think about that? I think that's similar to my reaction to that, which is it wasn't Carol pointed it out that caused the problem.
时代大思潮的一个化身，而不是根源。我想你也可以用同样的方式来看待这本书，也许它对城市规划者有着超乎寻常的重要影响，但如果美国当时没有朝着那个方向发展，这种工作也只会停留在这种状态。所以，尽管我深爱这本书，但我觉得我不能把当前发生的一切完全归功于它，也不能把责任归咎于它。罗曼，你怎么看？我认为这类似于我对这个问题的反应，也就是：造成问题的不是卡罗指出了这一点，
It's that Robert Moses built shitty public housing and didn't maintain it. And that is the part that's being kind of over-corrected for, that the bad actors who literally built the things and did not care for them and designed these really tight closed systems that had no fault tolerance whatsoever, like a real community does, are the people that failed in this scenario.
而是罗伯特·摩西建造了糟糕的公共住房却疏于维护。而人们现在纠枉过正的，正是这部分问题。那些真正建造了这些建筑、却对它们不管不顾、设计出毫无容错能力的封闭系统（而真正的社区绝非如此）的糟糕决策者，才是这个剧本中真正失败的人。
And pulling it out is not really the issue. You know what I mean? And I don't think people are overcorrecting for the power broker. I think they're overcorrecting for the sins that these people committed. And they were bad. I mean, they really did not serve the communities they were supposed to serve. And we've had to deal with that failure
指出这一点并不是真正的问题所在。你知道我的意思吗？我不认为人们是在对《权力掮客》进行过度矫枉，我认为他们是在对这些人犯下的罪孽进行矫枉过正。而且这些罪孽确实很恶劣。我的意思是，他们确实没有服务好他们理应服务的社区。我们不得不面对这种失败，
for a long, long time. But what I think was powerful about The Power Broker is it teaches you kind of indirectly the method to which to make it better. I'm really struck by the fact that the book is called The Power Broker. It's not called The City Builder. It's not called The Master Builder or whatever other things you might think of as a moniker for Robert Moses.
持续了很长、很长的时间。但我认为《权力掮客》强大之处在于，它间接地教给了你让事情变得更好的方法。我印象深刻的是，这本书书名叫《权力掮客》，它不叫《城市建设者》，不叫《总体规划师》，也不叫你可能会联想到罗伯特·摩西的其他头衔。
He's really focused on power and the human here. In a way, he's not really trying to explain all cities, you know, but what he's saying is that the root rot of this problem is the lack of democracy. That's what Caro really holds onto. And to me, you know, these projects are things that fail. Is that same problem, a kind of lack of input, a lack of care, a lack of like not having enough influences
他真正关注的是权力和其中的人性。从某种意义上说，他并不是真的在试图解释所有的城市，你知道的，他想说的是：这个问题的根源在于民主的缺失。这正是卡罗真正坚守的核心。对我来说，你知道的，这些项目的失败，
and expertise and material and it all being top down. A public housing system is great when everything works. It's just that it can handle failure so, so poorly. Like it has to have a diversity of incomes and races. It has to have working lights and safety and stuff. And when one of those things fall apart, like when Prude Igo fell apart in St. Louis, it crumbles dramatically. But in the beginning, it works really well. And that's just the problem of an idea in your head versus a thing in action.
也是因为同样的问题：缺乏民意输入、缺乏关怀、缺乏多元的影响力、专业知识和资源，一切都是自上而下的。公共住房系统在一切运转顺利时是很棒的。只是它承受失败的能力太差太差了。就像它必须包容不同收入和种族的多样性一样，它必须拥有正常工作的照明、安全等等。当其中某一个环节崩塌时——比如圣路易斯的普鲁伊特-伊戈（Pruitt-Igoe）大厦倒塌时——它就会以戏剧性的方式彻底崩溃。但在最初，它的确运作得非常好。这就是脑海中的构想与实际行动之间的矛盾所在。
And it just so happens that the Robert Moses types of the world who make things have much more fealty to the idea in their head than the actual thing that's created. And that would all be worked out through iteration and input and all sorts of other things that would make things good. So I would say that Robert Moses ruined it for all of us, not the knee-jerk reaction that the power broker brings. It is the lived reality of the failure of public housing, the failure to the community it's supposed to serve most of all, that I think people are reacting to
碰巧的是，世界上罗伯特·摩西这种类型的人更忠于自己脑海中的构想，而不是实际创造出来的东西。而这一切本可以通过反复迭代、民意收集以及其他各种能让事情变得美好的方式来解决。所以我要说的是，是世界上罗伯特·摩西这样的人毁了我们所有人，而不是《权力掮客》带来的膝跳反应。人们做出反应，更多是因为公共住房失败的现实生活，是因为未能服务好最需要服务的社区这一事实，
more than just its criticisms. Yeah, for sure. I guess what I was sort of driving at is that there's a critique now voiced by among others, Ezra Klein and so forth that like, we have gotten into this dynamic where any objector to any project can stop many, certainly in California, many projects for any reason. Sometimes those reasons are valid.
而不仅仅是对书中批判的反应。是的，当然。我想我刚才要表达的是，现在有一种由以兹拉·克莱恩（Ezra Klein）等人提出的批评意见，大意是：我们陷入了这样一种动态，即任何项目的反对者都可以阻止许多项目，尤其是在加利福尼亚州，他们可以以任何理由阻止许多项目。有时这些理由是充分的，
Sometimes they're not that valid. And this in part is a system that sort of grew up as a corrective to the many projects for any reason. Sometimes those reasons are valid, sometimes they're not that valid. And this in part is a system that sort of grew up as a corrective to the absence of that. Yes. And I think that that's a really, I just had that in my head a lot while I was reading this book about where are we going to hit that balance correctly? And I think that's a good criticism of the state of the world, is that we've probably overcorrected for, and a kind of knee-jerk nimbism is just a part of our modern progressive DNA.
有时这些理由并不是那么充分。而这在某种程度上是一个逐步发展起来的系统，用以纠正……有时这些理由是充分的，有时这些理由并不是那么充分。而这在某种程度上是一个逐步发展起来的系统，用以纠正过去那种缺乏民意反馈的弊端。是的。我认为这确实是一个……我在读这本书时，脑子里一直盘旋着这个问题：我们将在哪里正确找到这种平衡？我认为这是对世界现状的一个很好的批评，那就是我们可能对过去的矫枉过正反应过度了，而一种膝跳反射般的邻避主义（NIMBYism）已经成为我们现代进步主义基因的一部分。
And that's one of the reasons why it's like, it's a disappointing aspect of a branch of progressivism to not embrace imperfect solutions that will help a lot of people. But I do get a sense that it's beginning to turn a little bit, and the sense that, okay, well, maybe we are too reactionary about change and we have to serve as many people as possible. And I do think that these things come in waves and they come in fashion and go down again. And the truth is, it's going to be a case by case on every single issue of this. Like it's really gonna have to be decided based off of the merit of every single development
这也是为什么说，进步主义的一个令人失望的支脉是无法接受那些能够帮助很多人的不完美解决方案。但我确实感觉到这种风气正在开始发生一点转变，人们开始意识到：好吧，也许我们对变革的反应过于保守了，我们需要服务尽可能多的人。我确实认为这些事情是一波接一波的，它们有自己的流行周期，起起伏伏。但事实是，对于每一个这样的议题，都需要具体问题具体分析。这真的必须根据每一个开发项目的实际价值
and what the cost is. And it just so happens that in the Robert Moses era, it was only up to him. And that's the huge mistake. And we don't have that same problem today because there's not one person. But I do feel that sense of like people have a default sense that a certain type of development
以及其付出的代价来决定。碰巧在罗伯特·摩西的时代，一切都由他一个人说了算。这就是巨大的错误。而我们今天没有那个相同的问题，因为不再只有一个人独断专行。但我确实能感受到那种默认的心态：人们本能地觉得某种特定类型的开发项目
is bad. And we have to stop because there's bigger problems to solve and we need to take in as much information. The biggest sin that Robert Moses had was that he could take in no new information his entire life. Cars were leisure vehicles. Cars were just going to be for fun.
是坏事。我们必须停下来，因为有更大的问题需要解决，我们需要吸收尽可能多的信息。罗伯特·摩西最大的罪过在于，他一生中都无法吸收任何新的信息。汽车对他来说只是休闲工具。汽车纯粹就是为了好玩。
We can't move the road. I already drew the line on the map. Yeah, exactly. Yeah. And also just like, I don't care if I'm in traffic for two hours because I'm sitting in the backseat working and somebody is driving me. Sounds pretty nice actually. And so what I hope is that the leaders of today and the people who support them will accept a kind of thoughtful ambivalence about things. Like not being just a diehard about one thing or another and just like, in this case, this makes sense, in this case, this makes sense.
我们不能移动这条道路。我已经把线画在地图上了。是的，完全正确。还有，诸如：我才不在乎自己是不是堵车两小时呢，因为我正坐在后座工作，有人在帮我开车。听起来其实还挺不错的。所以我希望今天的领导者以及支持他们的人能够接受一种关于事物的、带有思考性的矛盾心理。比如不要对某一种观点或另一种观点死板顽固，而是要看：在这种情况下，这样做合理；在那种情况下，那样做合理。
And I would love if we all just got behind people like that. Yeah, and I do feel a great sense of optimism on that front that I think just, you know, Californians at least who probably are everywhere in the country just kind of got so sick of the sclerosis that they just individually dug up their, dug in and started to like figure out zoning codes and go to hearings and so forth because it just wasn't, it wasn't kind of breaking out of the, the the the you know the dynamics that it had been in for a long time and and that is super encouraging and I think you know shows that really explain this kind of thing as yours does also help us
如果大家都能支持这样的人，我会非常高兴。是的，在这方面我确实感到了极大的乐观。我认为，至少加州人——可能全美各地的人都一样——已经对这种僵局厌烦透顶，以至于他们开始亲自动手，深入了解区划法规范，去参加听证会等等，因为现状实在是无法再维持下去了，无法打破
hopefully it feels like if anything we're getting across in this show I hope it's that the the one correct and true reading of the power broker which is in my in my opinion it's not that he's saying this is the way to build and this is not the way to build, but that every project is a series of choices and decisions, and you have to make those choices and decisions as judiciously as you can based on the best information. And it feels like you could go through that book, Project with Robert Carroll, and you might say, this, they did okay.
长期以来一直陷入的泥潭。这真的非常令人鼓舞，我认为这也表明，真正像你这样阐释这类作品的著作，也能帮助我们
This one, maybe they should do, should have done differently. This one was good. You know, he never says he continues to go back to Jones Beach because clearly he sees Jones Beach as an unalloyed good, maybe not in the way it was managed necessarily, but in its construction.
希望如此。如果说我们在本节目中传递出了什么信息的话，我希望那就是对《权力掮客》唯一正确且真实的解读。在我看来，它并不是在说“这才是建造的方式，这绝不是建造的方式”，而是说每一个项目都是一系列选择和决策，你必须根据掌握的最佳信息，尽自己最大可能明智地做出这些选择和决策。感觉你可以顺着那本书，和罗伯特·卡罗一起审视每一个项目，然后你可能会说：这个，他们做得还可以；
And so the idea that people read it, this huge book, which has so much stuff in it, so much, so many ideas in it. And they come out and they're like, well, bad to do big things. It feels like that's people refusing to pick up what Robert Caro is really saying, which is like, hey, let's not rush things, but let's do them.
这个，也许他们应该……本应该用不同的方式去做；这个很棒。你知道的，他从未说过……他 계속 地回到琼斯海滩（Jones Beach），因为很显然，他将琼斯海滩视为无可挑剔的好事——也许不一定是在管理方式上，而是在其建设本身上。
It's funny, as much as I love this book and it's become the center of my personality for now many, many years at this point, how much I love big plants. Like I love, love big plants. It is not, it's not dissuading me from big plants at all. Big plants are great. I mean, Roman, reading this book, every time they mentioned that elevated expressway
所以，人们读了这本内容如此庞大、包含如此多东西、有如此多思想的巨著，结果得出的结论却是“搞大项目是不对的”，这感觉就像是人们拒绝去领会罗伯特·卡罗真正想表达的意思。他的意思是：嘿，我们不要操之过急，但我们要把事情做成。
through mid Manhattan that would go through buildings, I'm like, that would be bad. Everything about is bad, but you imagine it, you're like, that sounds amazing. It sounds so cool. Knowing it would be terrible, but it still sounds cool. You can't, you can't deny it. Some sort of Jetsons situation where you can just carve
说来也搞笑，尽管我如此热爱这本书，它甚至多年来一直成为我性格的核心，但它丝毫没有减弱我对宏大规划的热爱。我就是爱、就是爱宏大规划。这根本没有让我对宏大规划打消念头。宏大规划太棒了。我的意思是，罗曼，读这本书时，每次他们提到曼哈顿中城那条穿过建筑的高架快速路时，我都觉得：那太糟糕了。
a tunnel right through the Empire State Building. Yeah. It would be fun to see. So one thing I wanna get to is, it strikes me that you have been in a position where you're about to publish something that is going to piss someone off. And I think about this book about to come out and Robert Caro's state of mind. Could you put us in that head space of
虽然它的方方面面都很糟糕，但当你想象它时，你会想：听起来太棒了。听起来太酷了。明知它会是一场灾难，但听起来还是很酷。你无法否认这一点。就像某种《杰森一家》（Jetsons）里的未来场景，你可以直接在帝国大厦中间凿出一条隧道。是的。那一定会很有趣。所以我想讨论的一点是：我注意到，你曾处于这样一种境地——即将发表一件肯定会惹恼某些人的作品。而我在想到即将出版的这本书以及罗伯特·卡罗当时的心态时，你能带我们进入那种心理状态吗？
you're about to put out your reporting, you are confident in it, but you're always nervous that you're going to get little bits wrong. It's going to make people mad. They're very, very powerful that have a lot of money. What does that feel like right before you publish it? Sheer terror. I think when you've done your best to report something out and, you know, it would be very different manner in which Kara reporting over many years and going back to
也就是你即将发表你的调查报道，你对它充满信心，但你总是会担心自己会弄错一些小细节，而这会惹恼那些非常有权势、拥有很多钱的人。在即将发表之前，那种感觉是怎样的？纯粹的恐惧。我认为，当你已经尽最大努力去完成一项调查报道时……你知道的，卡罗多年来的调查方式完全不同，他曾多次找到
Moses many times and at some point Moses cut him off, of course, but like, you know, has the questions you're like, okay, this is your last chance. Like these are my last questions. I still don't, you know, still didn't get an answer. And to really do that early and often and to make sure that you kind of go back at the end, particularly in a long involved project and give people that space and real deadlines. But you know, it is terrifying and also you could have everything right and people, you know, will of course, disingenuously describe your reporting or maybe really just not see your point of view at all about it.
摩西，当然，到某个时候摩西把他给切断了，但你知道的，他会提出一些问题，让你觉得：“好吧，这是你最后的机会了。这些是我最后的几个问题。我依然没有……依然没有得到回答。”及早、经常地这样做，并在最后确保你再次核实，特别是在一个漫长而复杂的项目中，给人们留下空间和真实的截止日期。但你知道的，这确实令人感到恐惧。而且，就算你把所有事情都做对了，人们当然也会恶意歪曲你的报道，或者根本完全看不到你关于此事的观点。
So it's not like you're ever going to get the people that you're reporting critically on to agree with you. That said, we often have people say, all right, this was, you know, I didn't like it, but it was fair. Yeah. And, you know, I think that that's what you hope for when you can get it for sure. Yeah, yeah. You know, when I think about this book,
所以，你永远不可能让那些成为你批评对象的报道主体来赞同你。话虽如此，我们经常会听到人们说：“好吧，这篇报道……我虽然不喜欢它，但它是公平的。”是的。而且，你知道的，我认为当你能做到这一点时，这就是你所能期望的最好结果了。是的，是的。你知道，每当我想到这本书，
I think of how important it is to explain in New York an important biography of a person. And Kero has admitted we probably wouldn't think about Robert Moses at all if it weren't for his book. So he's both presented them and changed people's minds about him. But it makes me wonder, if you were to write your power broker, if I were to write my power broker, are there a thousand more books like this to write? Is this kind of a singular there a thousand more books like this to write? Is this kind of a singular like subject and style and achievement? Or if you dig deep enough, are there equally profound and interesting biographies out there for cities all over the world?
我就会想到在纽约解释一个重要人物的传记是多么重要。卡罗也承认，如果没有他的这本书，我们大概根本不会去想罗伯特·摩西这个人。所以他既呈现了摩西，又改变了人们对他的看法。但这让我不禁好奇：如果你要写你的《权力掮客》，如果我要写我的《权力掮客》，这个世界上还有成千上万本这样的书等着去写吗？这究竟是一种绝无仅有的独特题材、文风和成就？还是说，只要你挖掘得够深，世界各地的城市中其实都存在同样深刻且有趣的传记等待发掘？
There's at least one of Lyndon Johnson. Well, that's kind of it. It's like the things those two things have in common, it's caro. But maybe there's way more people that explain the 20th century in their own ways. I don't know. I honestly don't know the answer to this question. I think that there are, if you have the right, the sort of serendipity of the right reporter and project with the
至少还有一本关于林登·约翰逊的传记。嗯，差不多就是这样。这两本书共同拥有的东西，就是卡罗本人。不过也许还有更多的人，正以他们自己的方式诠释着20世纪。我不知道。说实话，我真的不知道这个问题的答案。我认为，如果你拥有正确的、
right subject. I mean, I'm thinking of a book that I thought was a truly excellent biography, George Packer's biography of Richard Holbrook was called Our Man. And I, you know, I had studied like Vietnam a little bit in college and whatever, but that was a book that in a similar and a much shorter, even though it also was a door stopper, just sort of makes you feel like, my God, this person was at the nexus of everything
恰到好处的机缘巧合，让合适的记者和合适的项目与合适的题材相结合，是有可能的。我的意思是，我想起了一本我认为堪称真正卓越传记的书——乔治·帕克（George Packer）所著的理查德·霍尔布鲁克（Richard Holbrooke）传记《我们的人》（Our Man）。我呢，你知道的，在大学时稍微学过一点关于越南战争的历史之类的东西，但那本书以一种类似但篇幅短得多（尽管它也是一块厚重的“门挡书”）的方式，让你由衷地感到：天哪，这个人曾经处于所有事件的核心枢纽，
and I had never really thought about them at all and now I kind of see the world in a different way. Obviously he's a great writer, but I do think that the works out there are possible, that the sort of time and even if you have a writer that's predisposed to spend years and years and years on one subject, which a lot of people, that would not be a healthy decision for them. But again, back to the support, just like how many people are going to get that level of institutional support or, you know, have, you know, maybe they're independently wealthy or
而我以前却从未真正关注过他，现在我以一种全然不同的方式看待世界了。当然他是一位伟大的作家，但我确实认为这样的作品是有可能实现的，只要有那样的时间，或者哪怕你遇到了一位注定愿意花上好几年时间去研究一个单一主题的作家——尽管对许多人来说，这可能并不是一个健康的决定。但话又说回来，还是要回到支持力度的问题上，就像：究竟有多少人能够获得那种级别的体制支持，或者……你知道的，也许他们本身就拥有独立的财富。
whatever it is, and they can just plug away at a book for, you know, seven years in the case of this one. And, you know, the LBJ stuff is what, like another 40 or something, we're on 40 years now. And that's just, you know, that's just, that's incredibly rare. I think in order to do the rest of the lives justice that you need to explain the world, you need this kind of like Borgesian library where there's a biography of every single person who's ever lived that has been given the treatment that Robert Carroll was able to give to Robert Moses because everyone is the nexus of everything in their own lives. And it's just like that the power broker is like like this it's like a little portal into what that
不管是什么，他们都可以专注于一本书，你知道的，就这个项目而言甚至写了七年。而且，你知道的，关于林登·约翰逊的内容又花了大概40年左右，我们现在已经写了40年了。这在你知道的情况下，真的极其罕见。我认为，为了公正地对待他们人生的其余部分，你需要解释这个世界，你需要这种类似于博尔赫斯图书馆的东西，在那里有关于曾经活过的每一个人的传记，都得到了罗伯特·卡罗能够给予罗伯特·摩西的这种待遇，因为每个人都是他们自己生活中心的一切。这就像《权力掮客》一样，它就像通往那个
library would be like but unfortunately it's beautifully impossible Roman unfortunately. Well that that can't think that's kind of my point like is there a power broker to be written about a lot I mean obviously there's some people that don't have as much influence in the world as this but there probably is more than we think because I didn't you know, we wouldn't know of this one if it wasn't for this book. And so I'm just, it makes me think that there's just a world out there to investigate and explore in a way that gets me kind of excited, you know, like I like that idea, you know. I mean, the other thing I think, Elliot, you and I talked about it a little bit before Roman came on, but this sort of the one, you know, and I mean, maybe somebody should get
图书馆的小小入口，但不幸的是，它美得不可能实现，罗曼。好吧，那——我倒不觉得，这正是我的观点，就像——难道还有很多关于权力掮客的故事可以写吗？我的意思是，显而易见，有些人对世界的影响没有这么大，但可能比我们想象的要多，因为如果不是因为这本书，我们根本不会知道这个人的故事。所以我在想，外面还有一个广阔的世界等待我们去调查和探索，这让我觉得有点兴奋，你知道的，我很喜欢这个想法，你知道的。我的意思是，还有一件事，埃利奥特，在你加入之前，我和你稍微讨论过，就是这个……你知道的，也许有人应该着手
around to doing this project, but the sort of examining the climate impact from what Moses and the Moses imitators or contemporaries did, you know, it's the it's super enraging to be like, why can't I get to the airport via the subway? Or like, why does it take three hours when it should take an hour to get out to wherever in Long Island? But then when you sort of sit back and you realize, my God, you know, just the lack of a good railway system on Long Island, the lack of certain things that have really became obvious even at the time, but not with the
去做这个项目，那就是审视摩西以及摩西的模仿者或同时代人所造成的气候影响，你知道的，这真的超级让人恼火，为什么我不能坐地铁去机场？或者为什么去长岛的某个地方本该花一个小时，却要花三个小时？但当你静下心来，意识到天哪，你知道的，仅仅是长岛缺乏一个良好的铁路系统，缺乏一些甚至在当时就已经变得显而易见的东西，但却没有
same vocabulary because of course they weren't worried about CO2 that was stuff locked deep in the memorandum of ExxonMobil and wherever. Nobody else kind of understood that or was talking about it, but they did start to understand the traffic and the more tangible pollution part of it. And that's the part that just enrages me. Yeah, and even more than wanting to see his work on Jane Jacobs, that feels like the missing piece. I had not thought about it too much until you had mentioned it before we started the interview,
相同的词汇，因为他们当然不担心二氧化碳，那些东西都被深深锁在埃克森美孚和其他地方的备忘录里。没有其他人真正理解这一点或者谈论它，但他们确实开始理解交通以及其中更具体的污染部分。这才是真正激怒我的部分。是的，甚至比看到他对简·雅各布斯的评价更甚，那感觉就像是缺失的一环。在我们开始采访之前你提到它之前，我并没有想太多，
but exactly the idea that he's so focused on the effect of the people in an area where this road exists, where people have to use this road. And now we know that the emphasis on cars affects billions of people that are not even living near the road, who have nothing to do with that road. And it's such an amazingly massive scale compared to what Kara was talking about in this book. That being said, when you live in New York, it's pretty inconvenient to get to the airport. You know, let's not forget about that. No, it's one of its least attractive features.
但确实，他的重点如此集中在道路存在这个区域内人们的影响上，人们必须使用这条路。而现在我们知道，对汽车的强调影响了数十亿甚至不住在路边、与这条路毫无关系的人。与卡罗在这本书中谈到的相比，这是一个极其巨大的规模。话虽如此，当你住在纽约时，去机场确实很不方便。你知道的，我们别忘了这一点。不，这是它最不吸引人的特征之一。
It's how hard it is to get to the airport. It's not really his to do, but like I do wish somebody could do it. It's a really good question. There could be just a Moses report that's just like this person is responsible to this many metric tons of CO2. I mean, in our atmosphere, it strikes me as a doable or at least a teachable metric to come up with. Yeah, sort of back of the napkin way. Yeah. Yeah. And I'm just, since I have
去机场有多难。这其实不是他该做的事，但我确实希望有人能做到。这真的是个很好的问题。完全可以有一份摩西报告，内容就像是这个人要对这么多公吨的二氧化碳负责。我的意思是，在我们的大气层中，这让我觉得是一个可行或者至少是可教的量化指标。是的，有点像是随手估算的方式。是的。是的。而且我只是，既然我有
you guys in the, I'm also curious, do you guys think that he directly influenced tons of projects and planners elsewhere in the country? This book is so, we know that he goes out there and he brings them in and he has them to Jones Beach and Guy Lombardo plays and all this stuff, but what part of this was really he was the stone thrown in the pond and the ripples go out from him versus LA was turned out that saw the trolley system and the Eisenhower Express out from him versus, you know, LA was tearing out the stop trolley system and the Eisenhower Expressway project was underway. But that part, I feel like,
你们二位在，我也很好奇，你们觉得他是否直接影响了国内其他地方的大量项目和规划师？这本书太……我们知道他走出去把他们带进来，让他们去琼斯海滩听盖伊·隆巴多演奏等等，但这里面有多少真正源于他是投入池塘的石头、涟漪由他向外扩散，而洛杉矶拆除有轨电车系统和艾森豪威尔高速公路项目正在推进，相比之下……但那部分，我觉得，
Caro had not, at least so far in my reading, had not kind of gotten to yet. Yeah, and he doesn't get to it. And I think this is one of the mistakes people, when they criticize the book, they talk about how, well, this was happening everywhere, Robert Moses wasn't all that important. And I think that what Robert Moses was great at
卡罗还没有，至少在我目前的阅读中，还没有写到那里。是的，他没有写到。我认为人们在批评这本书时犯的一个错误是，他们谈到，好吧，这种事到处都在发生，罗伯特·摩西并不是那么重要。我認為罗伯特·摩西最厉害的地方
was being at the lead of the popular sentiment that was already happening. So he was an effective warrior in this idea of complete mobility, freedom through cars, and the interstate system. And it was out there, but he was truly effective and pushed it. And when he was successful at generating money and generating his own projects and them all building on each other, that also was an example that people followed. So I think it's a little bit of both.
在于他走在了已经形成的民意浪潮的最前沿。因此，他是这种全面流动性理念的有效斗士，通过汽车和州际公路系统实现自由。这种思潮当时就在那里，但他确实非常有效并大力推行。当他在创造资金和自己的项目、让它们相互叠加方面取得成功时，这也成为了人们效仿的榜样。所以我认为两者兼而有之。
And again, this gets to one of the criticism in the book that I kind of bristle against is people try to take it down but they go, well, it doesn't explain LA. I was like, well, it wasn't trying to explain LA. Yeah, LA's, New York is in the subtitle. Like, come on. Yeah. Or the criticism that says, it's 50 years,
再说一次，这涉及到了书中我有些反感的批评之一，人们试图否定它，但他们却说，嗯，它没有解释洛杉矶。我就想，好吧，它本来就不是为了解释洛杉矶。是的，洛杉矶的……纽约就在副标题里。拜托。或者那种批评说，已经50年了，
and New York has bounced back. How does he explain that? And it's like, well, it's been 50 years. Like, it's half a century. I hope New York has bounced. I hope that the greatest city in America and the world has bounced back, you know? Yeah, so I think it was a little bit of both,
纽约已经恢复过来了。他怎么解释这一点？这就好比，嗯，已经50年了。就像，半个世纪了。我希望纽约已经恢复了。我希望美国和世界上最伟大的城市已经恢复了，你知道的？是的，所以我认为两者兼而有之，
but he was definitely like,, he exported like his, his self, you know, he went to other other cities, people came to study it. Um, and, you know, and he had the legacy in the ear of like the agenda setting people in the federal government who were like putting all this money into highways, you know, and he just tapped into it. Like he just had a way of just being a little bit ahead of everyone else, but knowing where it was all going so that he had very little friction. It feels unfair that sometimes a criticism the book gets is, yeah, but it doesn't explain everything.
但他绝对就像……他输出了他的，他自己，你知道的，他去了其他城市，人们来研究它。嗯，你知道的，他在联邦政府中那些负责制定议程的人那里有着遗产和影响力，他们把所有的钱都投入到高速公路中，你知道的，而他只是顺应了这一点。他只是有一种方式，比其他人领先一点点，但又清楚这一切将走向何方，所以他的阻力非常小。有时候人们对这本书的批评是“对，但它并没有解释一切”，这让人感觉很不公平。
And I guess it's the risk you run when you create an amazing, enormous book is that people want to find everything in it and have it easily explain everything. But But sometimes you got to read a second book. Yeah. You can't just rely on the one book. And you know, and everyone should and no one's saying that you should only read the power broker. No one's ever said that. Yeah. You know. But I think that's like it goes right down to again, like its title. It's like it is not the city builder. It is not the master builder. It is the power broker. He wasn't trying to explain all cities. And in a way, he wasn't necessarily trying to explain everything about New York City,
我想当你创作了一本宏大惊人的书时，你就要承担这种风险，那就是人们希望在其中找到所有东西，并希望它能轻易解释一切。但是，有时候你得读第二本书。是的。你不能只靠一本书。而且你知道的，每个人都应该……也没有人说你只能读《权力掮客》。从来没人这么说过。是的。你知道。但我认为这直接回到了它的标题。就像它不是城市建设者。它不是总建筑师。它是权力掮客。他并没有试图解释所有的城市。在某种程度上，他也不一定试图解释关于纽约市的一切，
even though people have taken it on as the perfect, the history of a city. He was really focusing on a human and the effects of this human and what he got out of it, even though he wasn't a quote unquote corrupt in the way that we normally think of. And that's his focus. What other people try to imbue into the text
尽管人们把它当作完美的城市历史来接受。他真正关注的是一个人，这个人所产生的影响以及他从中得到了什么，尽管他并不是我们通常认为的那种“腐败”。这就是他的重点。其他人试图灌输到文本中的内容
is kind of their own problem. But when I find criticisms, mostly it's those things that are these distal things that people have created around the book than the book itself. Right, it's a mistake to think the story here is just how did he make the atlas of New York look different when it's really like how did he sort of gather and exploit power in a way that had not been documented on this scale. Absolutely.
基本上是他们自己的问题。但当我发现批评时，大多是那些围绕这本书产生的外围事物，而不是书本身。没错，认为这里的故事仅仅是“他是如何让纽约的地图看起来不同”是个错误，而真正的故事其实是“他是如何以一种前所未闻的规模聚集和滥用权力的”。绝对是的。
But a credit in its own way to Moses, you know, sheer force and power to do all that. But then to Caro to showing it and really explaining how this has a material impact on everyday people both then and now. Yeah, that was Caro's mission. And to me, you know, he fulfilled it and then some. I don't think he was even trying to explain everything about New York City. He clearly thought there was something more to say when he was gonna do a LaGuardia biography, for example,
但这本身也是对摩西的一种肯定，你知道的，他拥有完成这一切的纯粹力量和权力。但卡罗将其展示出来，并真正解释了这对当时和现在的普通人产生了怎样的实质性影响。是的，那是卡罗的使命。对我而言，你知道的，他超额完成了任务。我不认为他甚至试图解释关于纽约市的一切。很明显，当他打算写一本关于拉瓜迪亚的传记时，他觉得还有更多的话要说，例如，
or something else. Like there's definitely more to say even about New York. He doesn't even try to say everything about Robert Moses. He barely talks about that power dam that he built at Niagara. Exactly, exactly. Which is by any, shouldn't be the biggest term. He has a sister.
或者别的什么。关于纽约，绝对还有更多的话要说。他甚至没有试图讲述关于罗伯特·摩西的一切。他几乎没有提到他在尼亚加拉建造的那个发电大坝。没错，没错。这在任何情况下都不应该是最大的术语。他有一个妹妹。
Yeah, children. Children. That's right, that's right. Well, Clara Jeffery, thank you so much for being on the 99% visible breakdown of The Power Broker. It was a real pleasure to have you. Well, thank you so much. I just wanna say again, what a fan I am of your show
是的，还有孩子。孩子们。没错，没错。好吧，克拉拉·杰弗里，非常感谢你来到《99%隐形》对《权力掮客》的深度剖析。很高兴能邀请到你。非常感谢。我只想再次表达，我是多么喜欢你们的节目，
and also that I got my mom to start reading The Power Broker and she's already caught up to where we are. I only talked to her about it a few weeks ago about this and she's 86 caught up to where we are. You know, I only talked to her about a few weeks ago about this and she's 86. She's getting through it. Mom's a beast, man. She's like, she's a big reader. She's a big reader. So, well, it's a real pleasure to have you.
而且我还让我妈妈开始读《权力掮客》，她已经读到我们现在的进度了。我几周前才跟她聊起这个，她已经86岁了，却赶上了我们的进度。你知道的，我几周前才跟她聊起这个，她86岁了。她正在把它读完。妈妈太牛了，天哪。她是个狂热的读者。她是个狂热的读者。所以，很高兴能邀请到你。
Thanks so much for having me on. Next month, we continue our journey through part seven, the final part of the book, The Loss of Power. We'll be covering chapters 42 through 46. That's pages 984 through 1,081. That's right, we're crossing the 1,000 page mark. We did it, quadruple digits of pages. And we couldn't have done it without you. Now, if you can't wait that long
非常感谢邀请我来。下个月，我们将继续我们的旅程，进入第七部分，也就是本书的最后一部分——权力的丧失。我们将涵盖第42到第46章。也就是第984页到第1081页。没错，我们要跨过1000页的门槛了。我们做到了，四位数的页码。如果没有你们，我们是不可能完成的。现在，如果你等不了那么久
to hear me summarize something, then I direct you over to the Flophouse podcast on the Maximum Fund Network. That is my bad movie podcast, which is a lot less informative than this one, but it does have roughly the same amount of me talking during it. I cannot believe we have only two episodes left.
来听我总结某些东西，那我建议你去Maximum Fun网络收听Flophouse播客。那是我的烂片播客，它的信息量比这个少得多，但我在里面说话的时量大致是一样的。我真不敢相信我们只剩下两集了。
So make sure to commemorate this incredible journey that we've all taken together this year with some 99PI Power Broker merch. We've got t-shirts, we've got bags, we've got bookmarks. Head over to 99PI.org slash store to get yours. The 99% Invisible Breakdown of the Power Broker is produced by Isabel Angel, edited by Comiti, music by Swan Real, mixed by Dara Hirsch. 99% Invisible's executive producer is Cathy Tu, our senior editor is Delaney Hall, Kurt Kolstad is the digital director.
所以请务必购买一些99PI《权力掮客》周边，来纪念我们今年共同经历的这段不可思议的旅程。我们有T恤、有包、有书签。前往 99PI.org 斜杠 store 获取你的周边。《99%隐形》对《权力掮客》的深度剖析由伊莎贝尔·安杰尔制作，科米蒂剪辑，音乐由斯万·雷尔创作，达拉·希尔什混音。《99%隐形》的执行制片人是凯茜·图，我们的资深编辑是德兰妮·霍尔，库尔特·科尔斯塔德是数字总监。
The rest of the team includes Chris Berube, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Gabriella Gladney, Martin Gonzalez, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Ley, Lashma Dawn, Jacob Maldonado-Medina, Kelly Prime, Joe Rosenberg, Nina Potuck, and me, Roman Mars. The 9% Invisible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. The art for this series was created by Aaron Nestor. We are part of the Stitcher and SiriusXM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building in beautiful Uptown, Oakland, Californiaia you can find the show on all the usual social
团队其他成员包括克里斯·贝鲁比、杰森·德莱昂、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、加布里埃拉·格拉德尼、马丁·冈萨雷斯、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、薇薇安·莱、拉什玛·唐、雅各布·马尔多纳多-梅迪纳、凯利·普莱姆、乔·罗森伯格、妮娜·波图克，还有我，罗曼·马尔斯。《99%隐形》的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作。该系列的艺术作品由亚伦·内斯特创作。我们是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客大家庭的一员，现在总部位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的上城区潘多拉大厦向北六个街区。你可以在所有常见的社交
media sites as well as our own discord server where we have fun discussions about the power broker and architecture and movies and music and all that kind of good stuff it's where i'm hanging out most these days you can find a link to that discord server as well as every past episode of 99 pi at 99 pi.org episode of 99 PI at 99 PI.org. Um, what's the word I'm looking for? It's open. It's not the one I'm talking about. Hold on a second.
媒体网站以及我们自己的Discord服务器上找到这个节目，我们在那里就权力掮客、建筑、电影、音乐以及所有这些好东西进行有趣的讨论，这也是我最近经常闲逛的地方。你可以在 99pi.org 找到指向该Discord服务器的链接以及 99 pi 的每一期过往节目。在 99 pi.org。嗯，我用的这个词是什么来着？它是开放的。不是我正在说的那个。等一下。
Uh, again, I can't think of the word I'm looking for. That's fine. Uh, is about keep all this. This is all gold. Me trying to struggling to find this word. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
嗯，再次声明，我想不起来我要找的那个词了。没关系。嗯，伊莎贝尔，把这些都留着。这些都是宝贝。我努力挣扎着想找到这个词。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。